Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Sag mal zurück, in Deutschland?
Ja.
Was hast du in der Schweiz gemacht?
Ich habe in der Schweiz eine Veranstaltung gemacht und zwar in Basel im Unternehmen Mitte. Das ist so ein Kulturzentrum. Und da gab es abends ein Gespräch mit mir. Was ist Ideologie? Und das Interessante ist aber, die Schweiz ist eine andere Welt. Wenn wir auf die Corona-Politik blicken. Wie soll ich das beschreiben? Man fährt mit der FFP2-Maske im ICE dahin, steigt dann aus und merkt schon, oh, hier tragen fast gar keine Leute Maske. Dann werde ich vom Veranstalter abgeholt und fragt nach. Und sagt er, ja, in Geschäften und so, trägt man keine Maske mehr. Und dann gehen wir zu diesem Veranstaltungsort. Und das ist eigentlich für 60 Leute bestuhlt. Aber es kommen dann sehr viel mehr. Und es wird immer enger und enger. Und dann heißt es immer, wir müssen jetzt noch mal zusammenrücken. Ich will es nicht übertreiben, aber zum Teil wurden die Leute gestapelt. Und in der Schweiz ist nicht 2G, 2G plus und diese ganzen Sachen. Und alle haben die Masken aus. Und danach sind auch dann viele gekommen, haben sich das Buch signieren lassen oder so. Und da ist keine ist nicht mehr diese Distanz. Und ich fand das sehr schön, weil ich dann sagte zu Leuten, die da standen, ja, für mich als Deutscher ist es jetzt erst noch ein bisschen schwierig, mich da umzugewöhnen. Und dann guckt mich ein junger Schweizer an und sagt, ja, haben sie immer noch Angst vor Corona? Und ich dachte dann, nee, eigentlich nicht. Und das war ja doch eine sehr, sehr gute Erfahrung, da jetzt reingeworfen zu werden. Denn jetzt kann ich ja hier auch sagen, sind alle Schweizer verrückt? Aber da muss ich auch sagen, ja, und die Niederländer und die und die und die und die, also eigentlich unsere ganzen Nachbarländer. Und man relativiert dann, und das ist ja eigentlich der Sinn einer Reise, man relativiert den eigenen Standpunkt und relativiert nochmal insbesondere Karl Lauterbach.
Wenn man dieses Argument zugrunde legt, dann kann man natürlich sagen, es gibt vielleicht bei den Russen so etwas wie Eingreisungsobsessionen. Das wird man annehmen können. Und das kann man auch nicht widerlegen, indem man sagt, die NATO hat euch aber doch gar nicht tatsächlich eingekreist. Wenn man sich eingekreist empfindet, dann agiert man eben so, als sei man eingekreist. Aber wenn man dieses Argument ernst nimmt, dann war es vielleicht zu ganz anderen Zeitpunkten akut, aber in der gegenwärtigen Situation überhaupt nicht, wo sich die USA wesentlich auf China konzentriert haben. Der Spalt zwischen den Europäern und den Amerikanern in der NATO war in jeder Hinsicht sichtbar. Und die Europäer haben mit sich selber beschäftigt.
Du hast es eben auch gesagt, wir sind an einem Punkt gewesen, wo man schon sehr laut darüber nachdachte, brauchen wir diese NATO noch? Nicht im Sinne von, wir treten jetzt aus der NATO aus. Aber die gibt es da irgendwie. Aber schon Macron sagt, die ist hirntot. Auch die, die für die NATO sich sehr stark wortreich stark gemacht haben, haben wir eigentlich auch nichts mehr Entscheidendes geliefert. Also es gab ja dann mal jetzt so ein Schuldbekenntnis von AKK, wir hätten da mal irgendwas, aber was, weiß sie glaube ich selbst nicht. Und jetzt haben wir aber die NATO wieder da. Aber eigentlich ist jetzt gar nicht der Zeitpunkt gewesen, ist mir eine klasse Argumentation, dass Putin sagen kann, jetzt muss ich aber dringend, denn sonst. Interessanterweise jetzt gar nicht, weil China ansteht. Alle sind auch noch irgendwie mit der Pandemie beschäftigt. Und naja, also Putin hätte es ja auch umgekehrt machen können, wenn China sich jetzt wirklich auch noch das eine oder andere einverleiht, weil die sagen, ja, wir haben hier nochmal in den Verträgen nachgeguckt, das ist ja eigentlich so und so, uns gehört noch viel mehr. Und damit ist ja vielleicht jetzt zu rechnen, dass sie sich das hier angucken, klappt das? Und dann sagt man, naja, wie ist denn das eigentlich mit diesen Sonderzonen da?
Ja, also wenn es so Beziehungen gäbe zu Russland, dass man da einfach hinflöger, und dann würde man so ein Interview mit Putin, könnte man durchaus fragen, haben sie die NATO so vermisst? Warum ist ihnen die NATO noch wichtiger als selbst den amerikanischen Präsidenten?
So, Münkler sagt jetzt, also er hält ja die Ukraine für verloren. Das hat er auch derzeit ja so mitgeteilt. Und er bringt jetzt nochmal einen Begriff ins Spiel, den wir jetzt auch in den vergangenen Tagen häufiger lesen konnten, nämlich von der Finlandisierung war die Rede.
Also ehrlich gesagt nicht aus der Sicht des heutigen Tages. Und von daher, die Entscheidungen der letzten Wochen evaluierend, wäre es fair gewesen, den Ukrainern zu sagen, ihr geht ein hohes Risiko, wenn ihr nicht bereit seid, die Finlandisierung hinzunehmen. Denn wir sind nicht bereit, eine gegebenenfalls nukleare Eskalation gegenüber Russland in der Verteidigung eurer Selbstbestimmung hinzunehmen. Das hat man nicht gesagt.
Ja, hat man nicht gesagt. Wir haben das lange Zeit als, ja, das hat man übersehen, man hat das nicht ernst genug genommen oder so. Wir hören nachher ja die O-Töne aus dem Bundestag gestern. Und wir können uns auch jetzt schon mal fragen, macht es den westlichen Politikern gerade Spaß? Einerseits diesen Primat der Politik zu erleben, diese Art von Hyperpolitik, alle wissen, was zu tun ist. Und dann auch wirklich mal diesen Instrumentenkasten, der vorher nur so theoretisch irgendwelche Ökonomen haben, also Ideen und schreiben irgendwas auf. Und jetzt wird das aber echt alles angewandt. Und wir haben ja damals auch Thomas de Maizière hier verabschiedet, indem wir uns noch mal seine Clips bei Markus Lanz angehört haben, wo er meinte, Politik macht schon Spaß. Und sie muss insbesondere Spaß machen, wenn Krisen zu bewältigen sind. Diese Freude an der Krise soll man auch annehmen. Und das erleben wir ja auch gerade bei Christian Lindner zum Beispiel, dass er da sehr viel Freude hat, jetzt gerade Finanzminister zu sein.
Aber die Finlandisierung ist ja eigentlich die Idee. Man schafft da einen Staat, der neutral bleibt, beziehungsweise eigentlich ein Vasaillen-Staat wird für Russland. Also Russland hat eigentlich die Oberhand und setzt da auch dann die Führer jeweils ein. Aber sonst ist man nicht direkt einverleibt. Man bleibt noch so als Staat, kann aber natürlich dann nicht in so Bündnisse wie NATO oder so eintreten und ist dann auf Dauer da ziemlich kalt gestellt, lebt aber in der Sicherheit, dass es keinen Einmarsch gibt, weil man ja schon quasi assoziiert ist.
Aber damit hätte man, wenn man das akzeptieren würde als Vorschlag, als Programm, hätte man den westlichen Politikern ihre Krisenfreude genommen, weil damit wäre das dann einfach erledigt und man hätte kein Zeichen gegen China gesetzt. Die Jungen wollen es auch nicht.
Die wollen es auch nicht. Es gibt jetzt, wir bleiben mal bei dieser Argumentation. Also das Problem ist ja jetzt, wir haben diese unglaubliche Aufrüstungspaket, das ich sehr, sehr kritisch sehe, dass man 100 Milliarden ausgibt und dieses NATO-Zwei-Prozent-Ziel überfüllt. Also man gibt dann etwa 70 Milliarden im Jahr fürs Militär aus. Und wir leben aber eigentlich in einer anderen Gesellschaft. Und das ist ja die große Mönkler-These, die er hier natürlich auch noch einmal anbringt.
Ich habe einige Male Kurse in Berlin für Leute aus der mittleren Ebene der ukrainischen Verwaltung zu geben gehabt. Und ich glaube, oder für mich war das eine Frage der Ehrlichkeit, denen zu sagen, ihr müsst davon ausgehen, dass im Ernstfall für die Europäer Russland wichtiger ist als die Ukraine. Und ihr müsst davon ausgehen, dass die Europäer als posteroische Gesellschaften nicht bereit sein werden, die Ukraine zu verteidigen.
So, jetzt klingt das erst noch so, als würde er jetzt sagen, uns ist Russland wichtig, uns ist die Ukraine egal, jetzt sehen wir gerade das Gegenteil. Aber wir sagen auch nicht Folgendes, und das ist ja dann die zweite Argumentation, wir sind jetzt wieder eine heroische Gesellschaft. Das würde tatsächlich bedeuten, und das ist nicht die Diskussion, die jetzt gerne so getan wird, wir könnten jetzt gar nicht, unsere Soldaten könnten nicht, weil die Maschinengewehre nicht ordentlich schließen oder so, wir würden nicht gehen. Also du, und ich halte es für einen zivilisatorischen Fortschritt, wir gehen nicht mehr, wir werden nicht mehr eine heroische Gesellschaft und sagen, toll, ihr jungen Männer und Frauen, bewaffnet euch, wir kämpfen dafür die gute Sache oder gegen den Feind, das ist nicht mehr da, deswegen sagt er ja auch immer gern mit Hegel, das Wesen des Kriegers ist seine Waffe. Und unser Kriegerwesen ist heute eines, das sagt, können wir das von zu Hause aus machen?
Genau.
Und das ist der Drohnenkrieg zum Beispiel.
Ja, ich würde hier sagen, Münkler, du hast ja jetzt gesagt, wir sehen ja genau das Gegenteil. Wir sagen ja nicht, uns ist Russland wichtiger als die Ukraine, wir opfern die Ukraine, damit wir mit Russland beide irgendwelche...
Aber wir würden uns auch nicht opfern für die Ukraine.
So, und das ist nämlich der Punkt. Wir sind gerade in einem Krieg mit Russland, nur wir führen ihn weder mit Waffen noch mit Soldaten. Und das ist bei Münkler noch nicht eingepreist. Das findet in seinem Bild noch gar nicht statt, dass der Krieg gerade von irgendwelchen EZB-Bankern in dem Homeoffice geführt wird, die dann einfach sagen, so, jetzt schicke ich mal.
Okay, aber dann müsste man ja wirklich das Konsequent haben, was soll dann diese Veranstaltung da am Sonntag mit 100 Milliarden mehr? Ich glaube, da haben sich einfach ein paar Kapitalfraktionen durchgesetzt. Ich habe mir mal die Aktie angesehen von Rheinmetall. Die hat in den letzten sechs Monaten jedenfalls einen Anstieg von 30 Prozent erlebt. Und raten wir mal, wann es besonders stark nach oben ging. Das waren dann so in den vergangenen Tagen.
Also 100 Milliarden für die Bundeswehr. Du hast ja eben schon gesagt, 100 Milliarden fürs Militär. Da würde ich ja sagen, mal abwarten und genau gucken, sind diese 100 Milliarden für die deutsche Bundeswehr oder für die Bündnisfähigkeit Deutschlands? Das würde ja was anderes bedeuten. Wenn das Geld wirklich nur, wie es gestern auch so durchschimmerte und auch als Tenor sozusagen ins Plenum gesagt wurde, in die Bundeswehr geht, dann ist das natürlich irgendwie verschwendetes Geld. Denn die Bundeswehr hat enorme Zuwächse in ihrem Haushalt gehabt, so wie jedes Bundesministerium.
Und wie auch jedes andere europäische Land im Militäretat.
Also an Geld mangels dann nicht. Die Frage ist nur, was soll man jetzt machen? Deutschland wird nicht so angegriffen irgendwann mal oder bedroht, dass wirklich ein Panzer irgendwie noch hilft.
Naja, ich bin mir zum Teil nicht mehr sicher. Ich war zum Beispiel verwundert, dass jemand, das sind ja linksliberale Medienleutchen wie Jan Böhmermann, dann auch mal twittern, wir müssen noch mal über die Wehrpflicht nachdenken. Jetzt auch so ein Polenz schreibt das auch.
Never.
Und da würde ich sagen...
Wird nie passieren. Niemand brauchte Angst vorhaben.
Also ich bin mir, nach dem, was ich da gestern erlebt habe und wie einhellig das war und dass man dann noch mal zum Teil von Grünen- und SPD-Politikern bei Twitter-Gemaßräge wird, die sagen, ja, wir nehmen ja dafür Schulden auf und so. Da würde ich denen auch mal ganz klar sagen wollen, ihr nehmt da Schulden auf. Bitte, ich weiß schon, wie das mit dem Geld dann da funktioniert. Also wenn jetzt so getan wird, als müsste man da irgendwie noch mal querfinanzieren und umlegen und sonst was. Also ich will das nur mal sagen. Wir haben jetzt da gerade mit Böhmermann einigen anderen Leuten Leute, die auf dieser Zero-Covid-Welle sind, die jetzt alles dafür tun würden, damit die Kinder niemals einen Schnupfen bekommen, um es mal ganz polemisch zu sagen. Aber ins Manöver schickt man die dann noch. Also ich bin sehr skeptisch, ob wir wirklich auf Dauer da nicht eine ganz ungute Diskussion bekommen. Denn gestern, es war nämlich so, wir haben 100 Milliarden. Diese 100 Milliarden, wir haben jetzt eine akute Bedrohung. Wenn mir jetzt jemand die Waffe an den Kopf fällt, dann kann ich nicht sagen, Moment, ich besorge mir auch eine und mache einen Waffenschein und dann treffen wir uns wieder. Also diese 100 Milliarden, die kann man ausgeben oder nicht, aber die ändern hier an dem aktuellen Konflikt nichts und das ist auch nicht irgendein Signal an Putin. Und sagt er ja schön, was die in drei Jahren dann daraus machen, werden wir ja sehen.
Es ist ein bisschen wie bei der Impfpflicht, weißt du noch, als alle meinten, ich muss mich revidieren, ich bin jetzt doch für die Impfpflicht. Ein Monat später will davon schon keiner mehr was wissen und es dauert alles ewig im Bundestag. Und man sagte auch gleich, das ist ja nicht für die aktuelle Bedrohung, da geht es ja um die nächste. Es ist mit der Werbpflicht so, dass wir in Deutschland, und da gibt es die O-Töne von Olaf Scholz, seine letzte Rede als Finanzminister zum Beispiel, wie er im Bundestag saß und sagte, ja hier wegstürzen. Also wir kommen jetzt wirklich in eine demografische Schieflage. Wir müssen nochmal alle Frauen für den Arbeitsmarkt quasi mobilisieren und so weiter. Wir wissen heute, dass 80.000 Lehrer perspektivisch fehlen. Wir reden nachher über das Bauen. Im Handwerk ist eine Katastrophe. Die wissen gar nicht, wer soll hier die Energiewende überhaupt materiell umsetzen? Wer soll die Steine bewegen? Wenn jetzt die Bundeswehr kommt und sagt, wir verzögern jetzt den Berufseinstieg aller 18-Jährigen um ein Jahr, dann steht Deutschland Kopf. Diese Diskussion wird jetzt irgendwie geführt. Es sind auch sehr viele symbolische Diskussionen. Ich würde sagen, die 100 Milliarden für die Bundeswehr ist auch nur eine rein symbolische Sache.
Also würdest du auch am Ende Virtuose-Signale legen.
Das ist absolut Banane. Das wird nicht passieren. Dafür drückt die Demografie zu hart. Das ist völlig ausgeschlossen, dass jetzt jemand nochmal Leute für einen Biwak und so weiter und ein bisschen Gemeinschaft da rauszieht. Diese Angst, klar, die ist da, es wäre auch absolut dumm, das zu machen.
Also wenn hier junge Leute zuhören, lasst euch da nichts einreden. Das ist keine gute Idee.
Nehmt es mit Humor auf und schreibt auf Twitter lustige Tweets dagegen.
Und ihr habt auch lange genug euch jetzt zurückgehalten und so, macht das nicht. Also wenn das hier kommt, gut, mich werden sie nicht einziehen.
Deutschland ist das letzte Land.
Mich werden sie nicht einziehen, mich kann man mit einem nassen Handtuch totschlagen. Und sonst muss ich in die Schweiz. Ich habe mir überhaupt gedacht, so eine Schweizer Staatsbürgerschaft, das wäre es. Man muss, glaube ich, reich sein, entweder.
Superreiche.
Oder heiraten ging auch. Dann kommt man schneller dran zumindest. Wir werden ja auch in der Schweiz ausgestrahlt. Also wer möchte, ich bin noch zu haben, einfach mal eine E-Mail schreiben. Wir bleiben aber ernst. Und jetzt war dieser Vorschlag von Mönchner Finnlandisierung. Da sind sehr viele in der Ukraine strikt dagegen. War auch in der Zeit noch mal ein großer Text von der ukrainischen Autorin. Die gesagt hat, fangt ja nicht damit an. Ricarda Vulpius sitzt dabei, war ja ein Alpha.
Bevor du den Clip spielst, ich weiß auch immer nicht, was kommt an den Clips. Aber Putin hat die NATO stark gemacht und den Ukrainern so ein richtiges Nationalgefühl gegeben. Das ist so paradox, was wir hier eigentlich erleben und dann auch jetzt besprechen, dass man echt... Klar, wollen die Ukraine jetzt keine Finnlandisierung, keinen Staat in der Peripherie sein. Die haben ja jetzt gerade mitgekriegt, wie sich das anders anfühlt. Die sind gerade das Zentrum der Welt. Das wollen die sich doch nie wieder nehmen lassen.
Und dieses Nationalgefühl, da müssen wir nämlich auch gleich noch mal gucken, was das eigentlich ist, also inwieweit das wirklich eins durch die Bedrohung geschaffenes ist. Wenn man sich ein bisschen die Biografie von Zelinsky ansehen, da habe ich nur gleich ein paar ganz kurze Clips. Aber Ricarda Vulpius widerspricht jetzt Münchner und dann sagt aber Münchner auch wieder was nicht Uninteressantes.
Aber ich wage die kühne These, dass selbst wenn man sich auf einen neutralen Status eingelassen hätte, früher oder später Putin nicht geduldet hätte, dass sich eine freiheitliche Ukraine rausgebildet hat.
Das ist ein interessanter Punkt, weil das möglicherweise heißt, dass die Finnen unter verstärktem Druck stehen, sich zu überlegen, ob sie nicht ganz schnell in die NATO sich hineinbegeben. Denn da kann man...
Was sie gerade tun.
Ganz genau. Also es gibt da nämlich auch eine schöne Geschichte, die man mal wieder aus der Hotelrezeption heraus erzählen könnte, wie Finnland und Russland doch eigentlich zusammengehören. Und dann geht das weiter. Also insofern, was kann man also jetzt tun? Münkler ist ja jetzt auch nicht als Pazifist hier unterwegs, sondern denkt auch über Aufrüstung nach. Aber wir waren uns jetzt eben schon einig, die werden jetzt hier nicht mit den Panzern die jungen Leute abholen und dann darüber fahren, auch wenn die 100 Milliarden ausgegeben werden. Münkler bringt Folgendes.
Wird man sich darüber Gedanken machen, ob die Europäer nicht eine eigene nukleare Option brauchen, wenn wir beobachten, dass die Stärke Putins in der Frage der Eskalationsdominanz ja letzten Endes daraus beruhte, dass sie gewissermaßen immer den nuklearen Schirm über seinen konventionell agierenden Truppen hatten, weswegen die Europäer gesagt haben, es können wir unter keinen Umständen riskieren. Und ob tatsächlich die USA für Litauen, Lettland und andere nuklear agieren werden oder andersherum, ob die Russen es für wahrscheinlich, die Führung im Kreml es für wahrscheinlich hält.
Ja, würde man dieses spieltheoretische Experiment auch von russischer Seite wagen, dass man sagt, naja, NATO, machen wir das?
Auch das hat Putin gerade provoziert, dass natürlich jetzt darüber nachgedacht wird.
Jaja, genau.
Putin hat bis jetzt genau das Gegenteil von ihm erreicht, auf allen Ebenen, was er wollte. Er hat Russland geschwächt, er hat die Bevölkerung, seine Bevölkerung ökonomisch aus dem Spiel genommen. Er hat den ganzen, wir sind angebunden an die Welt, über Tourismus, Geschäftsreisen, was auch immer beendet. Er hat die Ukraine ein Selbstbewusstsein gegeben, er hat die NATO wieder reaktiviert und mittlerweile wird jetzt auch über Atomwaffen, Schutzschirmen seit dieser Meldung von gestern nachgedacht und wen die alles so schützt. Also man kann die ganze Liste durchgehen und fragt sich so ein bisschen, hätte man das nicht antizipieren können.
Ganz kurzer Clip von Habeck bei Lanz, den wir uns auch nochmal dann vergegenwärtigen sollten von dem Hintergrund der Diskussion gestern.
Ich stimme zu, dass Wort und Tat manchmal auseinanderfallen. Und wäre ich jetzt der Energie- und Wirtschaftsminister der Ukraine, würde ich mich wahrscheinlich verraten und verkauft fühlen. Und das tun die ja auch, das sagen sie ja auch. Alleingelassen und im Stich gelassen.
Haben Sie Verständnis dafür, Herr Habeck?
Ja natürlich habe ich Verständnis dafür.
Da wird das Land überrannt. Und wir machen Wirtschaftssanktionen.
Das ist auch richtig.
Ich will das hier nochmal für Deutschland ausdrücklich sagen. Wir können nicht in einen Krieg mit Russland ziehen.
Wir können keinen dritten Weltkrieg auslösen.
Oder riskieren auslösen würde es ja Putin. Insofern sind unsere Hände im gewissen Sinne gebunden.
Aber auch da, letzte Woche waren diese ökonomischen Sanktionen, die nun wirklich tief reißen, noch nicht. Wir müssen jetzt auch Krieg nochmal neu definieren. Münkler muss sich jetzt auch nochmal einen Monat lang zurückziehen. Und mit den Finanzmärkten beschäftigen.
Ja, Münkler und Vulpius werden dann beide von der Moderatorin gefragt. Wo stehen wir denn jetzt?
Wie groß ist die Auswirkung? Stehen wir vor einer neuen Weltordnung?
Unangeschränkt ja. So, wie sieht denn diese neue Weltordnung aus? Wir haben jetzt da geopolitisches schon gehört dazu. Aber vielleicht sollten wir doch noch mal so die ideologische Komponente uns ansehen. Wir haben diese Geschichtsvorlesung da von Putin bekommen. Und im Deutschlandfunk war bei Wolfram Eilenberger, der später noch mal eine Rolle spielen wird in Bezug auf Bitcoin, nur so viel, war sie zu Gast und hat ein bisschen mal da aufgeklärt, was wird eigentlich so in Russland gedacht? Und da hören wir mal rein. Sylvia Sassen, sie ist Expertin für russische Philosophie.
Nikolai Sterikov hat ein Buch geschrieben, Die Nationalisierung des Rubels, der Weg Russlands in die Freiheit. Das ist ein Buch, was Putin gerne mal liegen lässt, wenn er interviewt wird, zum Beispiel in den Interviews mit Oliver Stone. Da lag dieses Buch dann auf dem Tisch und da geht es um so Ideale einer totalen staatlichen Souveränität und zwar kulturell, ökonomisch, militärisch, völlig frei vom Westen, den man als kolonalisierend empfindet. Also man ist praktisch gegen die Idee eines Humanismus, der universal ist und auch zum Beispiel gegen eine rechtsstaatlich fundierte Gesellschaft. Das sind gefährliche Ideologien, aber die finden wir auch in der Neuen Rechten in Westeuropa oder in Amerika in der Alt-Right-Bewegung. Also das ist nichts spezifisch Russisches.
Das hieße dann Putin führt eigentlich Krieg gegen junge Russen, die mit einem iPhone bei McDonalds sitzen und dann Marvel-Filme gucken.
Im Prinzip ja und genau dazu werden wir jetzt gleich kommen. Also dass auch das ein Krieg ist, der geführt wird. Und man aber zugleich auch sagen kann, naja, diese Popkultur, das wissen wir jetzt von identitären Bewegungen oder so, kann auch recht gut einverleibt werden für dann entsprechende Propaganda. Aber wir müssen uns also ganz klar mit den neuen Rechten auseinandersetzen. Das wurde mir so bewusst bei all den Diskussionen, die wir jetzt gerade haben mit Russland, dass wir hier auch so ein globales Netz erkennen müssen und ein anderer wichtiger Vordenker. Also wir hören jetzt hier schon Nikolaj Sterikow. Das liegt mal so da, wenn ein Fernsehinterview ist mit Oliver Stone, dann liegt dieses Buch da. Und Sterikow schreibt auch Fanfiction, jetzt platt formuliert. Er hat zum Beispiel auch so ein Buch geschrieben, wo er also eine alternative Historie schreibt. Also er sieht das als Geschichtsbuch an, wer eigentlich Hitler gesteuert hat, also wer eigentlich dahinter steckt. Also sei der aufgebaut werden von geheimen Kräften. Also das ist ein Buch, das eine Popularität da genießt. Und es gibt aber noch einen anderen russischen Vordenker dieser Entwicklung. Das ist Alexander Dugin, der sich auch jetzt wieder äußert im Diskurs.
Und der nimmt sich Versatzstücke für etwas, was er selbst Eurasismus nennt. Also er versucht Russland gewissermaßen zwischen Europa und Asien zu positionieren, hat dabei Theorien, die meinen, es gibt praktisch eine ethische, ethnische Grundlage für die Russen, dass sie anders sein und eben keine Europäer sind und auch keine Asiaten. Und dafür prädestiniert sind, im Grunde ein neues, großrussisches Reich aufzubauen. Das ist eine Ideologie, die stellenweise benutzt wird, auch und gerade jetzt.
Ja, und ich habe tatsächlich ein Buch von Dugin gelesen, als ich mich mit den Neurechten beschäftigt habe, weil ich hörte, dass der auch von den Neurechten in Deutschland rezipiert wird. Und sein Buch, Vierte Politische Theorie, ist ein würres Pamphlet gegen alles, was wir schätzen und ich habe dann nochmal nachgelesen und ich glaube, wir können jetzt so einiges verstehen, in welchem ideologischen Konflikt wir sind. Wenngleich ich auch hinzufügen muss, die Frage ist jetzt hier nicht nach dem, ist das wirklich der Autor? Also ist Putin absolut überzeugt oder nimmt er diese Versatzstücke, weil er weiß, die funktionieren international gut? Das klappt auch irgendwie bei den Republikanern, bei Trump und das klappt bei den Identitären in Europa und sonst wo. Wir hören jetzt mal eine Passage aus diesem Buch Fürthe Politische Theorie von Alexander Dugin, also in einem extrem rechten Verlag erschienen und so. Keine Werbung für das Buch hier. Der Weg, den die Menschheit in der Moderne eingeschlagen hat, führte direkt zum Liberalismus und der Ablehnung von Gott, Tradition, Gemeinschaft, Ethnizität, Imperien und Königreichen. Die Logik des Weltliberalismus und der Globalisierung zieht uns in den Abgrund postmoderner Auflösung und Virtualität. Unsere Jugend steht bereits mit einem Bein in ihm, denn die Verhaltensnormen des liberalen Globalismus werden auf unbewusster Ebene wirksam eingeführt durch Gewohnheiten, Werbung, Glamour, Technik, die Medien und Prominente. Was wir jetzt wahrnehmen, ist der Verlust der Identität, und zwar nicht nur der nationalen oder der kulturellen Identität, sondern auch der sexuellen und bald genug auch der menschlichen.
Also wenn wir sowas aus Russland hören, auch immer die ganzen Putin-orientiert-sich-in-irgendwie-in-Theater-Machern, die dann immer so mit Bildern und Ideen spielen und so weiter, ich muss immer wieder daran denken, wie das in Amerika total normal ist, dass es damals Newt Gingrich gab, der für die Republikaner auch als Mehrheitsführer zum Beispiel diese ganze Doktrin hinterlassen hat, dass man wie in Europa ja auch so ein bisschen ausgewogenen Journalismus macht. Nee, damals durfte man plötzlich, weil die Politik das wollte, ganz einseitige Programme gestalten, bis hin zum Talk-Radio, bei dem einfach nur drei, vier Stunden lang gequatscht wird. Dann zieht sich der Bogen ja bis zu Donald Trump, der dann in der State of the Union Reden noch den Orden da an den, wie heißt er, Glenn Beck und so weiter gibt. Und das, was wir hier so aus der politischen Peripherie in Russland hören, das war in Amerika immer so der Kern Washinghans, der das inhaltlich forciert hat, solche Ideen hatte, dann auch die Strukturen bereitet hat, sowas zu machen.
Wir haben es ja bei Peter Thiel auch nachlesen können, was da alles so...
Genau, der ganze Kram. Also in deren Sicht, dieses russische Zeug ist immer so faszinierend. Man kriegt auch immer so ein bisschen Gänsehaut, wenn man dann sowas hört. Aber dann stehen die Russen, den Amerikanern, also die sind da nicht irgendwie besonders bizarre oder so.
Nee, die sind sehr vernetzter. Ich werde gleich noch eine Vernetzung mal aufzeigen, die dann ganz froppierend ist. Aber hier war im Prinzip das, was du jetzt schon gesagt hast, ja, kämpft der Putin jetzt gegen die jungen Leute, die bei McDonalds sitzen mit ihrem Smartphone. Genau, das ist das, was Dugin hier sagt. Sassen, hat auch nochmal hier was zu Dugin?
Das ist, wenn es darum geht. Also Dugin hat da bestimmte, wie soll ich sagen, Versatzstücke geliefert, 2012, 2014, wo es darum ging, praktisch die Proteste in der Ukraine stets als etwas zu lesen, was vom Westen aus gelenkt wird.
So, Francis Fukuyama, den kennen wir natürlich als denjenigen, der sagte, Ende der Geschichte, Liberalismus hat gesiegt und dann wird immer wieder gesagt, hahaha, hat er sich ja groß geirrt. Es ist nicht so einfach. Er hat ja nicht nur das Buch Ende der Geschichte und Ende des Menschen geschrieben, das ich sehr mag. Er hat noch ein anderes Buch, mit dem es ein bisschen langweilig ist, aber jetzt für diesen Kontext ganz interessant, das ist nämlich ein Buch über Nation Building. Also wie baut man eigentlich jetzt einen modernen Staat? Das ist ja eine Frage, die sich auch gerade dann stellt, wenn man als Großmacht wie Amerika interveniert. Und das Nation Building hat ja zum Beispiel dann in Afghanistan nicht richtig funktioniert. Also man hat da keine Institutionen aufgebaut und all das. Dugin setzt sich nun auch in seiner Theorie mit Francis Fukuyama auseinander und sagt, ja dieses Nation Building ist immer noch Ende der Geschichte, ist immer noch Liberalismus. Und Dugin sagt Folgendes dazu. Fukuyama hat eine neue These aufgestellt, die Staatskonstruktion. Als Etappenziel beim Übergang zur Weltregierung und Weltführung hat er die Verstärkung von wirtschaftlich liberalen und demokratisch regierten Nationalstaaten empfohlen, um den Boden für den Endsieg des Weltliberalismus und der Globalisierung gründlicher und profunder vorzubereiten. Dies ist keine Verwerfung seiner früheren Perspektive, sondern deren Verschiebung in unbestimmte Zukunft mit einer sehr konkreten Vorstellung für die Zwischenzeit. So, die These ist, das Ende der Geschichte ist nur aufgeschoben, also der liberal-demokratische Konsens hat gesiegt. Man muss nochmal so einen Zwischenschritt machen, man muss jetzt noch moderne Staaten überall aufbauen. Das, was wir eigentlich schätzen und was die Ukraine sein will, also wenn man jetzt Zelinsky und so, wenn man jetzt von den nationalistischen Gräfen absieht, also diese moderne Staatlichkeit, die ist eigentlich nur, wird die etabliert, um einen globalen Liberalismus zu herzustellen. Und was man also jetzt sehen kann, der Angriff, der russische Angriff auf die Ukraine, ist eigentlich ein Kampf gegen den modernen Staat an sich und damit auch gegen den Liberalismus. Dogen geht da noch einen Schritt weiter. Fukuyama sagt fast nichts zum Zivilisationsbegriff. Nimmt aber die Thesen Huntingtons offensichtlich zur Kenntnis, indem er ihm antwortet, dass die stetige Entwicklung nationaler Regierungen, die sich in den Epochen der Kolonialisierung, der nationalen Befreiungsbewegungen und der ideologischen Spannung zweier Lage als Verkrampf der Wiesen hat, jetzt ordentlich vonstattengehen müsse. Gerade das wird allmählich dazu führen, dass verschiedene Gesellschaften, die Marktordnung, die Demokratie und die Menschenrechte einführen, die letzten Überreste des Unbewussten mit der Wurzel aushotten und der Globalisierung einen Boden bereiten, der krisensicherer ist als der heutige.
Ja, also, kann man ja ablesen. 100 Milliarden für die Bundeswehr oder die Bündnisfähigkeit. Das sind zwei ganz unterschiedliche Sachen. Weil die Bundeswehr, klar, das wäre die deutsche Bundeswehr, Grenzverteidigung und so weiter, so wie die Armee aufgestellt ist, oder Bündnisfähigkeit über den Nationalstaat hinaus in die uns jetzt gerade wieder wichtigere NATO und so weiter da einfach spezifische Fähigkeiten reinbringen. Andere bringen dann andere ein. Wir haben keine Atomwaffen, die wir haben, dann andere. Und wir bringen dann, was weiß ich und so. Dieses Ganze auch, das hat ja Olaf Scholz auch nochmal betont, wir wollen auch technisch auf Augenhöhe bleiben. Es geht auch darum, Resilienz, das Wort hat er ja auch benutzt, zu stärken. Also da geht es jetzt gerade, wo wir feststellen, wir sind national bedroht, also wo zumindest so gesagt wird, ist die Reaktion, dass wir die Organisation, die globalen Einrichtungen und so weiter da jetzt wichtiger nehmen wollen. Und dieser Shift muss nochmal über den Nationalstaat gedreht werden. Also da wird wahrscheinlich Fuku Yama recht haben, am Ende ist es das Ende der Geschichte, nur verzögert, später.
Genau, vor uns aber nicht als Dystopie, wie Dugi in die hier beschreibt. Das ist interessant, dass ich das nochmal nachgelesen habe. Zum Teil ist es einfach nur irre, aber manche Sachen liest man so und denkt, ja genau, so hätten wir es eigentlich gerne. Aber er beschreibt das als Dystopie. Und wir hören jetzt mal einen einzigen Clip von Putin, von dieser ominösen Rede vom vergangenen Montag, was er da über die Ukraine sagt.
Um zu verstehen, was denn heute geschieht, um Motive und Ziele zu verstehen, muss man ein paar Worte über die Geschichte verlieren.
Ich fange damit an.
Moderne Ukraine ist voll und ganz von Russland erschaffen worden, von der Bolschivisten Russland, von kommunistischen Russland. Dieser Prozess kam in Gang nach der Revolution von 1917. Lenin und seine Mitstreiter haben das auf eine grobe Weise zu Russland gemacht durch die Abtrennung einiger geschichtlich Russlands zugehöriger Teile. Millionen Menschen, die die bewohnt haben, wurden nicht gefragt.
Ja, das ist also genau diese Idee zu sagen, ist Konstrukt. Wir haben jetzt hier etwas künstlich Erschaffendes. Und wir sagen heute als moderne Menschen, ja, genau, das sind Staaten. Denn wir haben ja nicht irgendein gemeinsames Blut. Und da müssen wir nur mal nachschauen. Oder wir holen noch mal die Ahnenforschung raus. Nee, ist eigentlich alles modern angekommen. Aber genau das akzeptiert Putin nicht. Und er greift damit Muster von Dugin auf. Wenn wir jetzt über neue Rechte, um die mal so zu bezeichnen, sprechen, dann müssen wir es global sehen. Es war auch am Wochenende die America First Political Action-Konferenz, wo sich wirklich die Rechtsextremen in den USA treffen. Da war dieser Nick Fuentes, hat vielleicht manches Jahr schon mal gehört. Der ist jung, ich glaube Mitte 20. Sympathisiert mit Holocaust-Deugnern und Co. Also Wahnsinn, wenn man nur den Wikipedia-Eintrag liest, wird einem übel. Und der ist auch aufgetreten und hat sich wie Volk geäußert.
The United States government has become the evil empire in the world. Und es ist schade. Und jetzt reden sie über Russland, Vladimir Putin ist Hitler, und sie sagen, das ist nicht eine gute Sache.
Also vielleicht ist diese Sache da untergegangen, also er sagt und jetzt sagen sie uns Putin sei wie Hitler und sie sagen uns, das sei nicht gut, dass er so ist. Also man sieht es wirklich. Und da ist eine große Konferenz, die viel Zuspruch hat. Da hat auch mit Ben Shapiro und mit all denen zu tun. Und ich meine, es gibt ja diese Top Ten, die man auch sehen kann bei Facebook, der meist geliebten und gelesenen Post, die von Kevin Ruse angefertigt wurde, kann man jeden Tag bei Twitter sehen. Und da tauchen ja all solche Dinge immer wieder auf. Und wir haben also hier von Amerika, was jetzt Dugin als Feindland natürlich sehen würde. Aber wir haben jetzt hier gerade diese unheimliche Allianz, die stattfindet, dass wir da jemanden haben, der auch gegen den Liberalismus ist, der auch sagt, ja, diese postmoderne Sexualität, Transgender, LGBT, Black Lives Matter dann auch noch und so. Also wir sehen einen allgemeinen Kampf gegen Liberalismus, Menschenrechte und Moderne. Und das wird jetzt miteinander verquickt. Und ich glaube, dass wir durch die Pandemie ja schon etwas erlebt haben, dass eigentlich etwas passiert, wovon eigentlich Bewegungen, politische Bewegungen träumen, nämlich dass Äquivalenzketten hergestellt werden. Das war was, was Chantal Muff und Ernesto Laclo immer sagen. Also man muss eigentlich sehen, dass die streikenden Arbeiter gemeinsam streiken mit der Gay Pride Parade und dann vielleicht noch die Pflegerinnen dazu. Dann hätte man eine Äquivalenzkette, die sehr wirksam ist. Die Neurechten schaffen das. Die sagen, du bist Impfgegner und du findest auch, dass das wahre Geld der Bitcoin ist. Aber guck mal, hier habe ich dann noch ein anderes Angebot für dich. Wir sind auch noch gegen die LGBT-Bewegung. Ah ja, kannst du auch noch mitmachen. Und dann hat man so eine Äquivalenzkette von Anti-Modernen gebildet. Und das funktioniert. Und Sylvia Sassen wird hier auch von einem Berger gefragt, wie weit Putin denn daran glaubt. Und dann sagt sie, ja, er nutzt das. Denn die Herrschaft ist doch wohl anders von Putin zu definieren, die er da pflegt.
Michael Rücklin, ein russischer Gegenwartphilosoph, der sagt, wir haben es eigentlich im Moment mit einer Herrschaft zu tun, einer Herrschaft in Reinkultur, die sich auf keine beständige Ideologie stützt. Also das auch gerade im Unterschied zur sowjetischen Ideologie, oder? Was ich auch interessant finde, ist der ungarische Soziologe Balint Magyar, der den putinschen Staat, also die Regierung, die aktuelle einen postkommunistischen Mafiastaat nennt, sagt eine kleine Gruppe von Machthabern, die im Grunde wie eine Familie aufgebaut ist. Im Mittelpunkt ist der Patriarch, der nicht regiert, sondern verfügt. Die regieren eher nicht ideologiegestützt oder ideologiegesteuert, wie das früher der Fall war in der Sowjetunion, sondern ideologieanwendend. Also man nimmt sich verschiedene Versatzstücke von Ideologien, die ins politische Profil passen.
Und wenn es funktioniert, dann funktioniert es. Da ist man ganz pragmatisch. Und jetzt wollte ich es wissen, Stefan. Jetzt habe ich gedacht, ich muss jetzt wissen, wie reagieren eigentlich die Neurechten in Deutschland auf den Krieg gegen die Ukraine? Wir haben da ja auch von der AfD-Seite Verurteilungen gehört, aber dann auch Sympathien für Putin. Also man kann es sich jedenfalls nicht ganz so leicht machen, dass man sagt, ja, die AfD, die findet ja einfach den Putin toll. Es ist dann komplizierter. Was habe ich also gemacht? Ich habe mir einen Podcast angehört von dieser sogenannten Stiftung 1%. Das ist so, die angedockt sind an Schnellroder. Ich glaube, da ist auch, da dürfte auch der Verfassungsschutz dann gerne ein Auge mal drauf und so weiter. Ich habe auf jeden Fall, die haben einen bei Telegram natürlich einen Livestream veranstaltet, dreieinhalb Stunden. Da wird man aber dann als Podcast sich ausspielen lassen können. Dann dauert es nur noch die Hälfte. Und wenn man es doppelt so schnell hört. Und dann habe ich gedacht, ich muss mir das anhören, um das mal zu wissen. Und das ist hoch aufschlussreich jetzt für uns, um das ideologische Feld abzustecken. Und ich dachte, wir können das unserem aufgeklärten Publikum zumuten. Wir müssen jetzt hier nicht sieben Trickerwarnungen und sonst was machen, sondern wir können das einfach jetzt mal hören. Da ist jetzt erst mal zugeschaltet, Maximilian Krah von der AfD sitzt im EU-Parlament und versucht, die Lage mal einzuschätzen.
Und das Besondere ist ja darin, dass wir in der Westukraine auch national gesinnte Leute haben. Die sind total antirussisch, aber auch ganz klar gegen diesen Liberalismus aufstehen oder zumindest eintreten, den wir als westeuropäische oder mitteleuropäische Rechte ja auch für problematisch halten. Insofern ist die Lage der Ukrainer innen politisch sehr unübersichtlich.
Mit wem also sich solidarisieren? Wichtig ist doch immer, dass man guckt, wer kämpft gerade gegen den Liberalismus. Und was soll ich sagen, Grah bezieht sich auf wen? Auf Dugin.
Es gibt einen interessanten Tweet von Alexander Dugin heute. Der sagte, das Ende des Kalten Krieges war das Ende der Bipolaren Weltordnung. Heute erleben wir das Ende der unipolaren Weltordnung. Und eine neue multipolare Weltordnung entsteht aus den Feuern des Krieges. Natürlich klassisch Dugin martialisch. Dieses gedachte Ende der Geschichte, weil wir jetzt alle westliche Liberale werden. Ich glaube, dass das nicht funktioniert, müsste jedem klar geworden sein.
Also hier hat man es nochmal ganz deutlich. Wir leben also in einer Zeit, wo das öffentlich kommuniziert wird. Ich habe ja jetzt nicht in Geheimdokumenten gewühlt, sondern das habe ich ja ganz einfach finden können. Also wo das schon mal ganz klar gesagt wird, wir sind gegen diesen westlichen Liberalismus. Also auch was da auf republikanischer Seite ganz klar kommuniziert wird, sprechen dann auch weiter.
Ja, wir hatten das auch bei uns auf dem Blog bearbeitet. Das Problem ist natürlich, es gibt jetzt auf beiden Seiten Verlierer. Wir haben Rechte, Anti-Liberale, wenn man das so sagen will, nationale Ukrainer, junge Männer, die natürlich für ihre Nation jetzt einstehen wollen und die am Ende vielleicht im Leichensack landen, sehr wahrscheinlich sogar im Leichensack landen, dafür, dass sie für eine Idee kämpfen oder vielleicht sogar, um es deutlich zu sagen, missbraucht werden.
Das denke ich auch. Und insofern müssen wir einfach schauen, also wenn wir das innenpolitisch sehen, ist ganz klar, wir haben auf beiden Seiten gute Leute stehen. Und das Bemerkenswerte ist, dass es den Liberalen gelungen ist, die gegeneinander auszuspielen, obwohl sie gesellschaftspolitisch ziemlich viel gemeinsam haben.
So, und jetzt ist auch hier wieder Dugun-Argumentation. Er sagt ja, diese Nationalstaatsbildung wird nur gemacht, um den Liberalismus durchzusetzen. Und jetzt wird gesagt, naja, dass da auch natürlich nicht nur Selinsky-Leute und ich sag mal, in der Ukraine sitzen jetzt nicht 95% potenzielle Grünenwähler, dass die da auch mitkämpfen. Die sind eigentlich nur verführt worden von den liberalen Eliten, da kann man dann noch sich denken, wer dann da so gemeint ist.
Also, das ist alles so verdreht, dass man sich diese Rationalität kaum richtig vorstellen kann. Dieses Bild, was die aufmachen und man fragt sich immer, wo ist die Motivation dahinter? Warum versammelt die sich überhaupt so in so einem Zoom-Call, in so Konferenzen wie auch immer? Aber wenn man jetzt diese Fukuyama-These von, naja, man nimmt noch mal den Nationalstaat, aber das ist dann das Sprungbrett sozusagen in die globale Welt und dieser Nationalstaat führt die dann nochmal in die Irre oder so, weil die dann vermuten, ja, also eigentlich hat ja Putin jetzt das Superreich im Hinterkopf und möchte es den Ukrainern aufzwingen. Dann gibt es aber in der Ukraine junge Männer, die sich selbst behaupten wollen, so wie Putin sich selbst behaupten will, aber weil genau Putin ihnen das aufzwingen will, müssen sie sich gegen ihn wenden. Also haben beide eigentlich die gleiche Idee von Superreich, Selbstbehauptung, Superminität, Identität, wir verteidigen uns und so weiter und kämpfen dann aber gegeneinander und müssten sich eigentlich verbrüdern und darunter leiden die jetzt, weil die das von außen beobachten und so sehen, dass jeder in so Schleifen drin hängt.
Genau und das ist, ich glaube, das ist sehr typisch für die, wie möchte man das nennen, die Flitterhaftigkeit dieser neurechten Strömungen.
Genau, aber da wiederholt sich, was die AfD jetzt, worunter sie ja auch sehr leidet irgendwie, wenn ihnen das so bewusst wird, dass sie natürlich gegen die Islamisierung des Abendlandes wettern und gleichzeitig aber die Gründe, warum die Islamisten hier das Abendland angeblich übernehmen wollen, total gut finden, aber doch nicht so.
Also sie wollen, eigentlich ist ja die Idee eines Ethnopluralismus, dass jede Nation ihre Identität reinhält und pflegt. Und das sollen dann die Ukrainer machen und das sollen die Russen machen. Und nur in der Ukraine natürlich. Und die Russen nur in Russland und so weiter und so fort. Es wird immer von eigentlich einem homogenen Volk bei der Sache ausgegangen. Und hinzu kommt ja auch, weil uns wundert ja, weil wir erstmal sagen können, ja Nationalstaat, wenn der doch erschaffen wird, so wie Zelinsky das jetzt ganz vehement da immer wieder einfordert, ja auch patriotisch spricht, das ist doch eigentlich etwas fast Rechtes, ja? Oder zumindest nicht irgendwie sowas, was dem Linken als erstes einfallen würde, wenn so ein Nationalstaat hochgehalten wird. Nein, die Neurechten in Deutschland, also gerade so die Schneiroder Leute, sind ja stark beeinflusst von Alain de Benoit, dem französischen Neurechtenvordenker, lebt ja auch noch, und der sagt, der Nationalstaat ist eine liberale Erfindung. Also man will zu eigentlich einer völkischen Idee da zurück. Jetzt ist Roger Beckham zugeschaltet, AfD, NRW, und sagt Folgendes.
Ich habe eine große Schwäche für nationale Bewegungen, auch für die deutsche. Und so auch für eine ukrainische, der ich eben nicht ihr Dasein abspreche, wie manch andere.
So, das ist genau das. Jetzt sollen die mal alle da ihre Identitäten auskämpfen. Dann ist Volker Zierke, der das mitmoderiert, auch nicht als Sprecher der AfD oder so, sondern der ist, ich glaube irgendwie Autor oder was auch immer. Jedenfalls sagt der jetzt mal Folgendes.
Ich bin halt kein Freund von diesem pazifistischen Grundkonsens, dass der Krieg immer als das Schlechteste anzusehen ist.
Okay, das ist jetzt ehrlich gesagt zu weitführend. Lassen wir das.
Ja, so jetzt ist man selbst irritiert. Jetzt sagt da jemand, ja, aber so Krieg ist doch nichts Schlechtes. Wir wissen doch, wir haben doch Ernst Jünger und so gelesen.
Also hier schwingt ja auch immer im Hintergrund mit, dass der liberale Rechtsstaat, ich habe den Fernsehpodcast gestern mal Hypopolitik genannt. Weil Hypopolitik ist ja das, was hier gerade stattfindet, dass einfach der Bundeskanzler keine Befehle gibt, sondern einfach im Fernsehen sagt, was weiß ich, Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz, da ist das Zitat dann original her. Was, und nee, das hat er bei Putin gesagt. An Putins Seite dann endlich mal angesprochen, auf und so weiter. Und dann hat er gesagt, ja, Nordseem 2, wenn die Grenzen überschritten werden durch die russische Armee, weiß jeder, was zu tun ist. Was ja im Grunde so die Handlungshinweisgebung ist. Lieber FC Schalke 04, lieber FC Jaycee. Also ihr wisst, was dann zu tun ist. Ihr müsst euch dann und so weiter verabschieden von so und so. Oder, liebe, was weiß ich, Oper da in München oder so. Der Dirigent darf dann halt nicht mehr auftreten. Weil er so ein russischer Freund ist.
Was ich allerdings ein bisschen übertrieben finde. Ja, also wir können jetzt nicht jeden da, also das ist natürlich unschön, aber ich meine, das ist ein wichtiger Dirigent. Und Trepko ist eine ganz gute Sängerin. Ich finde sie ein bisschen überschätzt. Aber wir können hier, also ich finde, lasst uns bitte über die richtigen Maßnahmen sprechen. Und lasst uns alle Finanzströme einfrieren. Aber jetzt fangen wir nicht an, bei Künstlern nochmal immer abzuklopfen, wer hat jetzt gerade was gemacht und wen gewählt.
Aber das fällt ebenso in diese Domäne Hyperpolitik. Alle fühlen sich unter Druck gesetzt, obwohl es gar keinen Befehl der Bundesregierung gab. Während wir auf der anderen Seite, und das wird ja so bewundert, bei Putin einfach dieses Durchregieren sehen. Er führt einfach seinen Geheimdienstchef vor, sagt ihm einfach, was er jetzt sagen soll. Und dann sagt er das einfach vor der Kamera. Er gibt diese Befehle ins ganze Land und sagt halt jedem genau, was er tun muss. Und das ist ja diese Sehnsucht, dass es diese Orientierung einfach gibt. Also der Liberalismus wird wahrscheinlich auch deswegen abgelehnt. Nicht nur, weil diejenigen, die wir hier gerade alle sprechen, keine mächtigen Menschen gerade sind, sondern weil ihnen gar nicht die Gelegenheit gegeben wird, überhaupt mächtige Menschen zu werden, weil es diese Art der Macht gar nicht gibt. Sondern jeder weiß halt, was zu tun ist. Geld verdienen, Kinder großziehen und Sonstiges. Aber keiner strahlt so über seine eigene Manneskraft hinaus und dirigiert so die ganze Welt.
Und sagt, so ein Krieg wäre jetzt so ein inneres Erlebnis, das man doch mal mitnehmen sollte. Richtig, genau.
Und dieser Idee hängt man aber nach. Und daran doktern die gerade rum und nehmen dann so gerade in Kauf, wie er sagt, also Krieg ist gar nicht so schlecht. Da hätte man ja wirklich, wenn man das jetzt mal wirklich weiterführt und das nicht abbrecht, das Gespräch, so wie die, entfernt. Also meine Vermutung wäre, dann müsste man ja sagen, ja, dann müssen wir jetzt durchs Tal der Tränen durch, dass ukrainische Nationalisten und russische Nationalisten halt gegeneinander kämpfen und sich da eigentlich unsere Brüder gegeneinander, Hauptsache, äh, die richtige Sache.
Und dann hat das aber irgendwas, also so einer faschistischen Argumentation würde man dann sagen, das hat aber irgendeinen reinigen Effekt. Dann sagt ja Philipp Stein schon, ja, gut, da machen wir jetzt hier so ein großes Fass auf. Dann ist eine Stunde, wird darüber nicht mehr gesprochen, da werden wieder laute Leute zugeschalten. Das überspringen wir jetzt mal alles. Aber dann kommt Philipp Stein doch nochmal so auf diese Frage zurück. Ja, so Krieg, ist das dann, ist vielleicht nicht doch auch mal toll, jetzt mal so ein Krieg?
Aber wir Europäer sind diesen Krieg auf eine gewisse Art nicht mehr gewohnt. Und jetzt geht aus meiner Sicht wie so eine Art Schockwelle durch die rechte Szene auch, lustigerweise, die ja immer Ernst Jünger liest und schreibt in Stahlgewittern und dies und jenes, geht plötzlich so eine Art Ruck durch diese, ja, durch diese Szene. Und gerade schreibt jemand im Chat, sehe ich mit einem Auge nur Günter Maschke. Und das ist ein guter Begriff, der Günter Maschke, der hätte sich, Gott hab ihn selig vermutlich jetzt kaputt gelacht.
Ja, Günter Maschke, wer ist Günter Maschke, ist gestorben. Er war ein sehr eigenartiger Zeitgenosse. Er hat für die FAZ-Zeit, weiß ich auch mal, geschrieben. Er hat sich von ganz links nach ganz rechts entwickelt. Er hat auch sich verdient gemacht, um die Werke von Karl Schmidt, muss die hervorragend ideiert haben, wie also Experten auch immer sagen. Und zugleich ist er jemand, der tatsächlich mit keine Probleme hatte, mit Faschisten zu tun zu haben. Und der würde natürlich noch den heroischen Kriegsgeist immer wieder hochhalten wollen.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt ein rechter Podcast, den wir hier hören. Ich habe gestern an der Wille gehört, da saß Karl Schlögl, ein Osteuropa-Kenner, keine Ahnung, den ich nicht kannte vorher, der dann plötzlich auftauchte vor einem Millionenpublikum. Und mir als jüngeren Mann einfach sagt, du bist ja wohlstandsverwaltungslos, du kennst ja gar keinen Krieg mehr. Das ist eigentlich falsch. Auch du solltest wissen, was ein Krieg ist, und ich wundere mich sehr. Also ich referiere jetzt, was ich verstanden habe bei ihm. Das kann ja jeder selber überprüfen, was er von ihm verstanden hat. Aber im Grunde steckt in dieser Sendung dieser Vorwurf, der sich an mich richtet, warum bist du jetzt nicht in die Ukraine gefahren und kämpfst damit? Du bist doch ein junger Mann. Genau.
Und das war jetzt schon häufiger zu lesen. Das war von Leuten, von der Springer-Presse, aber auch von linksliberaler Seite war da zu lesen, ja vielleicht haben wir dann doch ein bisschen mit der Wugnis übertrieben und so.
Genau, genau.
Jetzt müssen wir mal wieder zu so einer Härte finden. Und dann würde ich sagen, dann geht los. Bitte, ihr könnt gerne.
Nee, das würde ich sagen. Ich würde sagen, lasst uns mal alle ins andere Trappurkonzert gehen. Wir gehen jetzt nicht in den Krieg in die Ukraine. Auch nicht, wie die wollen.
Ja, sowieso. Aber die würden es doch alle nicht machen. Und das kannst du mir auch nicht erzählen. Auch hier die so Promi-Comedians, die irgendwie sagen, wir müssen um die Wehrpflicht reden. Ich weiß ganz genau, deren Kinder werden nicht zur Wehrpflicht gehen. Die werden nämlich dann zufälligerweise gerade dieses tolle Auslandsstudium in Kalifornien machen. Also, das darfst du euch da nichts erzählen. Und jetzt, du hast es gerade sehr schön gesagt, das ist jetzt ein rechter Podcast. Und dann hört man sowas bei Anne Will und ich glaube, wir werden es jetzt noch häufiger hören. Also dieser, wie soll ich sagen, diese geistige Aufrüstung, die jetzt gerade stattfindet, dieser gedankliche Militarismus, der wird sich jetzt häufig wieder in Talkshows artikulieren. Ich finde es auch skandalös, dass unsere Leute da bei Anne Will sitzen können. Und selbst jemand wie Benedikt Kaiser, der zu den Autoren gehört, der die großen politischen Einordnungen da schreibt, der reagiert jetzt auch mal auf das, was da sein Kollege gesagt hat mit Krieg. Ist vielleicht doch nicht so schlecht.
Ich glaube, da niemand von uns dreien, die wir jetzt miteinander sprechen, auch wenn der Volker noch ruhig ist, niemand von uns hat ja in irgendeinem bewaffneten Konflikt kämpfen müssen. Und ich glaube, deswegen wäre es ein bisschen absurd, wenn wir uns jetzt militärstrategisch da äußern und irgendwie einen Krieger-Heroismus hochleben lassen, den wir selber nie gelebt haben.
Selbst die Neurechten sind da jetzt ein bisschen zögerlich und sagen, naja, jetzt lassen wir mal die Kirche im Dorf. Wir wollten ja eigentlich auch die Zentralheizung morgen früh genießen und nochmal an das Smartphone gehen.
Also bei Phoenix, der deutschen Fernsehcenter oder im ZDF, wenn Christian Sievers diesen Egon Rahms zuschaltet, der seit einer Woche da immer präsent ist. So ein 80-jähriger, ich weiß nicht genau wie alt, ehemaliger NATO-General, wohl irgendwie der damals ranghöchste europäische Militär in der NATO usw. Und die stellen ihnen ja wirklich die Fragen, ist das gerade klug, was der Putin macht? Oder müsste man das nicht strategisch usw.? Und wie sind denn die Aussichten, wo ich mir auch denke, ist das jetzt so eine Spielfeldanalyse des Krieges? Sollen wir jetzt irgendwie im Nebel der Propaganda, und wir wissen auch nicht genau, was da stattfindet, kriegen wir jetzt so eine Expertenmeinung dazu? Wo selbst die Rechten hier noch da sitzen und sagen, also jetzt mal halblang, wir ziehen ja mal eine Linie, das ist jetzt auch quatschig, das zu diskutieren. Also im Fernsehen ist das mittlerweile schon wieder irgendwie normal.
Ja, ich bin, ich bin darüber wirklich sehr, sehr schockiert. Da wird ganz zum Schluss noch Gürt Skubicek, der Chef da von Schnellroda, zugeschaltet. Und der spielt natürlich jetzt nochmal sehr damit. Mit dem, ja, können wir doch mal hier den Ernstfall sehen.
Ob Russland das, was es tut, im übergeordneten Sinne nicht einfach tun darf, weil es dazu in der Lage ist. Und ich glaube, dass die diese Frage immer so einen Erschrecken auslöst. Also ich habe das sogar beim Benedikt ein bisschen gemerkt, dass er erschrocken ist, weil das ja im Grunde eine sehr kalten Antwort auch bedürftet auf diese Frage. Wenn wir nur alle als Karl-Schmidt-Leser wissen, dass, um es mal auf so ein paar Formeln zu bringen, eine Großmacht tut, was eine Großmacht tun kann und was sie im Zweifelsfall tun muss.
So, und da sieht man nämlich dann ganz klar, die Lektüre ist das eine, ja. Aber wenn es dann tatsächlich so eintritt, dass eine Großmacht sich in einer solchen Weise verhält, dann ist man doch plötzlich stärker abgeschreckt, als man es bei der Lektüre war.
Ja, also Russland wird ja hier so als Großmacht dargestellt. Russland ist keine Großmacht. Da sehen wir gerade jetzt, Russland hat Hoheit über den Rubel. Der ist nichts wert, gar nichts. Der Aktienmarkt dort als Index hat einfach die Hälfte seines Wertes verloren. So als wäre einfach die Hälfte der Wirtschaftskraft.
Und hier nicht, ne?
Hier nicht, genau.
Ich würde sagen, die Börsen haben schon glückliche Beträge erlebt. Wir haben so ein Plus gemacht. Und einiges hat Plus gemacht. Aber generell geht es ein bisschen nach unten. Aber wenn man sich das jetzt ansieht in den letzten fünf Tagen, da ist es nicht so, dass da Leute jetzt in ihr Portfolio reinblicken und sagen, das ist ja alles weg.
Ja, also wir müssen ganz klar sagen, das, was jetzt gerade passiert, ist, dass der Westen feststellt, wir machen jetzt mal alles, was wir können. Ohne, dass man aufgrund vorheriger Erfahrung oder so, die sammeln wir jetzt erst, da auch mal rote Linien einzieht. Wie weit geht man jetzt mit Zentralbankpolitik und so weiter? Wie weit treibt man es denn mit? Wollen wir nicht den Exodus der Menschen dann wirklich mal begrenzen? Die Ausweichbewegung, wenn Russland ausfällt in der Weltwirtschaft, dann kauft man das Öl halt woanders. Das ist ja auch für andere Länder wieder eine neue Situation. Die Preise steigen extrem, sehr viele Länder profitieren jetzt davon. Also Russland hat sich in der Annahme, es sei eine Großmacht, jetzt richtig zum Opfer gemacht. Demografisch ist das jetzt die Hölle, die da einfach ausbricht. Wirtschaftspolitisch, haben wir jetzt schon gesehen, geht es einfach rapide runter. Politische Handlungsfähigkeit, wir haben das so oft besprochen, wie das übers Geld einfach gemacht wird. Souveränität, über die Verfügbarkeit von Geld, die ist in Russland nicht gegeben, die Inflation. Wir haben Bankruns da und Inflation, das kommt jetzt alles zusammen. Das Geld ist nichts mehr wert, Rubel hat irgendwie 40% im Vergleich zum Dollar verloren und so weiter und so fort. Und hier in so einem Podcast zusammenzusitzen, Russland als Großmacht machen die einfach mal, was sie gerade machen können, Russland sind alle Hände gebunden.
Ja, Kubitschek ist ja Preußen-Fan, das merkt man dann hier, aber das ist halt auch vorbei mit dem alten Preußen.
Aber eigentlich müsste man jetzt mal diskutieren, ob nicht die westliche Antwort über die Stränge schlagt auf der anderen Seite. Und das muss man auch ganz deutlich sagen. Und das ist auch ein Auftrag für Historiker und auch Politiker, wenn jetzt irgendwer Abschlussarbeiten schreibt oder so. Die Anne Will Sendung vor einer Woche, wo Ursula von der Leyen zugeschaltet war, sie war nicht zugeschaltet, sondern sie hat im Vorfeld Fragen beantwortet, die dann in der Sendung live gesendet wurden, ohne nochmal Rückfragen zu stellen. Da hat ja Ursula von der Leyen gesagt, also vor dieser ganzen Woche, bevor das alles losging, hat sie ja gesagt, unsere Sanktionen, die wir geplant haben, sind so hart, dass wir Russland jetzt nochmal die Chance geben, sie abzuwehren. Und jetzt hat Russland die aber wollte sozusagen sehen, hat gepokert und wollte sehen. Und jetzt greifen aber diese Sanktionen. Und die sind wirklich so hart, wie wir uns das alle nicht vorstellen können. Und jetzt müssen wir auch nochmal neu definieren, was ist eigentlich eine Großmacht. Die sitzen hier zusammen und sagen, eine Großmacht definiert sich darüber, dass sie im Krieg machen kann, was sie will.
Und über Raum.
Ja, über Raum, klar. Also oben so Territoriale und so weiter. Nur wir sehen jetzt gerade das Territorium, schön und gut, aber auf politischer und juristischer Ebene, so wie das LIndner vorhin alles in einen Topf geworfen hat. Da geht es gerade richtig zur Sache. Und da müssen wir auch nochmal ganz neu definieren, was es eigentlich gerade eine Großmacht. Das dann auch perspektivisch mit Blick auf China und so weiter. Also da haben wir hier so einen ganz engen Fokus von diesen Leuten.
Ja. Jetzt noch kurz ein paar Clips zu Zelinski. Denn wir wissen ja gar nicht viel über den. Denn seien wir ehrlich, wir haben uns dann doch gar nicht so viel für die Ukraine bis vor kurzem interessiert. Also das muss man immer wieder sagen. Ich bin dann bei manchen sehr verwundert, die so tun, als würden sie seit zehn Jahren nichts anderes machen, als in die Ukraine blicken. Das ist nicht wahr. Also für ganz wenige Markte stimmen, nämlich für Experten.
Die Leute haben auch vor einer Woche noch nicht gewusst, was Zwift ist. Genau.
Ja, ja.
Plötzlich alles total präsent.
Ja, ja klar. Natürlich so muss es gemacht werden. So es gab, und das ist das Einzige, was ich jetzt dazu bringen will, weil ich es interessant finde für unseren Podcast. Wir haben ja schon häufiger über History Has Begun, Trump, der Reality-Star, Ronald Reagan als Schauspieler und so. Wir haben hier, ohne dass ich jetzt sagen will, Zelinsky ist jetzt wie Trump, aber ich will dir eine mediale Parallele aufzeigen, die doch ganz interessant ist, auch nochmal in Bezug auf das, was du sagtest. Na ja, der Putin hat jetzt da das richtig patriotisch gemacht. Denn wenn man sich jetzt mal so den Werdegang von Zelinsky ansieht, dann muss man sagen, ja, das ist halt jemand, der in erster Linie auch sagen will, ich bin hier gerne in der Öffentlichkeit und ich glaube, ich kann das ganz gut. Und dann mache ich das mal. Aber das haben wir auch nicht jetzt hier mit einer Figur zu tun, die in dem Sinne ideologisch agiert. Das war immer mein Ziel. Genau dahin wollte ich die ukrainische Bevölkerung führen. Also ZAP-Beitrag 2019 über Zelensky.
Der Kandidat hält keine Wahlkampfreden, er dreht. Staffel 3, einer der erfolgreichsten Fernsehserien der Ukraine. In der Hauptrolle Vladimir Zelensky, der bekannteste Komiker des Landes. Zelensky spielt niemand anderen als den Präsidenten der Ukraine. Der Diener des Volkes heißt die Serie. Es ist die Geschichte eines kleinen Lehrers, der plötzlich Präsident wird.
Das ist halt einfach eine unglaubliche Biografie, was soll man sagen?
Er spielt den Präsidenten und wird dann der Präsident. Wir hören mal weiter.
Der zur Arbeit radelt, der nicht korrupt ist. Ein Traumpräsident. Die Schauspieler kennen sich seit Jahren. Irgendwann während der Dreharbeiten sagen sie, hätte Vladimir sich wohl gedacht, warum sollte er es nicht wirklich versuchen, als echter Präsident?
So, wer ist denn eigentlich am meisten prädestiniert dafür, Politiker zu werden? Ein Schauspielkollege gibt jetzt hier eine sehr, sehr interessante Antwort.
Wir spielen hier doch seit Jahren im politischen Umfeld. Wir hatten Politologen als Berater hier. Wir kennen uns alle besser aus als jeder Abgeordnete, der neu ins Parlament kommt.
Zunächst hielt man es für einen Scherz, als Zelensky an Silvester im Fernsehen auftauchte.
Doch es war ernst. Ich verspreche Ihnen, liebe Ukrainer, dass ich als Präsident kandidiere und erkläre hiermit offiziell, ich trete an.
Wir haben es bei David Klobber gelesen. Das ist der Spielkönig. Man kommt erst mal auf die Idee, wie wäre es? Dann spielt man den König und dann ist man irgendwann König.
Ganz genau. Und es ist auch ein Kandidat, der die sozialen Medien zu nutzen wusste. Was wir jetzt ja auch gerade wieder merken, dass das relativ gut funktioniert über Twitter und Co.
Seitdem vergeht kaum ein Tag, an dem er sich nicht im Selfie-Modus auf Facebook oder Instagram melden würde. Politisch konkret wird es dabei nie. Es geht allein um die Ansprache. Wahlkampf war gestern, sagen sie in der Parteizentrale. Inhalt? Offenbar auch. Selenskis Partei heißt wie die Serie Diener des Volks. Sie besteht aus seiner Comedy-Truppe. Neue Mitglieder nehmen sie nicht auf.
Das sehen wir ja auch in Deutschland. Man kann sich genau anschauen, wie Olaf Scholz das macht. Die erste Idee, ich mache es wie Merkel, ich bleibe im Hintergrund und plötzlich taucht er so auf. Plötzlich stehen so deutsche und europäische Fahnen im Bundeskanzleramt an dem Fenster, wo man hinten den Bundestag sieht. Dann ist da so ein kleines Podest. Dann hält er da plötzlich reden. Das ist ja alles neu erfunden. Das haben wir bei Merkel 16 Jahre nicht gesehen.
Tritt den amerikanischen Fernsehen auf.
Richtig so was. Ist plötzlich bei sie ein Endpräsent und so. Irgendwie schwingt bei mir auch immer so eine Idee mit, dass man es so beobachtet. Ich betone das dann im Fernsehpodcast immer so ein bisschen deutlicher zu sagen. Die sind eingeladen von den Medien und gehen dann auch dahin. Und dann gehen sie aber zurück zur Arbeit. Also hier spielen sie den Bundeskanzler. Und dort sind sie, der Bundeskanzler. Und da ist es ganz bewusst zu machen, bei Annalena Baerbock ja auch. Hat man ja auch gesehen, als die Angriffe von Russland dann kamen, war sie gerade in Paris. Bei der Arbeit. Und ihr Statement war 20 Sekunden lang oder so. Der Appell an den Putin, hör mal auf damit. Und wir müssen jetzt hier alle zusammenstehen. Das war's. Mehr fand da nicht statt. Weil sie hat ja gerade, sie war mit Arbeiten beschäftigt. Und nicht mit der Öffentlichkeitsarbeit. Also diese harte Trennung da zu machen, ist glaube ich super wichtig. Da hat uns Trump und Zelensky jetzt den Fokus für gegeben, wie man das beobachtet, dass man halt da wirklich sagen kann, das waren dann einfach Fernsehstars vorher. Und dann sind sie in diese Rolle reingekommen. Und so sollte man aber auch unsere Politiker einfach beobachten.
Es gibt natürlich auch so eine postdemokratische Komponente bei der ganzen Sache, die wir nicht verschweigen sollten.
Aber sie beschäftigen junge Leute für die sozialen Medien. Wir dürfen sie filmen. Reden geht nur mit dem Parteichef. Der ist auch Jurist der Comedyfirma, kennt Zelensky seit Jahrzehnten und glaubt an den Erfolg.
Alles ist ein Projekt, auch Wahlkampf.
So, alles als Projekt. Hier haben wir jetzt einen Produzenten, der sagt, wir organisieren das so, wie wir eigentlich auch die Shows organisieren. Und das gibt einem dann doch zu denken, bzw. man sollte jetzt also natürlich diese Regierung auch nicht glorifizieren.
Bis kurz vor der Wahl turt Zelensky mit Comedy durchs Land immer ausverkauft. Lachen über Politik und über Politiker hinter gepanzerten Autoscheiben. Mit Journalisten redet er fast nie. Wir erwischen ihn zwischen zwei Auftritten. Glaubt er an den Sieg?
Für die Wähler geht es um Sieg oder Niederlage. Es geht doch nicht um mich. Sie sollen wählen, wen sie wollen. Und ob ich bereit bin dafür? Auf sowas kann man sich doch nicht vorbereiten. Du musst sagen wir adäquat sein.
Aber irgendwie müssen sie sich doch vorbereiten. Gespräche führen mit Politologen oder so.
Inhaltlich meine ich. Ja, wir arbeiten an einem Programm. Wir studieren wichtige Ereignisse und Momente, politische Schritte früherer Politiker, analysieren das. Und wir sammeln, also wir reden sehr viel mit Leuten, mit einfachen Leuten. Da gibt es viele Möglichkeiten online.
Bei den Fans verschwimmt die Grenze zwischen Kunstfigur und Kandidat längst. Wir hoffen, dass er als Präsident so ist wie in der Rolle, mit dem gleichen Verhältnis zum Volk.
Naja, das ist, aber wahrscheinlich bewegen wir uns immer mehr in dieses Stadium hinein, dass man dann sagt, Serienstar geht dann noch in die Politik oder geht aus der Politik wieder zurück in das Showbusiness. Das ist ja eine Entwicklung, die wir bei den Obamas und weiß ich nicht, wo überall erleben kann. Hillary Clinton schreibt Romane. Also man geht von der Fiktion in die politische Wirklichkeit, in die Realpolitik und geht von der Realpolitik wieder zurück in die Fiktion. Das ist eine allgemeine Entwicklung, die sehr problematisch, finde ich, auf Dauer ist. Aber das müssen wir dann über die großen Zeitverläufe, die wir hier haben, betrachten. Das ist jedenfalls ein Detail, ein Mosaik in diesem größeren Bild.
Genau, wir in Deutschland haben sowieso einen engen Fokus. Wir setzen schon immer sehr darauf, dass der Kanzler doch möglichst vorher Vizekanzler war oder irgendeine andere Regierungserfahrung hat. In Texas zum Beispiel gibt es ja jetzt ein neues Gesetz, das alle Eltern aller Schulen beauftragt sozusagen zu beobachten, wer hat denn hier transsexuelle Kinder zu Hause, um die dann zu melden. Also da wird sozusagen richtig Druck aufgebaut, weil da soll der Staat dann ein bisschen anders drauf gucken, ob hier Kindeswohl, Gefährdung und so weiter eine Rolle ist, weil transsexuell ist ja nicht normal und deswegen soll das jetzt gemeldet werden.
Ja, das ist auch wieder Kampf gegen das liberale, moderne.
Genau, so wie man auch schon bei Abtreibungen diese 10.000 Euro Kopfgeld ausgerufen hat und so, falls irgendwer Tipps hat. Und auf der anderen Seite haben wir aber in Texas diese Lage, dass zum Beispiel Matthew McConaughey immer so ein bisschen damit spielt, werde ich hier jetzt Gouverneur oder nicht? Weil er könnte ja einfach sagen, ich erkläre mich bereit, ich mache hier einen Wahlkampf und die Chancen stünden ja nicht schlecht. Und dann hätte man plötzlich so eine ganz andere Welt. Also daran sieht man auch, wie wir auch heute noch nicht wissen, wer denn jetzt auf der nächsten Debattenbühne bei den Demokraten steht oder bei den Republikanern. Und je nachdem, was dann passiert, schlägt es dann richtig zu. Aber auch in Europa fühlen sich ja Menschen auf der Bühne sehr wohl, wenn sie wirklich mit Macht und so weiter kommen. Und dann gucken wir nochmal an die Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz, um uns auch sowohl dem Ende des Ukrainerthemas heute zu nähern und nochmal die EU-Sicherheitsfrage aufzubauen. Denn die EU denkt schon in ganz anderen Kategorien, wenn es um Sicherheit geht. Zum einen, wir haben jetzt Streit mit Putin. Und zwar nur, könnte uns ja alles egal sein, wenn wir nicht so abhängig wären. Wie genau abhängig sind wir denn jetzt von Polen? Da kann man jetzt mal, wenn man die Zahlen hört, und zwar aus dem Munde der Chefin selbst, so ein bisschen überlegen, ist das jetzt eigentlich viel oder nicht?
Ich konzentriere mich auf unsere Abhängigkeit von russischem Gas. Ich möchte Ihnen ein paar Zahlen geben. 24 Prozent insgesamt im Energiemix der Europäischen Union. Das ist der Anteil des Gases. 90 Prozent dieses Gases importieren wir. Und 40 Prozent dieser Importe kommen aus Russland.
Das ist also eine substanzielle Abhängigkeit.
So 24 Prozent der europäischen Energieversorgung ist Gas. 90 Prozent davon sind Importe. Und 40 Prozent davon kommen aus Russland. Das sind also Summa summarum. Das hat sie dann bei Anne Will noch mal konkretisiert.
Das sind ungefähr 10 Prozent der gesamten Energieversorgung in Europa.
Also 10 Prozent.
Ich glaube, da hat doch Amerika sogar mit... Also ich weiß nicht, wie es im Gesamtanteil ist, aber die haben ja ihre Ölimporter aus Russland noch mal gesteigert 2021. Wenn ich das recht...
Also ich weiß nicht genau. Amerika ist ja jetzt erst seit Kurzem wieder Netto-Exporteur durch dieses Fracking und so. Und diese neue Möglichkeit, dieses Gas da so zu verflüssigen, was ja das Volumen irgendwie ums 200-fache senkt und so. Das ist ja eine ganz erstaunliche Technologie. Aber 10 Prozent, also da kann man ja nun mit kalkulieren, würde ich sagen.
Ja, eben.
Perspektivisch irgendwie.
Das kann ja jetzt nicht sein. Mal davon abgesehen, was so energiepolitisch da versagt wurde. Aber ich glaube, da finde ich auch jetzt, es haben ja auch wieder Leute nochmal, das war doch auch Robin Alexander, der jetzt nochmal das Atomkraftwerk ins Spiegel hatte, hat gesagt, wo wir jetzt schon dabei sind, mal Zeitenwende zu machen, jetzt mal wieder Atomkraftwerke.
Ja, also ich habe es nur über Peripherie mitbekommen. Aber Robert Habeck hat wohl gestern im Bericht aus Berlin abends gesagt, wenn Not am Mann ist, weil Gaslieferungen fehlen, könnte man auch Atomkraftwerke in Deutschland doch noch ein bisschen länger laufen lassen. Ich weiß aber nicht genau, er hat das wohl sehr flacklos gelesen.
Also ich traue denen inzwischen alles zu. Ich sehe das sehr schwarz.
Ich meine, die Grünen sind jetzt echt in der Bredouille. Die kriegen jetzt dieses riesige Angebot. Wir machen jetzt Energiewende und nehmen das wirklich ernst. Allerdings nur unter dem Schirm Sicherheitspolitik, was eben bedeutet, das ist aber nicht die einzige Sicherheitspolitik, sondern das heißt dann auch Aufrüstung und der ganze Kram.
Ich bin nur gespannt, ob du die Energiepolitik auf der Strecke hast. Gerade beim Heizen. Ich habe bei Bekannten jetzt gehört, wenn du ein Haus besitzt, ein älteres, mit einer älteren Heizung, die ist 25 Jahre alt, muss erneuert werden. Dann hat man Öl oder Gas. Was würde man denn jetzt machen, wenn man eine neue Heizung braucht? Dann haben die sich überlegt, man könnte doch so mit Erdwärme und dieser Sache arbeiten, denn dann ist man ja ziemlich autark oder fast ganz autark. Dann bekommt man vom Heizungsbauer dann mal einen Kostenvoranschlag gemacht und der sieht dann wie folgt aus, wenn sie jetzt eine neue Gasheizung machen, die ein bisschen effizienter ist, und da sprechen wir da von 10%, kostet das 10.000 Euro. Wenn sie die Erdwärmegeschichte machen, 30.000. Wie alt sollen die Leute werden, dass sich das amortisiert? Und was machen die? Natürlich die Gasheizung.
Also, Robert Habeck, hören wir nachher noch beim Wohnbautag, der im Februar stattfand. Diese Geothermie ist ganz wichtig. Er möchte das gerne von 1, 5 Millionen auf 8 Millionen oder so, hören wir nachher die Zahlen. Also richtig, dass das richtig präsent wird. Auch als, das hätte ja auch so das Energieeffekt, das wird dann auch billiger. Und als zweites, es gibt ja schon die Pflicht, jetzt auf Gewerbegebiet, Immobilien, Solardächer aufzubauen und das Gebot ist auch bei Privaten zu machen. Was er mit der interessanten Floskel umschreibt, das ist die Verpflichtung, Geld zu verdienen. Denn so ein Hausdach bringt ja unglaublich viel Strom. Also wenn du auf so ein übliches Hausdach, so ein typisches Einfamilienhaus, ein Solardach draufmachst, produziert das sechsmal mehr Strom, als es tatsächlich für sich selber braucht. Also da sind unglaublich viele Schätze noch zu heben und dann könnte man auch ein bisschen anders heizen.
Genau, aber das ist ja etwas, was noch in den Sternen in meinen Augen steht. Also momentan ist es ja einfach so, du hast ja die demografischen Zahlen. Die ganzen Boomer, die jetzt in Rente gehen, haben ja...
Allein, was über das Bau nachher hat. Wir haben die ganzen Zahlen da, inklusive Demografie usw. weil die kriegen da jedes Jahr so einen riesigen Fortsprung.
Ich sag nur, da sind einige Heizungen, die jetzt gerade anstehen, also auch gar nicht so einfach, jetzt in der Heizung anzukommen. Und die werden natürlich alle die günstige Variante nehmen. Also wenn ich jetzt die Alternativwerte gebe, 10.000, 30.000 Euro raus, ich rette ja nicht alleine die Welt damit und dann wird 100 Milliarden für militär verpulvert.
Also der Zielpfad der Bauindustrie ist, 1, 8 Prozent der Gebäude pro Jahr für die nächsten 23 Jahre in Stand zu halten. Also sowohl für altersgerechtes Wohnen als auch fürs klimaneutrale Wohnen. Damit die auch Perspektive haben. Das passiert also nicht von jetzt auf gleich, aber die Perspektive ist so, den Unternehmen zu sagen, ja, also die Förderung und so weiter, das ganze Ökosystem dieses Wandels wird so gestaltet, dass man die nächsten 25 Jahre so planen kann, dass man auch jetzt schon sicher Leute in Ausbildung bringt, von denen man weiß, die kann man dann auch in 30 Jahren noch verwenden und so weiter. Also da gibt es schon ganz vernünftige Pfade. Bleiben wir nochmal beim rudimentären. Ursula von der Leyen macht also wirklich diese krassen Ansagen. Bei Anne Will hat sie das eine gesagt. Und jetzt bei der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz hat sich schon sozusagen den ganzen Wind eigentlich aus Putins Haltung so rausgenommen.
Wir müssen uns diversifizieren, sowohl wenn es darum geht, unsere Ressourcen im Energiebereich zu nutzen und auch die Lieferanten. Und wir arbeiten bereits daran. Wir haben unsere Partner und Freunde kontaktiert, und zwar auf der ganzen Welt. Und heute kann ich sagen, dass auch falls es eine volle Unterbrechung der Gaslieferungen aus Russland gibt, dass wir sicher sind auf der sicheren Seite für diesen Winter.
Mittelfristig und langfristig setzen wir uns mehr für erneuerbare Energien an.
Wasserstoff, Windenergie, Wasserenergie und so weiter. Wir werden weiter energieunabhängig werden als EU.
Ja, also wir sind jetzt schon nicht gefährdet an Energielücken. Es sind nur noch Preisfragen. Also Russland kann uns nicht substanziell schaden, sondern es wird halt nur teuer. Das Geld fließt aber irgendwo hin und ist ja dann auch nicht aus der Welt, sondern nur bei jemand anderem. Und man hat sich hier schon mit der Welt verständigt.
Momentan wären wir in der Lage, dass russische Gas mit LNG-Gas aus anderen Teilen der Welt zu ersetzen. Und wir werden auch unterstützt durch andere Einkäufer, zum Beispiel Japan oder Südkorea, denn sie sind bereit mit uns sozusagen Verträge auszutauschen, sodass Schiffe mit Gaslieferungen umgeleitet werden in die EU.
So, Südkorea, Japan, also von der anderen Seite der Welt könnten wir irgendwie versorgt werden, und so weiter, das ist alles Tagespolitik. Jetzt kommt ein Clip, den hören wir uns genau an. Es war diesen Monat auch EU-Afrika-Gipfel. Wir wissen aus Afrika, die erleben jetzt ein 20. Jahrhundert mit einer Verdoppelung, Verdreifachung der Bevölkerung plus Lebenserwartung irgendwie auch nochmal verdoppelt. Also eine Versechsfachung von Arbeitszeit, Arbeitskapazität, die da stattfindet. Während der Rest der Welt schrumpft. Alle Vorzeichen sind negativ. Die Hälfte der Länder schrumpft schon und so weiter und so fort. Von dieser Veranstaltung gibt es nichts zu berichten, denn niemand hat daran gedacht, dass es jemanden interessieren könnte. Ich habe nichts dazu gefunden. Keine Kommentare, keine Berichterstattung, keine Clips, nichts. Es war nirgendwo Thema. Ja, Afrika interessiert mich. Also hier muss man echt mal vorausdenken, das ist das Thema. Ursula von der Leyen hat nur ganz kurz hier angemerkt.
Gestern hatten wir den EU-Afrika-Gipfel und es ist jetzt unsere Aufgabe, uns dem globalen Süden zuzuwenden, denn sie haben dort Sonne, Wind, Wasserkraft. Es fehlt an Infrastruktur, aber hier kann wirklich eine grüne Wasserstoffinfrastruktur aufgebaut werden. Und wie gesagt, wir haben bereits Pipelines, die wir nutzen können. Und dann haben wir wirklich ein ganz neues Business-Unternehmensmodell für den globalen Süden. Unsere afrikanischen Freunde beispielsweise, hier gibt es dann auch grünen Wasserstoff für den globalen Süden. Und diese erneuerbaren Energien sind sauber, sie sind gut für den Planeten, aber sie werden eben auch vor Ort produziert und sind daher gut für unsere Unabhängigkeit.
So, Christian Lindner, immerhin Bundesminister, saß ja bei Anneville und hat gesagt, wir werden niemals in Deutschland uns selbst versorgen können mit Energie. Wir werden immer importieren müssen. Dann hat Robert Habeck, auch Bundesminister, gesagt, ich weiß nicht mehr in welcher Sendung, der Vorteil an Sonne und Wind ist ja, das gehört ja niemandem. Ist also sehr friedensstiftend. Jetzt hören wir hier aber, naja, es wird Afrika gehören. Also zumindest brauchen wir Afrika dafür. Es ist ja wirklich die Frage, gestalten wir jetzt dieses Geschäftsmodell mit Afrika oder machen wir es wie die letzten 200 Jahre, fallen da einfach ein, ignorieren auch alle Streitigkeiten vor Ort und sagen, liebe Westsahara, wir wissen ja, gibt es Krieg und so, aber wir nehmen euch trotzdem mal, weil wir das Gemüse brauchen.
Und ihr bekommt so eine kleine Rente dafür, dass ihr das hier zur Verfügung stellt. Also die Kräfteverhältnisse sind ja sehr klar verteilt und ob das ein solidarisches Miteinander gibt. Also wir sprechen ja im Salon über, gemeinsam lesen wir das, das Buch Der Kampf der Nationen. Und da geht es ja darum, dass Europa sich eigentlich blockiert, indem die Nationen untereinander wirtschaftlich gegeneinander kämpfen und in diesen Wettbewerb treten. Und da sehen wir das schon auf europäischer Ebene. Ich bin gespannt auf das Buch. Und dann auf afrikanischer Ebene ist es dann eher nochmal schwer. Und wir haben uns ja schon so lange zurückgehalten, dass auch andere schon mal gesagt haben, könnte interessant für uns werden.
China ist natürlich da präsent. Also in deren Sicht, ich verstehe das nicht, warum es hier so schwierig ist, so einen EU-Afrika-Gipfel einfach mal zu besprechen, weil niemand dran denkt, dass es ja auch von Relevanz ist. Aber ein anderes Sicherheitsthema, den Chips-Act, den gab es jetzt. Und der läuft auch ganz explizit unter europäischer Sicherheitspolitik. Denn zum einen hat die Presseabteilung ihre Verlautbarung gemacht von der Europäischen Kommission, aber Euronews zum Beispiel, die haben es drüber geschrieben, Microchips and Geopolitics. Also da ist es ganz explizit. Denn bislang ist es ja so, 63% aller Chips kommen aus Taiwan. Es sind Friedenszeiten gerade zwischen China und Taiwan. Soweit kann man glaube ich gehen, das zu sagen. Und trotzdem stellen wir fest, irgendwo klemmt es an allen Ecken und Enden. Also da muss ja nun mal nur ein falsches Schiff über eine falsche Grenze fahren oder so. Und wenn da irgendeine Versorgung ausfällt, dann kann gar nichts mehr produziert werden. Wir brauchen also eigene Chips. 63% des ganzen Umsatzes mit Chips wurde über Taiwan abgewickelt. Also die Chips kamen aus Taiwan. Jetzt haben die Amerikaner schon ihren eigenen Chips for America Act mit 52 Milliarden Dollar Investitionsvermögen. Und die EU. Und das ist wieder so erstaunlich. Wir waren ja mal Weltmarktführer bei Solarzeug und sowas. 1990, in den 90ern, war 40% des ganzen Chips markts europäisch. Jetzt weniger als 10%. Also wir haben ja einfach krass verloren. Wir hatten ja Siemens, Ericsson, Nokia und der ganze Kram. Ist alles verloren gegangen. Jetzt gibt es verschiedene Programme, zum Beispiel den Horizon Europe, was auch immer, das den Covid Recovery Fund, der wird auch nochmal herangezogen, und die nationalen Budgets, das 11 Mrd. staatliche plus 32 gewollte private Investitionen sind, die also zu viel Geld, aber auch nicht ganz aufschließen kann, zu den 52 Mrd. Dollar die Amerika da anführt. Und 2020 als Referenzjahr flossen 3% der weltweiten Investitionen in die Chip-Produktion nach Europa, also verschwindend gering. Und jetzt allerdings hat sich Intel schon entschieden, in Magdeburg sollen große Chips-Werke entstehen. Also da werden mehrere Milliarden investiert. Mal gucken, wie weit man es da treiben kann.
Wie muss ich mir das vorstellen, wenn man jetzt sagt, man errichtet da eine Fabrik dafür? Hat man dort auch dann ein Know-how zu haben? Also wird damit auch entwickelt und getan? Oder ist das reine Produktion? Das heißt, wer arbeitet da eigentlich, frage ich mich dann? Natürlich viele Maschinen, aber welche Personal?
Sehr viele Maschinen, aber auch die Ingenieure aus Deutschland in dem Fall. Also da müssen wirklich Menschen vor Ort arbeiten. Und es ist ja auch nicht so bei den Chips, dass man designt in Kalifornien so etwas entwirft und dann auf der anderen Seite der Welt eine Fabrik umsetzt. Sondern das muss doch sehr verzahnt sein. Frank Krieger hat mir das vor 10 Jahren oder so mal beschrieben, dass sie dann einfach so eine Fabrik bauen, in der Hoffnung, dass es irgendwie geht. Und wenn es dann geht, am Ende geht es halt. Aber die Fabrik dann einfach mal nachzubauen, weil hat ja funktioniert, ist auch nicht so einfach. Sondern da muss man dann schon genau achten, wo liegen hier die Wasserrohre? Vielleicht liegt es einfach daran, dass die Platten so schön am Ende da rauskamen. Also das ist super kompliziert. In deren Sicht ist das nicht ohne Grund so massiert in Taiwan, weil man da einfach so Hotspot-mäßig das irgendwie alles vor Ort braucht. Jetzt versucht man das so ein bisschen aufzudröseln. Und die Europäer gehen auch wirklich radikal ran, denn die wollen nicht nur so die Alltags-Chips, die jeder bauen kann, die man so für ganz spezifische Anwendungen in der Waschmaschine oder so, sondern die wollen so richtig an diese 2, 3, 4 Nanometer neue Technologie ran. Also wo wirklich die Transistoren so richtig eng beieinander, also auch wahnsinnig schnell miteinander arbeiten können. Dazu zumindest gab es nachrichtliche Berichterstattung.
Spätestens die Pandemie hat allen gezeigt, wie abhängig Europa ist. Dass, wenn in Asien ein Hafen wegen Quarantäne schließt, bei deutschen Autoherstellern die Montagestraßen ins Stocken geraten. Ohne Mikrochips läuft nichts. Sie stecken überall drin und kommen aus Regionen, die geopolitisch umkämpft sind, wie Taiwan. Der Chips-Act ist also der Versuch, Europa unabhängiger zu machen, Erwachsener selbstständiger. Auch der Versuch, die Globalisierung ein Stück zurückzudrehen.
Man müsste auch immer noch gleich dazu sagen, und um gegen die Inflation zu kämpfen.
Gegen alles.
Wir haben ja immer noch sehr stark diesen Diskurs, was kann die EZB jetzt tun? Und wenn man einfach sagt, es sind keine Chips da, das heißt, die neuen Autos sind nicht da. Was bedeutet das für den Gebrauchtwagenmarkt? Naja, dass der leergefegt ist und dass da jetzt horrende Preise verlangt werden für Autos, wo man früher dachte, naja, die können ja froh sein, wenn sie den loswerden.
Genau, also die Chips sind das Nadelöhr, daran hängt einfach alles. Und das hat man im heutigen All hier auch gehört. Das war ja ein nicht hinterfragter Tonfall, der da drin steckte, dass das gerade nationale Sicherheitspolitik ist, die da stattfindet. Oder zumindest europäische Sicherheitspolitik, also der kontinentale Sicherheitspolitik. Und erstaunlicherweise gibt es ja dann doch ein paar Themen, wo auch die knausrigen Frugalen in Europa sagen, ja dafür können wir auch mal Schulden aufnehmen. Das ist hier zum Beispiel der Fall.
Europa versucht, mit China und den USA mitzuhalten, Subventionen auszuschütten und Wettbewerbsregeln zu lockern. Und das sonst so kritische Europaparlament findet das genau richtig. Selbst Abgeordnete aus Ländern, die mit Steuergeld eigentlich geizen. Die Halbleiterindustrie ist keine normale Branche. Es geht hauptsächlich um Geopolitik. Das bedeutet, dass sich alle Staaten bemühen und einmischen. Und wenn Europa das nicht tut, spielen wir nicht mehr mit. Europa also mischt sich ein, versucht, mit den Großen mitzuspielen. Der Slogan vom Parlament ist wie für den Chips-Act gemacht. Die Zukunft liegt in euren Händen.
Die Niederländer sind ja fast noch knausenriger als wir eigentlich. Aber selbst hier sagen sie, ja, das hat alles total Sinn, das müssen wir machen. Die Niederländer haben aber auch ALS bei sich. Also diesen Maschinenbauer, der die Maschinen baut für die Chips-Produktion, die in Taiwan da so wichtig ist. Wahrscheinlich das größte wirtschaftspolitische Nadelöhr überhaupt. Zumindest das ist dann noch in Europa. Und jetzt hören wir mal diese Zahlen im Vergleich. Also hier haben wir jetzt wirklich einen Wirtschaftsweltkrieg der Regionen Amerika, EU gegen China.
Die EU wird sich ganz schön strecken müssen, um mit der Konkurrenz mitzuhalten. Kritiker meinen, dass der Zug schon längst abgefahren sein könnte, bis die ersten europäischen Chips aus der EU-Initiative vom Band laufen vergehen schließlich noch Jahre. Außerdem stecken die Amerikaner und die Asiaten zum Teil erheblich mehr Geld in die Chip-Entwicklung. Zum Vergleich. 43 Milliarden Euro will die EU in den nächsten Jahren investieren. Bescheiden im Vergleich zu China, da sind es 132 Milliarden Euro. Die europäische Subventionspolitik hat nicht nur mehr Versorgungssicherheit zum Ziel, sondern auch technologische Führerschaft. Das Geld soll Chip-Hersteller nach Europa locken und so die EU unabhängiger machen.
Das ist ja jetzt auch ein Kampf um Köpfe. Das ist ja nicht nur ein Kampf um Geld. Jetzt haben wir ja gesehen, wie in China gerade Olympia organisiert wird. Da kann also jeder im Fernsehen zugucken und sich fragen, will ich da leben? Weil ich finde, so ein bisschen zu sagen, die Deutschen haben ja nur 43 Milliarden mobilisiert und die Chinesen aber 130 Milliarden und so. Vielleicht reichen ja einfach 43 Milliarden. Es mangelt ja nicht immer nur an Geld. Gerade bei diesen Chips, da geht es ja nur wirklich um Werten. Und echt mal eine Fabrik und so weiter. Die muss ja nicht dann 1 Billion kosten, sondern...
Die sollen ja auch dann hier was verdienen. Also es soll ja nicht nur darum gehen, dass man eine Förderung macht und sagt, es ist ja nicht eine Staatsproduktion, die man da einleitet, sondern es ist ja eine Förderung, die man gibt, damit sich dann privatwirtschaftlich da etwas erzeugen lässt. Und jetzt gibt es Leute wie Yevgeny Morozov, die auch sagen, naja, das können die eigentlich ins Reich der Fantasien schieben, was sie da glauben, welche Nano-Chips sie da bauen können. Das kann ich nicht beurteilen. Ich glaube aber, das Argument, das du bringst, ist das Entscheidende zu sagen, die Attraktivität eines Landes. Die sollte man nie unterschätzen, denn wir haben mit hier diesem Ortsbonus einen Vorteil, wo man sich gut überlegt. Generell könnten viele Leute, die jetzt Homeoffice machen, oder wir können den Podcast ohne, dass wir uns gegenüber sitzen, machen, dann wandere ich jetzt ein Land aus, wo ich dreimal mehr Geld habe, weil da alles so billig ist.
Die ganzen Influencer in Dubai, die kommen alle zurück.
Will ich das jetzt wirklich machen? Würde ich nicht am Ende sagen, ich setze mich lieber wieder hier in die Bahn und ärgere mich, dass sie zu spät kommt, bevor ich ausgeraubt werde?
Warum geht Tesla nach Berlin? Weil da ganz viele Autoingenieure sind, die sich denken, ich fand es schon immer blöd in Wolfsburg, warum kann ich nicht in Berlin leben? Und jetzt macht Tesla denen das Angebot. Also gehen alle, die was auf sich halten und das Bewerbungsverfahren durchlaufen, mit dem Hintergrund, ich komme ja von VW, die gehen natürlich zu Tesla, weil die jetzt einfach damit in Berlin leben können. Und wenn Berlin, Wolfsburg schon so ein Standortvorteil ist, dass Tesla sagt, dann investieren wir unsere Milliarden und Milliarden dort, dann ist die Idee, also gehe ich jetzt nach Deutschland oder nach China, für den einen oder anderen amerikanischen, was weiß ich, afrikanischen neuen Chip Auskennner und so weiter, natürlich eine andere Frage.
Und da kann man auch nochmal mit etwas anderem locken, nämlich mit Staatsbürgerschaft. Nicht vielleicht, also man muss vorsichtig umgehen. Man darf da auch nicht eine Ungleichverteilung dann nur noch machen, aber das ist ja etwas, was Branko Milanovic immer sehr stark macht. Also der Ortsbonus, das ist eigentlich die größte Ungleich, oder die andere große Ungleichheit in dieser Welt, die bekämpft werden muss. Und man kann natürlich das erstmal für sich ausnutzen als Europa und sagen, wir bieten hier zumindest Privilegien an, die nicht einfach wieder futsch sind, wenn du entlassen bist. Also dass du auch zum Beispiel die Möglichkeit hast, wenn sich da etwas nicht ermöglicht, dass du nochmal sagst, diese Leute haben aber dann auf jeden Fall zwei Jahre hier, wo sie Zeit haben, sich was Neues zu suchen. Und die müssen dann keine Arbeitserlaubnis und dann das Land verlassen.
Ja, wobei Staatsbürgerschaft, ich denke immer so bei Unternehmen wie Intel, Google, Apple und so weiter, Tesla, du bist halt Mitglied dieser Organisation. Du sagst dann, ich arbeite bei Tesla in Deutschland.
Also du hast ja vielleicht noch Familie und so.
Naja, aber der Nationalstaat ist dann vielleicht, also klar, das Gebiet ist dann wichtig und so weiter, aber ob man dann wirklich die Urkunde hat oder nicht, ist dann fast egal. Nur braucht man, um sich hier resilient zu bringen, Geld. Also Europa, auch wenn sie darauf hoffen, dass hier 30 Milliarden privates Geld, 11 Milliarden staatliches Geld muss schon sein. Selbst die Niederländer sagen, ja ja, Geld, das muss schon fließen. Christian Linden haben wir eben schon gehört, im Bundestag hat an seiner kleinen Fragestunde gegeben, das macht ihm unglaublich viel Spaß, da einfach seine rhetorischen Fähigkeiten stehend im Parlament noch mal einen Anklang zu bringen. Und wir hören ihn hier. Er bekommt Fragen des SPD-Lers Johannes Schraps.
Und trotzdem stehen auch in der nächsten Zeit sehr viele wichtige wirtschafts- und finanzpolitische Weichenstellungen auf europäischer Ebene bevor. Die Stichworte dazu sind sicherlich die Debatte über die Weiterentwicklung des Stabilitäts- und Wachstumspakts, aber auch die Umsetzung der globalen Mindestbesteuerung in Europa. Die Vollendung der Bankenunion oder eben auch die Debatte über neue Eigenmittel in der Europäischen Union. Sie haben gerade die Motivation der Bundesregierung ja schon mal angesprochen. Trotzdem ist eine gewisse Prioritätensetzung sicherlich notwendig. Deshalb würde ich gerne noch mal nachfragen, welches aus Ihrer Sicht die Reformvorhaben sind, die sie auf europäischer Ebene für vordringlich halten.
Schon ganz ohne Ukraine und Russland und Gasversorgung und überhaupt Energie als Grundlage der Wirtschaft. Ohne Energie ist alles nichts. Da kriegt er hier diese Frage. Wir sagen, was sind jetzt Ihre Grundprinzipien? Worum geht es Ihnen? Was wollen Sie als Europäischer Finanzminister in Europa machen, das wichtigste Land? Jetzt hat er schon angefangen, eine Liste aufzuzielen. Die Liste ist noch zu klein, die ist noch viel größer. Meine Aufgaben sind viel größer. Dann nennt er mal seine Top 3. Dann kriegen wir einfach nur das Gruseln.
Es steht sogar noch mehr an. Wir haben Banken- und Kapitalmarktunion, Stabilitäts- und Wachstumspakt, Umsetzung des Inclusive Frameworks der OECD, aber eben auch die Entscheidung über Eigenmittel der Europäischen Union.
Haben alle gehört, wie er die Taxonomie hier ausgeklammert hat? Nachher am Bundestag, von gestern wird er es ja noch mal richtig begraben.
Das heißt, es ist eine sehr dichte Agenda auf der europäischen Ebene. Und es gibt Ankündigungen seitens des Chefs der Eurogruppe, der französischen Ratspräsidentschaft und der Europäischen Kommission, dass in allen Bereichen in diesem Jahr Fortschritte erzielt werden sollen. Dafür ist die Bundesregierung offen. Sie wird auch eigene Vorschläge zu gegebener Zeit vorlegen. Wichtig ist für uns erstens die...
Erstens, ja, wir hören das jetzt an und vielleicht kann man sagen, er ist der gefährlichste Mann Europas. Es ist leider alles wahr geworden, was wir uns befürchtet haben mit Christian Linden als Finanzminister.
Finanzpolitische Eigenverantwortung der Mitgliedsstaaten der Europäischen Union, wie der Europäischen Wirtschafts- und Währungsunion. Zweitens die Mobilisierung von privaten und öffentlichen Mitteln für die transformativen Vorhaben. Und drittens, wir wollen sicherstellen, dass wir einen nachvollziehbaren, verbindlichen Schulden-Abbau-Fahrt in den nächsten Jahren erreichen. Und die unterschiedlichen Handlungsfelder, die sie genannt haben, sind dort in spezifischer Weise voll.
Und deswegen ist wirklich Vorsicht geboten, wenn jetzt so getan wird, wir helfen dann der Ukraine. Sicherheitspolitisch ist das absolut richtig. Aber uns ist das Wohlergehen der Bürger schon der eigenen Europäischen Union scheißegal. Und das muss man festhalten. Und das ist auch nicht hier Whataboutism und all das, was dann irgendwelche Linksliberalen in einem vorwerfen. Nein, es ist einfach so, dass wir einen Menschen jetzt im Finanzministerium haben, der dafür sorgen wird, dass es ganz vielen Menschen in Europa noch schlechter geht, als es ihnen ohnehin jetzt schon ergeht. Und das ist dann auf so Punkte wie, wir müssen Schuldenbremse einhalten, wir müssen die Schulden abbauen, zu beziehen. Und private Investitionen meint Deutschland First.
Genau. Er meint nicht mal nur die Schuldenbremse, sondern er will noch einen Schuldenabbau forcieren. Und da frage ich mich, welche Spielräume sieht er denn da? Er kriegt jetzt auch von Schrapps nochmal die Nachfrage. Naja, aber sie sehen schon auch, was die Vorstöße in Italien und Frankreich und so bedeuten. Die wollen ja nun schon so einen Schritt weitergehen. Wenn man sich vergleichend anschaut, dass in Japan irgendwie der Schuldenstand bei 250% BIP ist und in Amerika bei 130% und in der EU weit, also ganz EU bei 68%, dass wir hier also noch mega Spielräume haben, um jetzt einfach mal den großen Sprung nach vorne zu machen.
Ich würde gern zur Bankenunion nochmal konkret nachfragen. Da haben wir ja auch uns die Vollendung der Bankenunion im Koalitionsvertrag auf die Fahnen geschrieben. Ich würde gern nochmal genau von Ihnen wissen, was aus Ihrer Sicht jetzt die nächsten konkreten Schritte sind, um im Bereich der Vollendung der Bankenunion voranzukommen. Wir haben ein Gespräch zwischen den Finanzministerinnen und Finanzminister. Ich führe auch viele bilaterale Gespräche. Ich war gerade in der Frage kürzlich in Rom. Sie wissen, dass zwischen Deutschland und Italien ein Gesprächspunkt die Berücksichtigung von Staatsverschuldung auf den Bilanzen privater Banken ist. Wir wollen einen ganzheitlichen Ansatz bei der Bankenunion. Das heißt, wir wollen sowohl die Problematik Staatsverschuldung in Banken, Einlagesicherung und Liquiditäts- und Kapitalflüsse zwischen einzelnen Mitgliedstaaten der Europäischen Union gemeinsam angehen. Wichtig für Deutschland ist, eine starke nationale Komponente bei der Einlagensicherung muss erhalten bleiben. Eine voll vergemeinschaftete Einlagensicherung ist nicht in unserem Interesse.
Ja, sowas löst keinen Shitstorm aus, müsste es aber eigentlich. Das ist das Problem, weil die meisten Leute, die da auf Twitter sich gerne äußern und die die Nachrichten kommentieren und Kolumnen schreiben, keine Ahnung, von Ökonomiehalmen. Es ist so entsetzlich, das zu hören. Und ich glaube ja auch, dass das dann insgesamt gilt für Investitionen, Klimatransformation. Also ich würde sagen, ich bin seit gestern pessimistischer denn je. Ich bin ja wieder mit dem Zug gefahren, die Schweiz hin und zurück. 50 Minuten Verspätung und 45 Minuten Verspätung. Ich glaube, es wird so sein, wie Michel Wabeck in Vernichten beschreibt, Frankreich 27, es gibt keine Mittelklassewagen mehr, weil es keine Mittelklasse mehr gibt. Es gibt noch Autos für Reiche und irgendwie die Armen, die fahren dann so kleine Autoschen rum und können sich aber kaum noch das Tanken leisten. Und Mobilität ökologisch korrekt wird meinen. Die meisten sind immobil und die wenigen können sich mobil korrekt bewegen mit Tesla und irgendwie Flugkompensatoren, bla bla bla. Und für die meisten wird es richtig schwarz aussehen in Deutschland und noch viel dunkler in den anderen europäischen Ländern.
Lindner kennt ja die Pläne von Macron und Draghi, wie die jetzt einfach sagen, wir brauchen jetzt die europäische Wirtschaftsschicksalsgemeinschaft. Wir müssen alles in die Waagschale werfen gemeinsam. Und dann sagt Christian Lindner, wir können gern alles ins Papier schreiben. Wir können dann auch gerne Bankenunion oder was auch immer Bankenunion, also dass für alle Banken in Europa die gleichen Regeln gelten. Wenn es aber um die finanzielle Verantwortung geht, da spielt bitte jedes Land für sich. Was im Grunde heißt, eure Pläne werden alle nichtig sein. Die werden alle nur als Präampel auf dem Papier stehen. Aber da wo es hart auf hart kommt, spielt das dann keine Rolle. Und das, und so finde ich, haben wir jetzt auch einen guten Fokus gelegt, um jetzt dem Bundestag von gestern, wo ja nun das Geld rausgeschüttet wurde, uns anzuhören. Denn da hat sich ja Lindner ja dann auch zu Wort gemeldet. Wir beginnen mal hier bei Olaf Scholz mit seinem Vorschlag für die 100 Millionen.
Der Bundeshaushalt 2022 wird dieses Sondervermögen einmalig mit 100 Milliarden Euro ausstatten. Die Mittel werden wir für notwendige Investitionen und Rüstungsvorhaben nutzen. Wir werden von nun an Jahr für Jahr mehr als zwei Prozent des Bruttoinlandsprodukts in unsere Verteidigung investieren.
Ja, also dieser Hurra-Patriotismus, der ist total verlogen, weil wir gerade diese Clips gehört haben und wir alles weitere gehört haben. Es ist unerträglich und da würde ich auch sagen, können wir hier schon mal, wo wir eben schon bei Ideologiekritik waren, sagen, das ist bürgerliche Ideologie. Also bürgerliche Ideologie meint gar nicht die Ideologie für die Bürger, denn die würden ja einfach von der besseren Bahn profitieren und von dem Solarpanel auf dem Dach, sondern bürgerliche Ideologie meint, ah, wir müssen jetzt diesen bürgerlichen Staat verteidigen und da gehen wir jetzt mal ordentlich für Rüstung aus. Wir wissen zwar noch gar nicht genau, was wir damit machen. Wir haben eigentlich die ganze Zeit nur gepennt in Bezug auf Russland und jetzt kommt dieser Aktionismus und jetzt wird Geld rausgepulvert, ohne Ende und bürgerliche Ideologie meint dann auch, da kommt halt dann niemand mehr auf die Idee, nächste Woche zu sagen, wir brauchen hier mal auch 100 Milliarden für dies und das. Das wird nämlich dann nicht eintreten und auch nicht bei Grünen und so wird das auch nicht eintreten, weil die auch in ihrem Refinanzierungsdenken stecken geblieben sind und es ist unglaublich traurig.
Ja, also das ist auch ein echtes Problem, denn man traut sich hier selbst nicht über den Weg. 100 Milliarden für die Verteidigung, was auch immer Verteidigung bedeutet. Also nachdem jetzt selbst die Energiepolitik da groß mit reinfließt, ist jetzt das Aufstellen eines Windrads plötzlich, also zählt das zu 100 Milliarden?
Das wäre eigentlich lustig, wenn man jetzt sagt, nee das meint ja jetzt eigentlich alles nur Windräder.
Genau, es wird natürlich sehr so Bundeswehr und so NATO-Kram bedeuten, aber was auch immer, jetzt geht es ja in die Ebene und jetzt muss man das alles mal durch die Mühle drehen. Aber Scholz hat ja noch diesen Spruch hier gemacht.
Ich richte mich hier an alle Fraktionen des Deutschen Bundestages. Lassen Sie uns das Sondervermögen im Grundgesetz absichern.
Wir haben ja nun diese Clips gehört von Michael Hüther, von Jens Südekum, das ganze Spektrum der Ökonome, die sagen, Schuldenbremse ist eigentlich das Misstrauen-Statement gegenüber dem Parlament, weil man den Parlamentariern gar nicht zutraut und ihnen auch nicht die Gelegenheit gibt, inhaltlich Politik zu machen. Man sichert es einfach im Grundgesetz ab, damit ist das Ding geregelt. Und jetzt kann man gar keine kluge Politik oder irgendeine Politik machen, weil es steht ja im Grundgesetz, dass man es nicht darf. Dieser 100 Milliarden, wenn jetzt wirklich die große Einigkeit da wäre, dass das notwendig und wichtig wäre, dann würde man doch eigentlich vermuten, dass das nicht nur heute im Parlament bejubelt wird, sondern auch in zwei Jahren. Dass man dann immer noch sagt, das war die beste Idee aller Zeiten, müssen wir gar nicht drüber reden, ist hiermit... Warum soll das jetzt im Grundgesetz abgesichert werden? Die wissen doch selber, dass das irgendwie bescheuert ist, dass man es lieber schnell wieder aus der Diskussion rausnimmt. Und man dann später einfach sagt, ich weiß, liebe Linken, ihr habt hier ganz viele Ansprüche gerade an uns und habt auch tolle Anträge geschrieben, aber es steht im Grundgesetz, da kann man nichts machen. Dieses Geld ist gebunden, weil das ist einfach absolute Banane.
Ja, ja, und weil man auch jetzt ist natürlich die CDU ganz dafür und wir haben es ja immer schon gesagt und bla bla bla, von wegen haben sie ja eben nicht, hätten sie ja machen können. Mehrheiten gab es ja immer für solche Geschichten. Und es wird ja so sein, wenn man das jetzt nicht möglichst schnell dann das Grundgesetz reinbekommt, dann fängt er auch mal die CDU an zu telefonieren.
Das ist wie die Impfpflicht.
Und dann sagen die auch, ja Moment, also dann müssen wir das aber noch so ausgestalten, so ausgestalten und so. Und da hat auch jeder noch mal einen eigenen Waffenhändler an der Strippe. Da wird man das schnell machen. Man könnte jetzt diesen Hurra-Patriotismus nehmen und sagen, wir brauchen jetzt immer 100 Milliarden mehr. Und das nennen wir aber, das ist das Souveränitätspaket. Das wird auch ein schöner Begriff. Und da könnten aber dann die Windräder rein, weil die uns ja souverän machen. Aber so clever wird man nicht sein, sondern das wird wahrscheinlich sehr stark auf das militärische, auf Aufrüstung im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes gehen. Und das ist...
Ja, ein Ding, das seit gestern so ein bisschen untergebutert wurde hier in der Rede.
Gut ist auch, dass die Verträge zur Euro-Drohne in dieser Woche endlich unterzeichnet werden konnten. Auch die Anschaffung der bewaffneten Heron-Drohne aus Israel treiben wir voran.
So, mal eben schnell die bewaffneten Drohnen angeschafft.
Jetzt kommt alles, also die Krise wird hier mal wieder genutzt. Das, was man nicht geschafft hat bei Corona im Sinne von wir machen jetzt mal was für das Soziale, für junge Menschen und so weiter. Aber hier einspalt die Tür auf und jetzt kommt alles. Da wird der Seeheimer Kreis auch noch mal schnell aktiv. Da wird alles möglich.
Ja, und jetzt hören wir mal, wie Scholz das formuliert mit dieser erneuerbaren Energien sind sich als Politik.
Wir werden umsteuern, umsteuern, um unsere Importabhängigkeit von einzelnen Energielieferanten zu überwinden. Eine verantwortungsvolle, vorausschauende Energiepolitik ist nicht nur entscheidend für unsere Wirtschaft und unser Klima, sondern entscheidend auch für unsere Sicherheit. Deshalb gilt, je schneller wir den Ausbau erneuerbarer Energien vorantreiben, desto besser.
Ja, da sieht man hier schon klug geschnitten von der Regie der Deutschen Welle.
Anton Hofreiter.
Anton Hofreiter, wie er sich in seine Maske übergibt, denn das muss jetzt erst mal argumentiert werden. Von seiner Seite aus, dass man dieses Programm ja dann doch irgendwie als grüne Partei so mitmacht.
Aber findest du, dass die Grünen damit ein Problem haben?
Also, an die Hofreiter hat damit ein Problem.
Ja, aber auch nur an Anton Hofreiter. Deswegen ist er ja auch nicht Vorsitzender geworden.
Wir sind alle sehr gespannt.
Sonst würde ich sagen, ist doch die Grünen hätten doch gerne schon viel mehr da in diese Richtung gemacht.
Also, Scholz und Baerbock sind pragmatisch, die nehmen jetzt den Spatz in die Hand.
Ja, aber wenn Grüne und Norbert Röttgen im Fernsehen sind, dann denkt man meistens, die heiraten gleich oder machen Kinder.
Ja, also ich meine, es gibt hier eine ganz große Alternative. Wir haben letztes Jahr im Mai, ich habe extra nochmal nachgeguckt, im Mai 2021 eine Rede von Joe Biden, da hat er so gesagt, das ist so 100 Tage, ich bin jetzt 100 Tage im Amt.
Genau, da war er dort.
Genau, da hat er ja so eine Art State of the Union, aber eben auch nur ein kleines Publikum wegen Corona und so. Da hat er ja so ganz nüchtern vorgetragen, wir sind in einem systemischen Streit mit China. Also mit China allgemein. Und dann hat er gesagt, ich habe viele Gespräche mit Xi gehabt als Vizepräsident und so weiter, mehrere Stunden, viele Konferenzen. Und ich kann euch sagen, der meint das total ernst, die wollen der neue Hegemon der Welt werden. Wir müssen also was dagegen stellen. Und dann hat er nicht gesagt, wir müssen uns energiepolitisch irgendwie unabhängig machen mit und so weiter. Und er hat auch nicht gesagt, wir müssen uns weiter aufrüsten, sondern er hat gesagt, wir müssen jetzt die Familie wieder an Klang bringen. Der Kern der amerikanischen Macht ist die Familie. Darauf basiert alles. Und davon hat man gar nichts gehört hier. Das war irgendwie, ja, wir sind irgendwie in Bredoje und müssen uns verteidigen. Ja, ja. Das einzige, was dann kam, waren hier so ein bisschen diese Brocken, die man so hingeschmissen hat.
Behalten wir bei all dem die hohen Energiepreise im Blick. Putins Krieg hat sie zuletzt noch weiter steigen lassen. Deshalb haben wir in dieser Woche ein Entlastungspaket vereinbart mit der Abschaffung der EEG-Umlage noch in diesem Jahr, einer Erhöhung der Pendlerpauschale, einem Heizkostenzuschuss für Geringverdiener, Zuschüssen für Familien und steuerlichen Entlastungen.
Ja, vielen Dank, Herr Scholz, aber wir zahlen immer noch 60 Milliarden pro Jahr in fossile Brennstoffe, nur über Subvention. Dieses Geld könnte man ja auch mal befreien, einfach für die Zukunft. Und ja, das würde bedeuten, und das sehen dann auch alle, dass es eine fossile Inflation gibt. Also wir haben ja vor allem Probleme mit den Preisen fossiler Brennstoffe gerade, sind ja nicht die Erneuerbaren, die uns irgendwie teuer sind. Die 4 Cent pro Kilowattstunde Strom aus Sonnenenergie, die ist sehr unschlagbar mittlerweile schon. Warum subventionieren wir immer noch den ganzen Rest? Müssten wir nicht da mal durch dieses tiefe Tal jetzt einfach mal hauruck durch, aber war alles nicht angesprochen? Stattdessen dieser alberne Diskussion, das Friedrich Merz hier nochmal so zu Wort meldet.
Wenn Sie es so wollen, wie Sie es heute morgen hier vorschlagen, dann können wir auch darüber, Herr Bundeskanzler, reden. Aber ein Sondervermögen ist nicht ein Vermögen, sondern ein Sondervermögen sind zunächst einmal neue Schulden. Und wie wir diese neuen Schulden aufnehmen und wie wir sie dann möglicherweise in unserer Verfassung verankern, das geht nicht allein mit einer Regierungserklärung am Sonntagmorgen zu machen. Darüber müssen wir dann in Ruhe und im Detail sprechen. Und lassen Sie mich auch dies ganz klar sagen. Lassen Sie mich hier dies ganz klar sagen. Das machen wir dann in allen Teilen gemeinsam, nicht in der Arbeitsteilung, dass wir mit Ihnen für die unangenehmen Dinge den Kopf hinhalten und Sie in Ihrer Koalition dann unverändert weiter alle Wohltaten zulasten der jungen Generation verteilen. Herr Bundeskanzler, das machen wir dann nicht.
Und diese Androhung wird vermutlich noch dazu führen. Also jetzt wird gerade diese Schulden werden aufgenommen. Wie sinnvoll diese Investitionen an sich sind, haben wir schon Frage gestellt. Aber die große Gefahr ist, dass wir tatsächlich noch auf diesen Punkt kommen. Auch wenn jetzt dann nicht gleich auf März das Zug aufspringt, dass wir die große Gefahr haben, dass man noch sagt, ja wir haben und Linden hat das ja schon vor in einem Interview vor einigen Tagen angedeutet. Wir haben den Sozialstaat zu groß aufgeblasen. Und jetzt müssen wir da mal noch kürzen. Brauchen wir eigentlich noch BAföG und so weiter. Denn wir müssen ja aufrüsten gegen die bösen Russen. Die werden ja sonst gleich morgen einfallen. Und das ist reine Propaganda.
Wir hören jetzt gleich mal von LIndner, wie er das auch im Bundestag noch mal argumentiert. Münkler hat das ja in irgendeinem Gespräch, ich habe es nur gelesen, ich habe es nicht gehört, auch noch mal betont, dass es immer diese Phasen gibt, der Friedensdividende, die dann eingefahren wird. Also Zweite Weltkrieg war so krass, dass man sich danach gar nicht mehr vorstellen konnte, als man den UN gegründet und alles dafür getan, dass es nie wieder dazu kommt. Also hatte man viel Geld für Sozialpolitik. Und diese Idee von LIndner dann aufgegriffen. Aber es ist ja Null so im Spiel. Sicherheitspolitik und Sozialpolitik. Man kann ja nicht beides machen, sondern es ist ja Null so im Spiel. Jetzt haben wir lange Sozialpolitik gemacht und keine Sicherheitspolitik. Jetzt müssen wir Sicherheitspolitik machen.
Bündner ist ja auch noch nicht angekommen in der finanziellen Moderne.
Bündner ist auch noch nicht beim Finanzkrieg angekommen und so weiter. Da ist auch für ihn noch viel nachzuarbeiten. Ich bin sehr gespannt, ob wir da noch was hören. Und jetzt hat ja Merz gerade gesagt, also diese Arbeitsteilung fände ich aber ganz schön blöd, wenn wir jetzt einfach immer nur noch abnicken sollen, die zukünftigen Generationen zu belasten mit den Schulden. Jetzt ist ja Lindner schon auf seiner Linie. Und wie er das im Bundestag argumentiert, fand ich abenteuerlich. Denn Olaf Scholz hat ja gesagt, 100 Milliarden sollen ad hoc zur Verfügung gestellt werden und dann pro Jahr das 2-Prozent-Ziel, was ja auch 20, 30 Milliarden mehr pro Jahr ab jetzt bedeutet. Und Christian Lindner hat wie folgt im Bundestag gesprochen.
Die Stabilität der öffentlichen Finanzen und die Handlungsfähigkeit des Staates müssen erhalten bleiben. Die Schuldenbremse gilt.
Die Schuldenbremse gilt.
Was bedeutet?
Bei dem Sondervermögen mal gucken. Zumindest, was diese Erhöhung der Verteidigungsausgaben, die gehen auf Kosten anderer Posten.
Ja, das machen jetzt SPD und Grüne mit. Und das müssten sie nicht, beziehungsweise die SPD will das ja sogar. Zumindest der Seeheimer Kreis und Klingbeil ist ja da vom Seeheimer Kreis quasi und hat ja da einen guten Draht zu allen, die ein bisschen was mit Pistolen und so zu tun haben und die da verticken. Also das ist so eine Katastrophe und wir erleben hier eigentlich auch eine Revival der 80er Jahre. Denn unter Ronald Reagan war es ja so, dass er sagte, wir haben zu hohe Staatsschulden. Und wenn man sich seine Amtszeit ansieht, wurden die Schulden dann eigentlich noch erhöht. Aber was geschah, man hat den Wehr-Etat immer weiter ausgebaut und hat zugleich die Sozialleistungen und alles, was den Staat sonst ausmacht, zusammengekürzt. Und das streben die jetzt wieder an. Und das ist eigentlich für uns die größte Katastrophe jetzt bei dem Angriff von Putin, dass hier Putin Türen aufmacht, genau für Leute wie Lindner und dann auch die Neoliberalen bei den Grünen und der SPD.
Und Lindner sagt es hier ganz explizit.
Wir werden deshalb in der laufenden Finanzplanung und in jedem Haushaltsjahr die Mittel für den Verteidigungshaushalt erhöhen. Wir werden den laufenden Betrieb der Bundeswehr aus den laufenden Haushalten unter Achtung der Schuldenbremse finanzieren.
Und dass das kein Shitstorm auslöst, dass das überhaupt nicht Leute in Wannung bringt, sondern alle nur in so eine Menschlenden, wir müssen da irgendwie helfen und jetzt müssen wir zusammenstehen und sonst was. Also wirklich, es ist das geistige Niveau der meisten Leute, die sich jetzt zu dem ganzen Konflikt äußern, kann man wirklich in die Tonne treten.
Also der Bundesverhalter ist nicht besonders groß, das sind 350 Milliarden oder so. Wenn da jetzt allein die Erhöhung des Verteidigungshaushalts 10% davon nimmt, dann heißt das irgendwie am Ende wird Hubertus Heil streichen müssen, denn es ist vor allem das Sozialministerium über den Zuschuss zur Rentenkasse, 100 Milliarden, da kann man was nehmen, Arbeitslosengeld 2, wie auch immer. Also irgendwo muss Bildung, könnte alles wieder zusammen streichen. Also ich verstehe das überhaupt nicht, dass das hier so nicht diskutiert wurde. Klar, das ist erst Montag und es ist gestern passiert, aber trotzdem, das muss eine mega Diskussion sein.
Das muss jetzt passieren, denn die machen das jetzt ganz schnell. Also das ist ja absichtlich alles so schnell gemacht, damit niemand mehr widersprechen kann. Deswegen, wenn man jetzt nicht widerspricht und die grüne Jugend hat es dann ein bisschen getan, aber von den Jusos und so kam da ja einfach nichts. Das ist absolut enttäuschend. Also dieser Kadavergehorsam von Parteiangehörigen schockiert mich, der natürlich nie in der Partei war, immer wieder aufs Neue.
Und jetzt hören wir nochmal seine Antwort auf Friedrich Merz, der ja eben schon meint, der Pipapo und so, also laufende Kosten, die Erhöhung des Bundeswehrhaushalts wird aus dem Haushalt bezahlt, auf Kosten anderer Posten. Ich weiß nicht genau, worum es jetzt hier geht.
Die Investitionen in die Bundeswehr, lieber Friedrich Merz, die sollten sie nicht führen mit der Warnung von neuen Schulden. Das sind in Wahrheit natürlich Kredite, die wir aufnehmen in den nächsten Jahren. Aber in dieser Weltlage sind es zunächst und zumeist Investitionen in unsere Freiheit.
Vielleicht bezieht das sich auf die 100 Milliarden oder so, oder die auch noch aus dem Bundeshaushalt kommen. Christian Lindner hat noch hier diesen kleinen Spruch gemacht, den hören wir nur aus Interesse. Wir haben ja sehr viel über die Taxonomie letzte Woche gesprochen. Das große Aufwachstumsversprechen für die Zukunft, der große Aufbruch. Bei Christian Lindner klingt das unglaublich krass. Er macht hier einfach, also im Grunde die Kriegsführung gegen die Europäische Union.
Wir haben viele Jahre eine Friedensdividende genutzt. Bundeswehr wurde vernachlässigt. In diesen Tagen wurde noch über eine Taxonomie gesprochen, die Investitionen in Verteidigungsfähigkeit eingeschränkt hätte.
Als ob das schon abgeräumt wäre so, ja?
Also Christian Lindner, das geht ja ein bisschen zu weit. Ich habe gestern ja auch Widerspruch erfahren. Wenn man dann anguckt, anklickt, das sind dann Profile wirklich von grünen Politikern. Ich will die grüne Jugend da ausnehmen, aber auch von jungen grünen Politikern. Man sagen muss, eure ideologische Verbohrung wird uns klimapolitisch in ein Desaster führen. Da wird ja mit eurer Kritik, die ihr an Merkel immer formuliert habt, noch zaghaft, wenn ihr dann seht, was ihr anrichtet.
Also in der Ansicht, das ist keine gute Aussicht, die wir gestern serviert bekommen haben.
Sollen wir mal wirklich was Lustiges machen?
Ja, zeig uns mal die Bitcoins.
Jetzt machen wir mal Sternstunden des Bitcoins. Also Sternstunden der Philosophie. Jeder kennt diese Schweizer Sendung.
Ich habe sie mir jetzt nicht angehört vorher.
Oft lautet ja die Frage, egal welcher Gast da ist, was hätte Hannah Arendt dazu gesagt? Aber darum ging es diesmal nicht.
Übrigens, dieser ewige Verweis auf Hannah Arendt und so weiter, was sie hat überdreißert. Ich habe bei Moritz in seinem Podcast, der ich mir jetzt, ich weiß gar nicht genau, wie er es nennt, aber da macht er auch so einen kleinen soziologischen Monolog und hat darauf verwiesen, dass Niklas Lumans Einführung in die Systemtheorie, eine Vorlesung, die so auf Kassetten und so weiter immer so kursierte, die ist jetzt offiziell veröffentlicht von irgendeinem Verlag. Ich werde es verlinken. Ich mache mir eine Notiz und da wird am Anfang, Luhmann macht das ja super clever, weil Luhmann viel gelesen hat, dann weiß man ja, was er da, also wie er so diese Vorlesung aufbaut. Und da kommt er auch am Anfang noch mal drauf zu sprechen, so die erste Stunde und sagt so ja, Soziologie liegt da am Boden und da ist ja auch nichts mehr zu gebrauchen. Und diese Theoriearmut sieht man vor allem daran, dass man sich immer auf die Klassiker bezieht. Und da habe ich gesagt, ja, das stimmt. Und das muss man auch immer wieder deutlich sagen. Wir müssen jetzt wirklich mal Pflöcke einschlagen. So wie wir hören, ist dann ganz deutlich, wie Olaf Scholz einfach ins Amt geht und sagt, schöne Geschichte hatten wir bisher in Europa, aber ein paar Sachen gelten jetzt einfach mal in einem Satz. Und da muss man nicht ewig wieder ewig lang diskutieren und noch mal die Hannah Arendt und der hat es auch schon gesagt und so weiter. Und das finde ich ist ganz wichtig, das sollte man jetzt auch immer diesen Fernsehleuten wieder, also denen das wirklich vorwerfen.
Aber das eine ist ja, also ich würde da noch mal differenzieren, denn das eine ist ja Theorie, die zwar alt, aber brauchbar ist. Und das andere ist ja, ob man jetzt immer so diese Wünschenroute auspackt und sagt, was hat Hannah Arendt jetzt gerade dazu gesagt. Also das ist, ich bin jetzt nicht so ein Riesen Arendt-Fan, wie man weiß, aber manches ist auch interessant, also ihr Eichmann Buch ist sehr, sehr gut und manches aus Vita aktiver, das spricht mir auch zu. Aber ich glaube, die Sache ist ja, man kann mit Philosophien, die älter sind oder Theorien, die älter sind und Marx ist ja auch am Ende ein ökonomischer Philosoph auch, sehr viel anfangen. Ich glaube nur, wo das so in dieses, ich begebe mich ins Archiv und nehme das als Autoritätsargument, das hat Anna Arendt schon gesagt. Da würde ich sagen, ja, das kann die ja gesagt haben. Aber ich muss ja immer gucken, ob das Argument jetzt gerade gut ist. Denn das nutzt mir nichts, wenn damals die Konstellation so war, genauso wie man dann bei Marx mit manchen Dingen, nämlich dieser modernen Geldpolitik, nicht weiterkommt, weil das auch erstmal nicht Marx ins Thema war und weil es im 19. Jahrhundert auch nicht diese Art der Geldpolitik überhaupt geben konnte. Und das ist, glaube ich, dann diese Differenz, die man machen muss. Ich kann nur diesen Gang ins Archiv so wenig nachvollziehen, dass man den ständig machen will.
Genau, richtig. Wollte ich genauso sagen, du hast nochmal richtig den Finger drauf gelegt, mir geht es nicht um Hannah Arendt oder Marx und deren Leistung.
Du beziehst dich auch auf Luhmann, nicht weil Luhmann je bislünger ist als Hannah Arendt, aber du würdest jetzt nicht sagen, ja, wenn ich dir jetzt hier sage, aber Luhmann hat sich mal in einem Vortrag da so und so geäußert, da sagst du nicht, was mache ich denn, das stört zu meinem Weltbild zusammen. Da sagst du ja, gut, das ist für mich nicht wichtig, ich muss die Theorie da anwenden, wo sie anwendbar ist.
Arendt und Marx haben ihren intrinsischen Wert, der so wertvoll ist, dass man ihn anbringen kann, ohne immer wieder auf die Autorenschaft zu sprechen zu kommen. Und das ist das Problem. Und der Vorwurf richtet sich nur an die Fernsehmacher, die begründungslos dieses Namedropping betreiben, um um die Ideen dieser Menschen einen größtmöglichen Bogen zu machen. Weil das wäre dann eine Argumentation, die wäre auch wirklich aufwendig, uns das wirklich zu vergegenwärtigen. Marx heute und so, ist eine absolut notwendige Arbeit. Nur die umgeht man einfach, indem man sagt, hat ja Marx schon damals gesagt.
Genau. Und das macht ja Eilenberger, hat das ja zur Perfektion getrieben, allein schon dadurch, dass er, ja Eilenberger schreibt ja diese Geschichtsphilosophie-Bücher, dass er dann sagt, ich erzähle euch jetzt mal die Geschichte von Philosophen in den 30er Jahren und dann erfahre ich, was Hannah Arendt 1934 da und dort sitzend gesagt hat und Ayn Randt hat das und das gemacht. Mich interessieren diese Biografien nicht so besonders. Aber das ist, genau wie du sagst, genau die Möglichkeit, einem sehr bürgerlichen Publikum zu sagen, ihr wisst ja, Hochkultur, Philosophie, große Namen, großes Raunen und Staunen. Das Schlimmste wäre natürlich, man müsste jetzt wirklich mal die Texte lesen. Also erzähle ich euch lieber mal die Geschichte, die Hannah Arendt, die hat ja so unglaublich viel geraucht, sogar in den Vorlesungen hat die noch geraucht und so weiter. Also, Sternstunde Philosophie, Eilenberger moderiert, wer ist zu Gast?
Das diskutiere ich heute mit Roger Wattenhofer, Informatiker und Professor an der ETH Zürich und seit Jahrzehnten mit den Technologien hinter Kryptowährungen wie Bitcoin beschäftigt, sowie mit Ijoma Mangold, Literaturkritiker, Philosoph, Feuilletonist bei der Wochenzeitung Die Zeit und derart vom Phänomen Bitcoin fasziniert, dass er zurzeit an einem Buch zu diesem Thema sitzt.
Und das finde ich noch krasser als dieser Verweis auf Hannah Arendt. Er arbeitet gerade an einem Buch, das wir alle noch nicht kennen, er selber noch nicht, denn er hat es noch nicht auspopuliert, aber trotzdem Mangold.
Ja, Mangold und warum ausgerechnet Mangold, fragt man sich. Also er ist Literaturkritiker bei der Zeit.
Er arbeitet an einem Buch zum Thema, weißt du?
Er ist einfach davon fasziniert und alle sind jetzt fasziniert vom Bitcoin. Die Sternenstunde will dem nachgehen.
Ich meine, ist das auf einem Level mit, wir holen mal die Erststudenten in die Corona-Hilfe, weil wir zu wenig Personal haben?
Wir werden das jetzt gleich hören und deswegen, Spoiler schon mal, ich denke, es ist schlimmer. Deine Frage ist ja absolut berechtigt, warum sitzt Mangold da? Hören wir mal weiter.
Herr Mangold, die Potenziale sind groß. Das Geheimnis ist es auch. Sie sind ja nun von Hause Literaturkritiker, Gegenwartsbeobachter. Können Sie denn sagen, wann Sie zum ersten Mal als mutmaßlich Außenstehender von dem Phänomen Bitcoin und Blockchain gehört haben und was, wie man das heute so sagt, das mit Ihnen gemacht hat?
Mangold ist jetzt verwundert, überrascht über sich selbst.
Ja, tatsächlich bin ich ja selber von mir überrascht, dass ich als Ästhet, der sich sonst mit keine Ahnungmaße Proust und Goethe beschäftigt, plötzlich fasziniert bin von Technologie. Ich bin wirklich nicht dafür prädestiniert.
Ja, nehmen wir doch gleich mal Nikosen Ich, der immer im Dialog steht mit Proust und Goethe und nun der Bitcoin und…
Ist ihm das nicht selber peinlich, das so zu sagen, das so zu formulieren?
Nein, das ist eine ganz weihevolle Atmosphäre, also ich hab das so und ich hab zum Teil ja mal…
Also wir haben ja gerade, du hast ja Eilenberger auch gerade vorgestellt, dass jemanden, der, weil Hannah Arendt damals leider noch keine GoPro hatte oder ein Selfie, dass er das heute so nachbaut, wie das damals war. Würden wir, also interessieren wir uns jetzt für Mangols Morgenroutine, wann greift er zum Goethe, ist es noch bevor er aufsteht oder ist das erst am Frühstückstisch?
Ja, so sollen wir uns jetzt erst mal da einfinden und die Frage, die wir uns jetzt stellen sollten, ist natürlich nicht, warum interessiert sich Ejoma Mangold, den die meisten, die uns zuhören, vermutlich nicht kennen werden, für den Bitcoin, sondern die Frage, die uns jetzt natürlich hier leitet, ist, was sagt dieses Gespräch über die gesamte Bitcoin-Ideologie aus? Ich will es in aller Ausführlichkeit machen, denn es interessiert jetzt hier primär, wir lachen ein bisschen übers Fernsehen, aber uns primär interessiert uns die Bitcoin-Ideologie, die ich glaube, hier auf schönste Weise verdichtet gefunden habe.
Wir hören, wir gehen also nochmal dieser Spur nach. Wie kommt das? Der Literaturkritiker Proustkenner und der Bitcoin.
Aber tatsächlich hat es mich gepackt und typisches Phänomen. Es war natürlich ein Pandemie-Phänomen, als wir nämlich zum ersten Mal zurückgezogen Zeit hatten, uns so Deep Dive-mäßig auf irgendeinen neuen Gegenstand wirklich einzulassen. Und ich weiß, es ist nicht lange her, als ich Feuer gefangen habe, aber dann war es auch um mich geschehen. Es war Januar 2021.
Also Januar 2021 beschäftigt er sich jetzt zum ersten Mal mit dem Bitcoin und dann frage ich mich, was hat er sonst die letzten Jahre gemacht? Das hätte man ja früher tun können. Und dann ist er gleich so überzeugt und fasziniert davon, dass er ein Buch schreibt und aber auch schon vorab in der Fernsehsendung setzt. Was kann ihn so sehr gereizt haben?
Als ich anfing darüber nachzudenken, was meint eigentlich Bitcoin? Das ist eine digital erzeugte Knappheit. Das fand ich jetzt auch wirklich aus der philosophischen Perspektive so erstaunlich. Ich dachte bisher, Knappheit sei quasi eine Reale in der Welt.
Ja, das ist philosophisch ziemlich ja humbug. Also man kann ja einfach mal sich modernes Wirtschaften ansehen und den Umgang mit Knappheiten.
Vor allem die digital erzeugte Knappheit, also er arbeitet bei einer Zeitung, die wird digital vertrieben und da wird jeden Morgen ganz hart Zeitungsplatz verteilt. Und wenn man da Mangold sagt, sorry, aber dein Text ist zehn Zeilen zu lang, mach ihn mal kürzer. Das ist digitale Knappheit. Das ist für ihn jetzt ein völlig neues Phänomen.
Und digitale Knappheit ist auch, wenn jemand ein Zeit-Online-Abo abgeschlossen hat oder die E-Zeitung lesen kann, die elektronische Zeitung lesen kann, dann hat, wenn er bezahlt, bekommt er einen Zugang. Und wenn ich kein Abo abgeschlossen habe, wird das für mich digital verknappt und bekomme ich nämlich nicht daran, weil ich das nicht bezahlt habe.
Genau, dass man das nämlich erzeugen kann, das ist das Faszinierende.
Dass man es erzeugen kann und wir leben, also da ist wieder unser Punkt, da ist jemand nicht in der Moderne angekommen. Ja, natürlich, die meisten Knappheiten sind ja erzeugt. Natürlich kann man, man könnte jetzt auch die Produktion umstellen und sagen, wir machen jetzt Rolex-Uhr noch und noch, aber da ist ja ein Grund da, warum das verknappt ist. Wir könnten die ganze Welt komplett ernähren, aber diese Verknappung ist eine sehr künstliche.
Es ist wirklich erstaunlich. Plötzlich ist Knappheit künstlich hergestellt.
Ja, er dachte, klar gibt es auch natürliche Knappheiten, die sind dann einfach so, also Luft oder…
Wir führen den Euro ein, 2002. Dann kommt irgendwie so dieses Internet auf. Wir digitalisieren den Euro. Und dann, was ist seine Legende? Plötzlich hat jeder 1000 Millionen Euro, so viel er wollte, also braucht man mal eine neue Idee von Geld, die das wieder knapp macht. Also das ist so Hanebüchen.
Geht noch weiter. So, wir können das Gespräch jetzt auch vor dem Hintergrund Sanktionen gegen Russland auch lesen. Wir haben jetzt gehört, da werden einige Finanzflüsse gestoppt und das Problem ist ja dann für die Russen, dass die jetzt nicht mehr sagen können, ach ja, ich hatte da ja noch so ein Schweizer Konto, da hole ich mal wieder die 10.000 Dollar zurück. Mangold aber glaubt, dass das ohnehin alles noch gar nicht so möglich war, aber der Bitcoin.
Das heißt, das Internet kopiert alles, deswegen war es bisher für den Transfer von Werten, von Value, nicht geeignet, weil das führt zu einer Verdopplung. Wenn ich quasi per E-Mail ihnen Geld schicke, haben sie es und ich, denn es wird nur kopiert.
Was für Geld besonders problematisch ist.
Was für Geld sehr problematisch ist.
Gut, also demnach könnte ja kein einziges Online-Geschäft funktionieren, denn natürlich überweisen wir uns ja die ganze Zeit digital Beträge. Wenn du mir jetzt 100 Euro überweißt, dann hast du die nicht mehr, dann sind die bei mir. Das ist nämlich keine Umbuchung.
Was ist denn sein Ziel? Er hat ja jetzt gesagt, wenn ich mit per E-Mail Geld schicke, dann ist es ja doppelt. Man kann ja nicht einfach per E-Mail Geld verschicken, das wissen wir ja alle, sonst hätten wir es ja alles gemacht.
Und selbst wenn man es könnte, also es ließe sich ja auch einrichten, wenn man jetzt sagt, über Gmail kann man ab sofort auch Geld transferieren wie PayPal, wäre ja möglich, dann ist ja keine Verdoppelung.
Dem Bitcoin verschickt man auch nicht von E-Mail-Adresse zu E-Mail-Adresse, sondern von Wallet zu Wallet und diese Wallets sind sehr voraussetzungsvolle Dinge. Also das, was er sich hier wünscht, ich kann einfach mit E-Mail und da habe ich ehrlich gesagt, wenn der Wunsch nur ist, ein wertehaltiges Datum zu übertragen, dann kann man auch den Amazon-Gutscheid nehmen. Also dann macht man einfach ein Foto von dem Strichcode, schickt den ab und der kann nur einmal verwendet werden und wer ihn halt verwendet hat, den verwendet. Ob das dann der Absender oder der Empfänger ist, der zuerst kommt, malt halt.
Also man macht einfach PayPal oder macht eine Überweisung, was auch immer. Jetzt der Gründer des Bitcoin, wie der jetzt eingeführt wird, also wir müssen jetzt auch, wenn wir über rechte Ideologie und dazu kann man das hier schon auch zählen, das werde ich jetzt gleich ein bisschen stärker machen, diesen Punkt, dann gehört natürlich diese religiöse Komponente. Ich glaube da an das russische homogene Volk oder ich glaube an den Propheten.
Und die Genialität von, sagen wir diesen Namen zum ersten Mal in dieser Sendung mit angemessener Feierlichkeit von Satoshi Nakamoto.
Mit angemessener Feierlichkeit?
Gibt es den überhaupt?
Das stellt ja auch dann in Frage. Wir wissen es ja gar nicht. Also es ist dann wie mit Gott. Also das religiöse ist hier ganz wichtig. Und Mangold hat da eine sehr interessante These jetzt zum Bitcoin und zur Finanzkrise, die mich aufrochen ließ.
Bitcoin reagiert auf die Finanzkrise. Das ist so entscheidend zu wissen. Der Bitcoin reagiert auf die Finanzkrise, auf die Tatsache, dass die Zentralbanken mal wieder, nicht zum ersten Mal, mal wieder Wall Street rausgepaugt, der Bailout der Banken betrieben haben. Und da sagt Satoshi Nakamoto, wir brauchen ein Geld, das unabhängig ist.
So, und dann habe ich mich auch auf diese komische Spurensuche begeben und habe gedacht, wie kann es denn sein, dass der Literaturkritiker der ST, Dejoma Mangold, sich plötzlich für den Bitcoin erwärmen kann. Der könnte ja jetzt auch sich sonst mit Geld beschäftigen. Aber warum gerade der Bitcoin? Und dann ist mir eingefallen, Mangold ist ja ein großer Anhänger von Boto Strauß. Das ist ein konservativ bis reaktionärer deutscher Schriftstel, den ich gar nicht nur schlecht finde. Das will ich ganz im Gegenteil. Ich habe die Stücke sehr gern gelesen und finde auch manche problematischen Texte von ihnen ästhetisch sehr gelungen. Aber Boto Strauß mischt sich auch immer essayistisch ein. Zum Beispiel in der FAZ tat er das, ich glaube, es war 2013. Ich habe es in einem Sammelband dann gefunden und da hatte ich noch eine Erinnerung, da war doch auch was, dass Strauß sich zu EZB und so weiter geäußert hat. Und hier hat eigentlich der Straußianer Mangold mit dem Bitcoin so ein Update, das er durchführen kann, denn bei Boto Strauß klang das Ganze so. Im Vorschlag, auf dem Weg von Eurobonds die gegenwärtige Schuldenschwemme auf alle Euroländer zu verteilen und dies als ein Gebot der Solidarität auszugeben, versteckt sich eine Version des alten antinationalen Affekts der Linken und im Kern die sozialistische Aporie. Am Ende sind alle Habenichtse. Kein rhetorisch begnadeter Politiker, keine noch so unanfechtbare Autorität könnte die Nichtbeherrschbarkeit des derzeitigen Schuldendilemmers mit Worten durchdringen oder gar bannen. So, und unser Christian Lindner will genau das.
Das war ja die Zeit, bei der ich auch über der Fazit war. Der hat ja viel im Föhtor geschrieben. Und ich weiß noch, wie Schörmacher einmal so, und da war der Text schon gedruckt, es war ja so, wo Bodo Strauß schreibt, ne.
Da kann man nicht ablehnen.
Genau, macht die Redaktion das halt. Am nächsten Morgen sitzen alle in der Konferenz, reden über das Blatt von heute Morgen. Was wollte er uns sagen? Also Schörmacher so in die Runde, ne. Was wollte er uns sagen? Aber ich weiß noch die Diskussion, da ging es echt um so Eurobonds und so weiter. Da hatte ich auch noch so einen Text vorgeschlagen zum Thema Eurobonds. Mit so einem, also die These war so, kommt ja eh. Wo man jetzt noch 15 Jahre wartet oder nicht. Also dieses Schicksals, Gemeinschaft Europa, die liegt da nun wirklich, manchmal braucht man keine Akteure, sondern dann ist einfach der Druck dann da und dann muss es halt passieren, egal wie. Also kann man es ja jetzt einfach beschleunigen, weil jetzt brennt ja grad die Hütte und so. Bevor man dann in zehn Jahren irgendwie denkt, da hätten wir das mal früher gemacht. So wie wir jetzt bei Corona denken, das hätten wir auch damals schon machen können, einfach das Geld raushauen. Nee, stattdessen muss die Griechenland irgendwie 20% Zinsen zahlen und so und blöd sind. Und das wollte dann aber Kaube damals nicht machen, weil das so, ja, wenn wir uns da jetzt so einmischen und so und man kann so einen Text dann lesen und denkt sich so, hm, ja, nicht dann dachte, ja, man kann auch so Bodo Strauß Text lesen und denken, hm. Also da ist da wirklich nur noch so Autor, der Volontär oder hier halt so Bodo Strauß. Und naja, also das ist wirklich alles wahnsinnig.
Aber auf Linie, wenn wir jetzt eben Lindner gehört haben, dann ist das ja ganz ehrlich, die nationale Stärke, die wird geschwächt, wenn man eine gemeinschaftliche Verschuldung will, wenn die EZB mit ihrem Willen sich durchsetzt, dann ist der Sozialismus auch schon kurz vor der Tür. Und Mangold argumentiert dann hier weiter gegen die EZB.
Es kommt die Finanzkrise und plötzlich sehen wir, wir wollen der zentralen Instanz der Zentralbanken nicht mehr ausgeliefert sein. Und da bietet der Bitcoin die Antwort.
Ja, das finde ich wahnsinnig gefährlich, denn hier blendet man immer aus, welchen Beitrag und welche Leistung die EZB eigentlich bietet. Denn es ist ja immer die Frage, angenommen die EZB würde sich jetzt so verhalten, dass, was weiß ich, irgend so ein normaler Boomer hier mit 300.000 Vermögen ein bisschen mehr Zinsen bekommt dafür. Was würde das auf der anderen Seite bedeuten, dass Europa an Schutt und Asche liegt? Also dieses Szenario, was man sich immer vorstellt, gibt es so gar nicht, wenn man nur einen Puzzleteil betrachtet, statt das ganze Panorama. Und das ist dieser Fehler, den er hier auch macht.
Und das führt dann auch zu einer sehr verqueren Kapitalismuskritik.
Billiges Geld wird einfach rausgehauen. Wir sehen das. Wall Street holt sich das billige Geld von der Zentralbank und kauft meinetwegen davon. Leidt es irgendwelchen großen Unternehmen, die davon ihre eigenen Aktien zurückkaufen? Und dadurch haben wir diese Aufblähung des gesamten finanzialisierten Sektors, den wir nicht wollen, der auch für sehr, sehr viel unschuld Geld haben.
Ja, es gibt Aktienrückkäufe, das hat mit billigem Geld über drei Ecken auch zu tun, aber da wurden einfach enorme Profite gemacht, da wurden mit Steuererleichterungen und da werden natürlich hier unsere liberalen Eilenberger und sonst wo, der ja auch bei Tilo schon sagte, na ja wenn man jetzt mit deutschen Wohnen enteignen ankommt, da ist man ja schon bald bei Stalin, der dann noch den Bauern die letzte Kuh abnimmt. Also da werden die ja sobald man sagt, wir brauchen eine Steuererhöhung oder wir brauchen mal eine Lohnumverteilung, sind die natürlich nicht dabei. Aber hier wird jetzt so getan, als sei durch den niedrigen Zinssatz das billige Geld da und dadurch kaufen die jetzt die Aktien alle zurück und dadurch haben wir die Ungleichheit. Also das ist einfach vollkommener Unsinn und da würde ich auch jederzeit mir schützend vor die Wall Street stellen wollen.
Ja, ja vor allem über diese Cash-Buybacks muss man auf jeden Fall reden. Wir haben das hier auch schon häufiger. Elizabeth Warren hat ja auch mal diese Liste, was ist jetzt zu tun und so weiter, da war das gleich Top 3, aber das verweist eben alles auf Politik. Hier muss einfach mal ein politisches Programm entwickelt und durchgezogen werden. Und zwar so, dass alle wissen, was zu tun ist. Also mit einer gewissen Sinnhaftigkeit und so weiter. Stattdessen einfach zu sagen, ne wir müssen mal alle alten Institutionen austauschen, weil wir haben ja jetzt Internet und da kann man jetzt auch Geld mit E-Mail verschicken. Also in Anführungszeichen, wenn das eine Antwort sein soll auf irgendein Problem, fragt man sich wirklich, vielleicht hat der Karl Schlöge recht. Wir sind alle wohlstandsverwahrlost und wissen nicht mehr, was Krieg ist.
Ja, so wir haben die Sanktionen gegen Russland. Wir haben jetzt schon über Rechte gesprochen und mich hat das jetzt angezogen. Ich dachte, jetzt muss man noch da weiter graben und muss auch mal schauen, was passiert da gerade in Amerika. Jetzt mal gerade zwischen den Sternen schon mal noch so zwei Clips von Ted Cruz, der ja auch aufgetreten ist und zum Bitcoin gesprochen hat. Also wir sind jetzt wieder bei der amerikanischen Rechten.
So wir müssen es zentralisieren, wir müssen es aparte. Das ist einer der Reasons, warum ich so wütend bin auf Krypto, auf Bitcoin, weil es zentralisiert ist und nicht kontrolliert wird. Also ich gebe dir ein fantastisches Beispiel. Hier ist ein Teil der Schrift, Dear Ontario Superior Court of Justice. Wir haben keine User-Identifikation und Information außer E-Mail-Adressen. Wir haben auch keine Klassen. Deswegen können wir unsere User-Accounts nicht gratisieren.
Übertragen wir das mal auf Russland, dann bedeutet das, wenn man das jetzt feiert, und wir hätten ein Bitcoinsystem richtig etabliert, dann könnten wir auf der finanziellen Ebene nichts gegen Russland tun. Dann wäre überhaupt nur die einzige Möglichkeit, wir bewaffnen uns und gehen jetzt an die Front und gucken, ob wir die Russen bekriegen können.
Ja, aber dieses ganze Szenario, man könnte ja diese Idee durchspielen, jetzt kommen die Zentralbanken des Westens und canceln einfach 600-700 Milliarden Euro. Das Konto wird einfach gecancelt. Wer Putin jetzt geholfen, wenn er das Geld in Bitcoin hätte, das ist doch genauso an irgendwelche Wallets geknüpft und so, die man aus dem Spiel nehmen kann. Also es ist doch völlig Banane.
Die Disintermediation, die da immer propagiert wird, bedeutet natürlich nur, dass ein neuer Intermediär kommt und da sind neue Gatekeeper. Das ist ja genau wie im Internet. Da kann man sagen, wir haben nicht mehr die alten Gatekeeper. Da ist jetzt nicht mehr der Chefredakteur einer Zeitung, der mir sagt, nee Herr Schmidt, die Kritik wird bei uns nicht veröffentlicht. Aber ich habe natürlich jetzt mit neuen Gatekeeper zu tun, nach deren Spielregeln ich auch in irgendeiner Weise funktionieren muss. So, jetzt hatten wir eben schon bei den Neurechten, bei Dugin und Co, diesen Anti-Liberalismus und der ist bei den Bitcoinern auch vertreten. Denn interessant ist, welchen Bogen jetzt Ted Cruz hier spannt, während er da nur zwei Minuten über den Bitcoin eigentlich redet.
Das ist wundervoll.
Es gibt auch diesen Spruch, erst wenn der letzte Baum gefallen und das letzte Reh gestorben. Aber dann wirst du merken, dass du Geld nicht essen kannst. Aber mit so einem digital gespeicherten Passwort auf dem US-Besteg, was er das richtig gut damit regiert, sie dann durch.
Wenn die Hütte brennt, ganz klar hätte Putin besser einfach nur ganz viel digital Coins, dann wäre jetzt alles in Ordnung.
Absurd.
So wir wissen, dem Bitcoin zugrunde liegt die Blockchain. Wir wissen, glaube ich, fast alle jetzt, was eine Blockchain ist. Aber wir bekommen jetzt mal von allen Berger erklärt, was eine Blockchain sein soll.
Machen wir es noch mal ganz einfach für so Seelen wie mich, die sich damit nicht beschäftigt haben, anhand einer Spielzeugeisenbahn. Das ist also ein erster Block. Jetzt entsteht eine Transaktion mit diesem mutmaßlichen Wertblock. Und das heißt, da wird ein neuer Block hinzugefügt. Und zwar anhand eines Schlüssel, der kryptographisch eine besondere Eigenschaft hat. Richtig?
Ja, das habe ich sofort verstanden.
Also er hat eine Spielzeugeisenbahn da, erklärt das und hängt da noch einen anderen Waggon dran. Und da würde ich sagen, genau das ist die Blockchain nicht. Deshalb kommt die Bahn meistens in geänderte Wagenreihen. Man kann nämlich ganz flexibel sagen, dieser Zug fährt so und der andere hat noch drei Waggons hinten dran und sonst was. Ich sage, das ist die Blockchain nicht.
Es gibt eine sehr schöne Analogie, denn die Blockchain so, also dieses Prinzip, diese Reihung einzuhalten, die ist ja gar nicht so neu. Ich glaube, das war damals in Italien oder so. Da hat man angefangen, das Grundbuch damit zu führen, dass man so einen Strick aufgespannt hat. Jedes Grundstück hatte einen so einen Strick. Und dann hat man immer den aktuellsten Vertrag, der gerade gilt, einfach vorne drangehangen. Und wenn dann jemand das gekauft hat, hat man einfach den wieder vorne drangehangen, sodass man den aktuellen Vertrag hatte. Und auch alle anderen, um dann nachzuvollziehen, klar, der vorne sichtbare Zettel war der aktuelle, da steht drauf, wem es gehört. Aber man konnte dann auch in der Geschichte nachgehen, wenn jemand Anspruch erhebt oder so, ja, du hattest mal, aber dann hat er das ja hier verkauft. Und dann musste er deshalb immer auf diesen Faden und dann gab es eben im Rathaus oder so dieses Amt, das dann gesichert hat, dass da niemand reingeht, ausser immer die Vertragsparteien, die diesen Faden dann einfach immer weiterfüllen mit Zetteln. Und das ist eigentlich die richtige Analogie.
Ganz genau. Und wir hören jetzt mal den anderen Gast, Wattenhofer.
Aber man rechnet, dass es etwa vielleicht 100'000 Computer auf der ganzen Welt sind, die im Prinzip alle eine Kopie dieser Blockchain haben. Das ist nicht ganz anders als bei einem Bankkonto sonst. Das ist ja auch digital, ihr Bankkonto. Und auch da gibt es natürlich mehrere Computer, die wissen, wie viel Geld sie auf dem Bankkonto haben, falls irgendeiner von denen ausfällt, dass die anderen das noch wissen. Der grosse Unterschied ist, es sind viel mehr Computer hier, es ist weltweit. Und der allergrösste Unterschied ist, dass jeder mitmachen kann. Also jeder kann seinen Computer, kann dieses Bitcoin-Programm laufen lassen und dann ist er dabei bei diesen 100'000 Computern.
Und macht das durch seine Partizipation auch tendenziell sicherer?
Ist denn jemals das Geld unsicher gewesen? Es sei denn, man ist jetzt gerade Putin und hat einen Krieg angefangen. Hat man schon mal ein Problem gehabt? Hast du gedacht, ich komme da nicht ran? Jetzt weiß ich, es gibt dieses Beispiel, was dann gerne gebracht wird. Und ich sehe das auch kritisch, dass man damals das eingefroren hat bei WikiLeaks. Und wir können auch noch bei anderen Hilfsorganisationen und sowas auch erleben. Die wird aber der Bitcoin, der so volatil ist, nicht retten. Und da würde ich auch wieder sagen, wir haben ja zwar diese Computer und wir haben eine dezentrale Stelle in der Sache drin, aber wir haben auch eine intermediäre Struktur. Und auch da sind Leute abzukapseln, wenn einem aus politischen Gründen daran gelegen ist.
Ja, vor allem diese Dezentralität. Das ist doch gar nicht gegeben bei Bitcoin. Ja, und es bringt ja gar nichts sich da selbst.
Genau, das ist ja eine interessante Machtverschiebung, die da längst stattgefunden hat. Das sind ja nicht irgendwie ein paar Nerds, die ihre PCs zu Hause aufgestellt haben. Naja, Mangold will das aber alles nicht sehen. Das tun religiöse Leute auch nicht.
Das ist ja das eigentliche Wunder. Diese Dezentralität heißt auch, es gibt keine privilegierte Position in dem System. Das ist etwas, was wir nicht kennen, was menschheitsgeschichtlich neu ist.
Menschheitsgeschichtlich neu? Geht es noch eine Nummer drunter? Und wie gesagt?
Also, da muss man echt hart widersprechen. Wir haben ja nun Grepper gelesen. Und ich habe ja einen Anklang gebracht, man könnte ja auch Luban lesen und so. Und wir haben ja schon diese Evolutionsgeschichte oder Entwicklungsgeschichte von... Jetzt sind wir in der Funktionaldifferenziert. Vorher war das so eine stratifizierte Gesellschaft und davor eben Zentrum Peripherie. Und davor, und da kann man schon sagen, das sind schon sehr unabhängige, voneinander unabhängige Gebiete einfach gewesen. Die wussten untereinander nicht, wo es hier noch ein Stamm und so weiter. Haben sich dann immer gegenseitig entdeckt. Wer aus dem Wald kam, galt irgendwie als heilig und so. Da wusste man gar nicht, das ist, den kennen wir ja gar nicht. Wer ist denn das? Und diese Prinzipien sind ja nie überholt worden, nur weil die Gesellschaft einen weiteren Schritt gemacht hat. So wie auch heute immer noch gilt, dass unsere Unternehmen keine Monopole darstellen sollen, damit es eben zum Vorteil der Diversität und Dezentralität kommt. Und so werden ja auch Unternehmen intern aufgebaut. Man hat halt verschiedene Abteilungen, klar Arbeitsteilungen, aber eben auch so ein bisschen Resilienz, dass man dann doppelte Buchführungen und so weiter. Das ist alles totaler Quatsch, dass man hier einfach sagt, Dezentralität und Internet, das gibt es nur beim Bitcoin. Das haben wir noch in Knappheit, das haben wir noch nie vorher gesehen. Alle diese Prinzipien finden wir nicht nur beim Bitcoin.
Und wie kann es sein, dass bei solchen ökonomischen Ammenmärchen niemand widerspricht? Wenn da jetzt jemand sitzen würde, wir würden über die deutsche Identität reden und da würde einer sagen, ja, die Deutschen, das ist ja alles im Blute oder so, dann würde sofort jemand kommen und widersprechen, zu Recht. Aber hier im Ökonomischen kann man alles loswerden. Mich würde interessieren, ob Mangold diese Äußerung zu Swift auch nochmal jetzt angesichts der Krise so machen würde.
Wir merken es auch, wenn ich meine PIN zu meinem Bankkonto vergesse, kann ich bei der Bank anrufen und dann schickt die mir ein neues Passwort gewissermaßen rekonstruiert, es gibt mir eine neue PIN, weil es immer einen gibt, der die Macht über das ganze System hat und jederzeit jemanden ausschließen kann, Drang salieren kann oder was auch immer.
Ja, das ist aber vielleicht auch für moderne Staatlichkeit ganz gut, dass es da auch Grenzen gibt, dass das gemacht werden kann. Und das ist ja nicht nur bezogen auf das Geld, sondern du kannst auch anderweitig kann der Staat eingreifen, wenn zum Beispiel irgendeine Gefahr droht.
Ja, das ist vor allem ein Feature. Es ist ein Feature. Die Leute hassen das, dass wenn ihr iPhone, wenn sie ihr Passwort nicht mehr haben, dass sie nicht mehr in ihr iPhone kommen. Da rufen sie bei Apple an und sagen die, sorry, aber wir haben ja Passworte auch nicht. Also sie müssen sich jetzt ein neues iPhone kaufen und die Fotos darauf sind halt verloren. Und das finden Leute ganz blöd. Das ist eine ganz kleine verschwindende Minderheit, die sagt, ich muss mich jetzt davon befreien von Apple. Lieber habe ich ein Feature-Phone, das aber dann nicht von... Das ist wie die Frage, die wir schon hatten. Wenn wir jetzt irgendwo so ein Planet finden, wo das idealtypisch läuft, alles ist dezentral, würden wir wirklich hinfahren, wenn wir die Zustände da sehen oder nicht?
Ich nicht. Aber wir sind ja auch nicht mehr ganz jung. Denn wir wissen, die FDP wurde von ganz vielen jungen Menschen gewählt, mehr jungen Menschen denn je. Und auch Mangold zeichnet hier eine Jugendbewegung.
Der Mythos oder das, was aus dem Bitcoin tatsächlich, wie ich meine, eine große, starke gesellschaftspolitische Jugendbewegung geradezu macht, das ist Freiheit neu definiert. Das ist wirklich ein großer Schritt nach vorne in der Geschichte der Freiheit. Und zur Freiheit, das wissen wir alle, die wirkt auch immer abschreckend. Warum? Naja, weil sie uns mit so viel Verantwortung zumutet.
Ja, und die Verantwortung liegt jetzt darin, dass man Unsinn in einer Schweizer Talkshow erzählt und mit allem, mit Zeitvertrag, mit einem Buchvertrag und allem abgesichert ist und jetzt irgendwas den jungen Leuten, die in prekären Zuständen leben werden, von Verantwortung und sowas erzählt.
Es gibt in Deutschland 10, 12 Millionen minderjährige Kinder. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, ungefähr 10 bis 12 Millionen, die sich von ihrer Oma ein Amazon-Gutschein wünschen. Und ich kenne wahrscheinlich drei, die ihrer Oma sagen, ich wünsche mir ein Bitcoin.
Ja, ganz klar.
Das ist eine Mega-Jugend-Bewegung, die wir hier gerade sehen. Weil Bitcoin ist nämlich das Spielzeug der Jugend.
Und diese Jugend.
Und nicht etwa der Boomer und millennials.
Die ist ganz politisch.
Meine Erfahrung in diesem für mich wahnsinnig bereichernden letzten Jahr mit so vielen jungen Leuten, die sich für Bitcoin begeistern, ist komplett was anderes. Das ist eine gesellschaftspolitisch hochbewusste Jugendbewegung, die genau an diesen Knackpunkten unseres Systems ansetzt. Die sagt, Inflation ist auch eine Umverteilung von unten nach oben. Deswegen wollen wir kein inflationäres Regiment mehr und so weiter. Das heißt, Gerechtigkeitsfragen natürlich im Geiste der Freiheit. Gar keine Frage.
Und der Selbstverantwortung.
Im Geiste der Freiheit und der Selbstverantwortung sind die...
Schön, wie die das auch sich nochmal so gegenseitig bemeiden. Wir wollen auch dieses FDP-Port noch bitte einmal kurz reinbringen, lieber Ijoma. Und es ist der absolute Wahnsinn, dass also jetzt hier, wo Leute in Europa unter einer Jugendarbeitslosigkeit leiden müssen im Süden, wo wir Leute haben, die sich niemals ein Eigenheim werden leisten können, die große Probleme haben in der Stadt, die Miete zu bezahlen, die schlechte Löhne bekommen, die schlechter gestätzt sind als die Eltern. Die kümmern sich jetzt um diese drei Prozent Inflation. Also wenn man ordentliche Löhne zahlen würde, dann würden diese Energiepreise und so überhaupt nicht in dieser Weise aufschlagen. Und so zu tun, als sei das jetzt hier so eine tolle Bewegung, die die Gesellschaft besser macht, das ist natürlich genau der Diskurs auf den Mangold ganz plump hereinfällt, der Bitcoin-Miner. Ich bringe jetzt mal hier einen Clip aus dem OMR-Podcast von November. Da war Marco Streng zu Gast. Das ist einer, der professionell einen Miner, der überall in allen möglichen Ländern, wo die Energie billig ist, dann diese Miner-Fabriken aufbaut. Und naja, wir wissen ja, der Bitcoin war mal günstig, ist dann an Wert gestiegen, könnte noch weiter an Wert steigen. Und wie ist es denn das jetzt da mit dieser großen Gleichheit? Und wer profitiert denn eigentlich davon, wenn jetzt angeblich Ungleichheit so ein wichtiges Thema ist?
Wenn das einigermaßen weiterläuft, dann wirst du ja persönlich wahrscheinlich auch mit dem Bitcoin-Thema nicht jetzt Millionär, das bist du schon, sondern eher Milliardär dann.
Ich denke, also für mich ist immer wichtig, unabhängig jetzt von dem privaten Privatvermögen. Wir haben eine klare Vision. Also sehr wichtig, dass wir unsere Mission und unsere Vision hier erreichen und dass wir, wie gesagt, das Privatvermögen. Ich denke, was viel erfüllender ist und was viel interessanter ist, ist, dass man wirklich Teil von etwas ist, was wirklich die Welt zum Positiven verändert.
Und wenn ich nebenbei noch Milliardär werde, dann sei es drum. Auch das werde ich in irgendeiner Weise zu Schultern wissen. Aber ja, ich glaube, besser kann man sich nicht selbst entlarven, wenn man so antwortet.
Wir hatten doch, was, im Januar oder so, diese kleine Zahl vom Wall Street Journal, irgendwie 50 Prozent des Bitcoin-Vermögens liegt bei 0, 1 Prozent der Bitcoin-Eigner und so. Also diese totale Konzentration des Vermögens, was ja auch nur zustande kommt, weil es eben dieses Schneeballsystem, was du mit Ole auch schon so beschrieben hast, ist. Irgendwer kommt halt immer wieder auf diesen Trip. Und da werden junge Menschen auch wirklich verarscht, die dann noch mal ein bisschen Dollar reinschieben, was dann am Ende, weil das ist ja auch immer wieder interessant. Der Typ sagt ihm einfach, du bist ja schon Millionär, dann wirst du ja bald Milliardär. In welcher Währung rechnen die das denn? In welcher Währung schmücken die sich denn damit? Na, in Dollar natürlich und nicht in Bitcoin. Die Typen gehen doch nicht los und gehen jetzt, oh, ich habe jetzt so viel Bitcoin, endlich kann ich mir alles in Bitcoin kaufen, was ich mir vorher nicht in Dollar leisten konnte. Das ist doch Quatsch. Deren Vermögen ist ja auch nur Dollarvermögen. Und der Bitcoin wird natürlich vorher abgestoßen, in Dollar umgewandelt und dann als Vermögen auch wirklich eingesetzt. Also hier ist, hier wird einfach eine ganze Generation verarscht und nicht befreit.
Und selbst der Informatiker Wattenhofer versucht das mal ein bisschen jetzt zu bremsen mit der Euphorie.
Wenn man selbst dieses Bankkonto besitzt, selbst aufsetzen kann, selbst verwaltet, dann ist man selbst auch schuld, wenn es dann gestohlen wird. Und man muss natürlich diesen Schlüssel, mit dem man Zugriff hat auf dieses Bankkonto, auch selbst bewachen. Und das ist etwas, was vielleicht nicht jedem liegt, oder? Es gibt diese bekannten Fälle von Harddisk verloren.
Einen Assistenten von Ihnen hat es besonders hart erwischt, wenn ich das kurz erzählen darf. Der hatte Bitcoin auf seinem Computer nicht ausreichend geschützt. Der Gegenwert war 300 Millionen Franken, wenn ich es richtig sehe. Man wusste das wohl in der Szene und hat diesen Computer attackiert.
Und hier würde ich auch wieder sagen, kommt in der Moderne an. Wenn da jemand jetzt von uns die EC-Karte vergisst oder verliert, dann ist man einfach froh, dass man bei der Bank anrufen kann und den Namen sagen kann und weiß nicht, was brauchen sie noch, Geburtsdatum oder so? Dann kann man sagen, sperren Sie mal bitte die Karte, ich finde die jetzt gerade nicht. Wahrscheinlich brauche ich eine neue. Und damit ist die Sache geritzt. Und das ist einfach ein ganz großer Vorteil. Man will sich um die Sachen nicht kümmern.
Es ist der eigentliche Vorzug.
Ich möchte, dass das Geld da ist, auch wenn ich an den Geldautomaten gehe, dass ich sage, bitte 200 Euro.
Es ist der eigentliche Vorzug dieses Systems.
Aber Mangold ist vielleicht einfach ein bisschen gelangweilt von seinem Literaturkritiker Dasein und schildert jetzt ja ganz selbst, wie er diese Transfers, diese Bitcoin-Transfers vornimmt.
Die Bitcoins sind jetzt in der eigenen Verantwortung, diesen Schritt zu machen, der technologisch nicht so wahnsinnig schwierig ist, aber psychologisch einen wirklich herausfordert. Und ein ganzes Jahr, ich überweise jetzt immer so kleine Bruchteile, wenige Satoshis, weil ich Angst habe, wenn ich einen Fehler mache und schicke dir eine falsche Adresse, dann wären die weg und so weiter. Ich will sagen, obwohl ich so begeister von Bitcoin rede, habe auch ich feuchte Handinnenflächen jedes Mal, wenn ich versuche, Satoshis von der Exchange auf meine Cold-Molle zu ziehen.
Aber das ist doch dann schon der Nachteil schlechthin. Man will doch einfach was Praktisches haben. Da kann doch niemand sagen, ja und so ein Gefühl müsst du jetzt auch mal haben, dass du jetzt Angst haben musst, ob das Geld wirklich ankommt und du mit feuchten Händen da Überweisungen tätigst.
Also es ist mir völlig lebensfern, dass ich verstehe das überhaupt gar nicht.
Vor allen Dingen, diese Gleichzeitigkeit ist ja wieder interessant. Zum einen sagt man die ganze Zeit, das Bezahlen muss einfacher und praktischer werden, wo ich dann schon manchmal denke, gut, Bargeld ist ja wahnsinnig praktisch, aber dann wollen die Leute mit dem Smartphone bezahlen und sonst was. Und zugleich haben wir jetzt hier wieder Leute, die und wahrscheinlich sind sogar dieselben. Also wahrscheinlich ist Mangold mit dem Smartphone unterwegs im Supermarkt und bezahlt damit und macht aber zugleich da mit feuchten Handinnenflächen seine Bitcoin-Trades.
Ja, also ich kann mich noch an früher erinnern, nächsten Monat ist großes Thema wirklich mal selbst Ermächtigung. Zumindest von meiner Seite. Ich habe so ein paar Entdeckungen gemacht, wie man doch noch mal so ein bisschen. Ich weiß noch von mir, früher als Kind an der Kasse anstehen, während die Eltern sagen, ich gehe mal noch mal eben was holen. Und man dachte so, ah scheiße, bin ich jetzt vielleicht gleich dran. Aber dann muss ich sagen, ich kann gerade nicht bezahlen und überhaupt und so. Wo ist meine Mama? Es ist eigentlich das Gefühl, was man austreiben will aus der Welt. Der ganze Erfolg des Silicon Valley, das sind ja die Theorien, die da immer wieder kommen. Da sind einfach junge Männer, die technisch umsetzen, was sie als Service brauchen, nachdem ihre Mutter ihnen nicht mehr zur Verfügung steht. Sie lassen sich Essen liefern, jemand sagt ihnen Bescheid, was sie morgens machen sollen und der ganze Kram. Bitcoin und der ganze Kram ist genau das Gegenteil. Wenn ich zum Friseur gehe und dort kein lockeres Gespräch haben kann, weil ich nicht genau weiß, ob ich die Bitcoin-Transaktion danach ordentlich über die Bühne kriege, am Ende steht man da noch eine halbe Stunde, bis es dann mal endlich durchgerutscht ist, weil es kommt ja auch sehr darauf an, wie das Netzwerk gerade arbeitet. Das ist doch der totale Horror. Wo ist denn da wieder eine Befreiung oder auch nur ein Fortschritt? Das ist einfach nur alles Müll.
Nein, Stefan, es ist deine westliche eurozentrische Perspektive.
Und es hat dann ja auch stark emanzipative Züge, weil man beispielsweise, um ein Bankkonto eröffnen zu dürfen, gewisse Voraussetzungen erfüllen muss, während die teilnehme Voraussetzung an diesem Wertnetzwerk eigentlich nur ein Smartphone ist. Oder sogar noch ein Nokia-Phone von früher, das die Rechenleistung grün würde. Das heißt, viele Menschen auf der ganzen Welt könnten Zugang zu diesem Werttransferierungssystem bekommen, den sie jetzt nicht haben. Es sind sogar Milliarden Menschen potenziell.
Absolut, da müssen wir uns auch manchmal aus unserer westlichen Perspektive herausbegeben, die wir natürlich in einer Form der finanziellen Privilegiertheit leben.
In facebook.org, so viele Menschen auf der Welt haben kein Internet. Lasst uns doch wenigstens kostenloses Facebook-Internet geben. Das ist auch eminzipatorisch eine wichtige Sache, dass diese Menschen jetzt endlich im Internet sind. Es geht auch um Millionen, Milliarden Schicksale.
Da kämpft sogar der Straußianer plötzlich gegen den Eurozentrismus. Es ist absurd, aber auch dies natürlich eine Argumentation, die Mangold eins zu eins von den Bitcoin-Minern übernimmt. Noch einmal, Marco Streng, wie ist er denn zum Bitcoin gekommen?
Es war ganz interessant. Ich hatte einen Nachbarn in meinem Studentenwohnheim. Der kam aus Afrika und der hat mir ziemlich leid getan, weil er am Ende jedes Monats, oder am Anfang, effektiv am Anfang des Monats, als er dann sein Gehalt bekommen hat, ist er zu Western Union gegangen, jeden Monat. Er hat irgendwie, ich glaube, es waren so 100 Euro oder so, das hat er zu seiner Familie geschickt und ich glaube, also großer Teil, ich glaube 40 Euro oder irgendwie um den Dreh war es, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was der Betrag war, aber es war wirklich ein sehr großer Teil davon, war einfach weg. Das habe ich live miterlebt, wie er da wirklich viel gearbeitet hat und dann musste er einfach so hohe Gebühren zahlen und dann kam ja das auch noch, ja, schau doch Bitcoin an.
Klassisches Bankenregulierungsproblem.
Ganz genau.
Nichts weiter.
Wir merken auch eine volle Bitcoin-Wallet verbessert nicht unbedingt die rhetorischen Talente. Nun noch mal Mangold, er benennt jetzt einen weiteren Vorteil des Bitcoin und wir können gleich mal nachdenken, ob das nicht der fundamentalste Nachteil überhaupt ist.
Ziemliche Inflationsraten in Deutschland mit 5 Prozent, in den USA mit 7 Prozent. Der Bitcoin ist von der Idee her ein langfristig deflationäres Geld. Das heißt, er ist ein guter Hedge, eine gute Absicherung gegen inflationäre Tendenzen.
Inflation bedeutet, nur ganz kurz erklärt, dass das Geld, das ich habe, in seiner Kaufkraft über einen Zeitraum an Kaufkraft verliert. Wenn man 5 Prozent Inflation hat, kann man sich von 100 Franken dann nur noch den Gegenwert von 95 Franken kaufen.
Ja, genau, so ist Inflation. Nur das Problem ist, wir sind ja eine Wirtschaft, die wachsen muss. Also wir haben einen Wachstumszwang im Kapitalismus. Und wenn man jetzt eine Wirtschaft hat, die wächst, man aber eine Währung hätte, die eher zurückgeht, also die deflationär ist und die auch noch mengenmäßig ganz klar begrenzt ist, nämlich nach diesem Dokument wird das ja dann in einigen Jahren der Fall sein, dann haben wir ja ein großes Problem. Also wie soll dann die Wirtschaft weiter wachsen? Das heißt, wir brauchen natürlich, und das ist ja immer das, was die EZB sagt, eine gewisse inflationäre Tendenz in jedem Land, das kapitalistisch betrieben wird. Sonst funktioniert diese Wirtschaftsweise nicht. Und dann kommen wir von einer deflationären Währung ganz schnell in eine ganz tiefe Deflation und dann kommen wir aus der Wirtschaftskrise nicht mehr raus.
Oder wir sehen das alles falsch. Wir brauchen einfach eine sehr fluktuierende Währung. Der Bitcoin war am 28. September 35.000 Dollar wert. Dann stieg er bis November, so 8. November, auf 60.000, fast 57.000. Dann allerdings fiel er bis 22. Januar auf 30.000, als er sich einmal halbiert. Das sind jetzt so Januar mal so, Februar mal so, Verdoppelung und Halbierung.
Wenn er wieder hoch geht, sagen die, ja seht ihr, dann denke ich, ja klar, aber das kann ich auch mit jeder Aktie machen.
Das ist eine Inflation von 5%, auf die man sich dann auch einstellen kann. Ein Sommerspaziergang, das ist wirklich fahnebüchen.
Nein, du musst auch so ergriffen sein wie Einberger.
Die letzte Ausschüttung oder Generierbarkeit von neuen Coins liegt im Jahr 2124 etwa. Und das ist ja nun anders als jedes andere wertehaltige Material, von dem wir auf dieser Welt wissen. Es ist eine absolute, in ihrer Menge detailliert bestimmbare Form von digitaler Knappheit. Und zumindest das muss man sagen, das ist doch unglaublich geistig anregend, sich vorzustellen, dass man mit digitalen Mitteln etwas Wertvolles schaffen kann, dessen Gesamtmenge absehbar absolut begrenzt.
Ja, das kann ich doch die ganze Zeit machen. Also du kannst ja auch dein Buch rausgeben, du sagst, es wird nur tausendmal gedruckt, und dann ist es halt damit knapp, und dann ist das so. Das macht man mit Wundschuhen doch auch. Ja genau, macht man mit Wundschuhen. Und wenn du genug Leute findest, die sagen, ich finde das aber so toll, ich gebe für Stefans Buch auch tausend Euro aus, dann klappt das halt. Aber das war immer so gegeben. Und wir haben diese religiöse Komponente schon drin gehabt. Und ich will nochmal betonen, das sind sehr stark rechte Denkmuster hier. Aber das wird natürlich immer zugleich auch noch verknüpft mit Widerstand gegen die herrschende Ordnung. Das ist ja was, was die Neurechten alle machen. Also Konservatismus war ja immer so, damit ja alles so bleibt, wie es ist. Keine Experimente, Konrad Adenauer und so. Und hier muss man aber immer das Revolutionäre sehen. Und wenn man es dann aufs Religiöse Münzt, dann kommt man von der Revolution zur Reformation.
Wir haben eine Parallelbewegung, was im 16. im 15. und 16. Jahrhundert die Trennung von Staat und Kirche war, werden wir, das ist meine Prognose jetzt, als die Trennung von Staat und Geld erledigen.
Eine neue Reformation, ja?
Ja, das ist eine neue Reformation.
Ich kann das, du hast es ja auch schon.
Man hält es fast nicht aus.
Dümmer wird es nicht mehr.
Also ich kann auch sagen, ich musste mir den ganzen Kram da anhören zu Putin und so. Das war schon schlimm und die ganze Putin-Rede nochmal. Aber hier, das hat mich wirklich mürbe gemacht. Ich fand es sehr schön, dass Wattenhofer in der gleichen Sendung folgendes sagt, wo wir hier Reformation, also die Protestanten gegen die Katholiken, das sagt Wattenhofer zehn Minuten früher das hier.
Und das ist vielleicht das vierte und letzte Problem für Bitcoin, dass Bitcoin einfach sehr schwierig zu reformieren ist. Das ist wie die katholische Kirche unter den Religionen, unter den Krypto-Währen.
Aber basisdemokratisch verwaltet?
Aber die Meiner sind die, die das Sagen haben da. Wenn man eine Änderung durchkriegen möchte, muss man den Willen der Meiner anschauen. Und die Meiner werden das Meining nicht wegnehmen. Das klingt schon im Namen so.
So, wir gehen nämlich zurück vor die Reformation. Wir gehen wieder zurück in die Vormoderne. Und deshalb wundert es nicht, dass wir nicht mehr mit Fakten oder sonst irgendetwas argumentieren, sondern dass wir in der reinen Sphäre des Glaubens angekommen sind und wir dann schlussendlich noch mal ganz kurz von Mangold ein Glaubensbekenntnis vernehmen.
Freunde, Basisdemokraten und Anarchisten, die wir sind, wir glauben absolut an Dezentralität als den höchsten Wert.
Anarchisten, die wir sind, ne? Das kann man auch wirklich nur in diesen ganz kurzen Momenten, ach, der Putin wird da nie angreifen, es wird nicht zu dem Krieg kommen, usw. Wir spielen hier mal ein bisschen mit so Worten einfach. Das ist wirklich, das ist so hanebüchen. Na gut, viel Spaß Herr Mangold. Ich bin auf das Buch nicht gespannt. Ich schließe hiermit aus, dass wir das im Salon besprechen, oder? Meinst du, es wird so doof, dass es sich lohnt?
Ja, wir lassen es uns mal offen, wir lesen mal rein. Wir haben ja online dann die Möglichkeit, mal eine Leseprobe einzusehen. Die ist ja nicht digital verknappt, da können wir dann mal reingucken.
Stimmt, ja, das Buch wird digital verknappt. Ich verstehe das gar nicht. Ist doch gar kein Bitcoin, ist doch ein Buch. Ja, gut, einen Kapitel machen wir hier noch auf. Das betraf den Februar und uns alle. Anders als der Bitcoin, das sind ja nur wenige Menschen, die da entweder geistig angeregt sind oder tatsächlich ein paar Bitcoins in ihrer Wallet haben. Ich war ein bisschen überrascht. Es geht ja jetzt die Bundesregierung so richtig. Also klar, Ukraine und so, die steht im Feuer, muss handeln. Aber sie drängen ja jetzt auch die Alltagsthemen. Und ich gucke den Wohnbautag, eine jährliche Veranstaltung, wo sich alle treffen. Diejenigen, die die Firmen, also die Verbände der Firmen, die die Wohnung herstellen, bauen. Dann natürlich der Mieterbund und so weiter. Die Politik, es waren unglaublich viele Politiker da. Geivitz als Bauministerin, Habeck, Kevin Kühnert als Generalsekretär SPD, Ricarda Lange als...
Also man schickt schon die Promis da hin.
Ja, da kommt schon die erste Liga und so und macht dann einen ordentlichen Aufschlag. Und bei dieser Veranstaltung hat man jetzt mal gesehen, ach ja, das sind jetzt die neuen Politiker. Also es ist jetzt nicht nur so, da kommt der Jugendverband und hat auch noch... Sondern das sind jetzt die neuen Politiker. Und wir hören hier mal einen Clip und das fand ich ganz überraschend, dass Ricarda, oder sagen wir so, wir fangen an bei Manfred Lehmann. Das ist hier sicherlich ein Begriff, eine berühmte Stimme, nämlich die von Bruce Willis und so weiter. Alle, die schon mal mit Taron gefahren sind, kennen ihn. Er macht die Sicherheitsanweisung, jetzt lassen sie mal nicht die Brille auf, die können hier runterfallen und Pippa.
Was ist Taron?
Nein, die Achterbahn. Ach so. Und Manfred Lehmann hat diese Filmchen besprochen, mit denen die durch die Sendung gingen. Und da habe ich gedacht, das passt überhaupt nicht. Wir hören mal diesen Sing-Sang der Eröffnung der Veranstaltung.
Hier ist der 13. Wohnungsbautag 2022. Mit der Polit-Arena Wohnen. Spitzenpolitiker treffen auf Wohnungsbaufakten. Jetzt live aus dem Verbändehaus in Berliner Regierungsviertel. Der Wohnungsbautag veranstaltet vom Verbändebündnis Wohnungsbau. Mit seinen sieben Partnern. Den führenden Akteur...
Und jetzt kommt die sieben Partner. Manfred Lehmann hat man jetzt aufgetragen. Wir sehen jetzt schon Pus-Villes im Unterhemd.
Da den Tag beginnen, aber nein.
Und selten hat die Auswahl einer Stimme und der transportierende Inhalt so wenig zusammengepasst wie in diesen folgenden 40 Sekunden.
und Immobilienbranche. Dem Deutschen Mieterbund, DMB. Der Industriegewerkschaft Bauen, Agrar, Umwelt, IG Bau. Dem Zentralverband des Deutschen Baugewerbes, ZDB. Dem Bundesverband deutscher Wohnungs- und Immobilienunternehmen, GDW. Dem Bundesverband freier Immobilien- und Wohnungsunternehmen, BFW. Der Deutschen Gesellschaft für Mauerwerks- und Wohnungsbau, DGFM. Koordiniert durch den B...
Vielleicht hatte man einfach zu viel Geld und hat gesagt, gut, können wir noch mal 10.000 oder so für einen Sprecher ausgeben, das wäre doch eigentlich ganz lustig. Man selbst merkt ja immer, was man für eine Fisselstimme eigentlich hat, wenn man so eine Stimme hört, das ist ja ganz, ganz ruhig war. Aber ja, es ist amüsant.
Aber jetzt, die Veranstaltung, der eine oder andere Zwischenfilm kam noch mit Manfred Lehmann, dann am Ende dieses Podium, auf dem dann Ricarda Lange steht, von der wir wissen, sie ist 28 Jahre alt, die sich dann wie folgt zu Wort meldete.
Was dann kommen muss, um klimaneutral zu werden, ist grüne Energie, Wärme und Strom regenerativ erzeugt.
Ja, Frau Lange, wollen die Grünen oder will diese neue Ampelregierung, will die zu viel?
Ich will vielleicht, wenn es geht, noch mal ganz kurz auf die Jungen eingehen, bevor ich dann konkret auf diese Frage. Ich muss einmal sagen, dass ich wirklich sehr neidisch bin auf die Stimme, die diese Videos einspricht. Das bräuchten wir auf jeden Fall für viele politische Kampagnenvideos auch. Das klingt mir sehr überzeugend. Genau, wenn sie mir die Kontakte vermitteln können, sehr, sehr gerne.
Sie hat noch nie vorher Manfred Lehmann gehört.
Ja oder sie hat ihn wahrscheinlich ja mal, er wird ja mal einen Prost-Willes-Film gesehen haben. Ich glaube nicht.
Und wenn, dann nicht auf Deutsch.
Das könnte sein oder sie findet das so verrückt, dass sie gar nicht auf die Assoziation kommt. Man denkt, was ist das für eine Stimme, aber das kann ja niemals der sein. Außerdem weiß ich nicht, ob junge Leute Manfred Lehmann wirklich als Name präsent haben.
Ja, aber die Stimme, auch wenn man jetzt den Namen nicht kennt.
Ja, die Stimme lässt einen so ein bisschen aufhorsten.
Also ich finde es irgendwie crazy, denn ich dachte immer, wenn jetzt irgendwelche Feuilletonisten erzählen, ich habe mal wieder so ein Filmseminar gegeben und da waren auch ganz viele Filmstudenten und dann heißt es plötzlich Alfred Hitchcock war denen kein Begriff. Und jetzt sehen wir das mal so richtig. Jetzt kommt eine junge Generation, die ihre eigene Kultur hat. Wir haben ja auch den Superboy gesehen, wo die ganzen Rapper und so weiter. Wir sind jetzt die Alten sozusagen, also die, die den Superboy cool fanden, sind jetzt nicht mehr die Jungen. Man macht jetzt also Superboy ist Programm für die etwas älteren und jetzt ist auch diese Musik Programm für die älteren.
Aber so fühle ich mich seit meiner Geburt an, meine Referenzen kennt ja überhaupt keiner mehr.
Also ich finde das Wahnsinn, dass wir hier einfach Ricarda Lang als Chefin der Grünen Partei haben, die Manfred Lehmann ist, also die Stimme einfach nicht erkannt hat. Nun gut, sie machen jetzt Politik und wir gehen nicht nur den Wohnungsbautag durch, sondern auch ein bisschen Bundestag, da war das ja auch Thema. Es ist die AfD selbst, die hier Anträge gestellt hat, also dann auch eine halbe Stunde Debatte bekam und so weiter, beispielsweise zur Wohnpolitik, weil sie wollten dann doch mal irgendwie das kommunale Vorkaufsrecht und alles und die Themen.
Die Migranten sind wahrscheinlich auch entscheidend schuld an der ganzen Misere für die AfD.
Ja genau, also die AfD zettelt eine Wohn-Bundestagsdebatte an und bekommt eine Migrantendebatte, obwohl sie es selber gar nicht will eigentlich, sondern man greift das dann halt auf, weil die das sagen und haut ihn dann aber so richtig ein vor den Latz. Wir hören jetzt zum einen mal eine AfDlerin bei der Debatte zum kommunalen Vorkaufsrecht, das ja kürzlich gecancelt wurde und dann durch einen Antrag der Linken wiederkommen soll, wo sich eine AfDlerin so zu Wort meldet.
Und stoppen Sie mit uns die Migrationspolitik! Schützen Sie nicht nur Ihre Mieterklientel, schützen Sie bitte die gesamtdeutsche Bevölkerung!
So, das ist immer dieser Tenor, wenn die AfD zum Thema Wohnen auch jemanden vorschickt, der sich dann nochmal im Bundestag äußert. Jetzt sind wir, nachdem das jetzt ein Antrag der Linken war, jetzt sind wir, wo die AfD selber sagt, wir wollen jetzt das mal thematisieren. Problemaufschlag natürlich dieser.
Dass es in Deutschland zu wenig Wohnungen gibt, hat im Wesentlichen drei Gründe. Es ziehen immer mehr Menschen aus dem ländlichen Raum in die Ballungszentren und es gibt immer mehr Singlehaushalte. An diesen Fakten kann die Regierung wenig ändern. Der dritte Grund ist aber, dass wir in Deutschland jedes Jahr eine Nettozuwanderung von rund 500.000 Menschen haben. Das heißt, jedes Jahr müssen Wohnungen wie für eine Großstadt wie Dresden zusätzlich neu gebaut werden. Das Leibniz-Institut bestätigt, dass die jährlich rund 300.000 fertig gestellten Wohnungen allein schon für die Zuwanderung benötigt werden.
Und die Bevölkerungsgröße ist ja auch eine fixierte, wie der Bitcoin, und sonst würden da alles gleich bleiben, wir würden immer 80 Millionen sein, wenn nur keine Migranten kämen. Nee, dann würden wir auch noch viel mehr alt werden und weniger werden.
Vor allem, er steht ja da mit seinem eigenen Fraktionsantrag, den er begründen möchte, und er zählt irgendwas von 500.000 Nettozuwanderungen, die wir nicht haben. Wir kommen ja gerade mal so auf 200.000, 250.000. Das sind dann auch hauptsächlich alles EU-Bürger, oder Deutsche, die zurückkehren. Das fällt gar nicht so groß auf in irgendeiner volkswirtschaftlichen Rechnung. Die Leute arbeiten entweder vorher schon in Deutschland oder auch, da kommt niemand so richtig neu eigentlich. Wir hätten gerne 500.000 Nettozuwanderungen. Er stellt das aber als das große Problem hin und dann kommt die Antwort in dem Fall hier von Hagen Reinholdt von der FDP.
Herr Präsident, meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren, ich muss mich ein bisschen entschuldigen. Ich bin sehr müde heute. Die Plenum ging bis nach 22 Uhr gestern. Danach noch Sitzungen und so was. Es hat mich jetzt aber nicht, ehrlich gesagt, munter gerüttelt, als ich diesen Antrag gelesen hatte. Er las sich eher wie eingeschlafene Füße, muss ich feststellen. Und deshalb muss ich trotzdem dazu reden. Einwanderer nehmen uns die Wohnungen, wäre Klimaschutz völlig unnötig. Die ganze Welt bereitet sich auf die Klimawandelfolgen vor. Nur Deutschland muss das nicht, völlig unnötig. Ich frage mich manchmal, Herr Berndert, Sie sind ja kein Dummer. Wenn Sie da sitzen und Ihren Antrag schreiben und Ihre eigene Welt formulieren, muss ich noch manchmal auffällen, wie unschlüssig die eigentlich ist. Das traue ich Ihnen eigentlich zu. Und wenn man mal überlegt, seit 90 haben wir ein Wanderungssaldo von Nichtdeutschen von 7, 6 Millionen Bürgern ungefähr. Seit 1990, also Ihre Großstadtrechnung, egal. Hätten wir die nicht in Deutschland, ich bin mir sicher, ich wäre nicht unfallfrei heute im ÖPNV hierher gekommen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich mein Frühstück so hätte zu mir nehmen können, egal, ob das jetzt vegan oder aus Fleisch besteht. Da hätte ich auch fleißige Hände für gebraucht. Krankenhäuser, Pflegeheime, alles würde in sich sicherlich zusammenstürzen, wie im Kartenhaus. Sie haben recht, bei 76 Millionen Einwohnern hätten wir jetzt vielleicht keine angespannten Wohnungsmärkte. Dann würden wir hier über ganz andere Probleme heute diskutieren als über die Wohnungsnot. Und wenn ich was zu essen und zu trinken habe, aber nicht zu trinken habe, aber ein Dach über den Kopf, hilft mir das nicht weiter?
Ja, also die nehmen uns nicht die Wohnung weg, sondern die versorgen uns mit Infrastruktur. Und wir haben ja nun mal in Deutschland ein Land, das vor allem Dienstleistungssektoren aufbaut. Also wer hier einen neuen Arbeitsmarkt kommt, landet im Dienstleistungssektor. Und seit mehreren Jahren sind ja mehr als 50 Prozent der Menschen, die neue Arbeit aufnehmen in Deutschland, nicht Deutsche. Das ist ja auch die AfD kommt da immer wieder überraschend.
Ach echt, mehr als 50 Prozent. Es wird ja so sein im Dienstleistungssektor, also gerade das, was auch er da nennt und was uns einfällt, ist es ja so, dass die Löhne sehr niedrig sind. Das heißt, wir können davon ausgehen, dass sogar diese Leute auf besonders wenig Wohnraum leben.
Das kommt auch dazu.
Und wo die großen Räume verbraucht werden, das ist wo ganz anders. Und da sitzt dann vielleicht auch wieder die AfD-Wählerschaft.
Genau, also zu diesen Zahlen, wie eng wir in Deutschland eigentlich wohnen und wie das vor allem diejenigen betrifft, die hier neu wohnen in Deutschland, wären sehr viele, die seit 30 Jahren in ihrer Wohnung sind. Die Kinder sind schon ausgezogen und der Mann ist schon gestorben. Und trotzdem lebt man noch auf 200 Quadratmetern und so. Das ist ja auch ein riesen Problem. Anja Liebert von den Grünen antwortete hier auch nochmal. Und hier kann man auch mal die Mühlen oder die dicken Bretter nochmal sehen. Denn wenn die AfD Anträge schreibt, sitzen tatsächlich in den anderen Fraktionen Menschen da, Abgeordnete, und lesen diese Anträge dann einfach, um mal so ein paar Sätze daraus zu ziehen.
Und ich habe lange gesucht in Ihrem Antrag, ob es vielleicht einen bemerkenswerten Satz gibt. Und ich habe einen einzigen gefunden. Die Bauwirtschaft leidet zunehmend unter einem Mangel an Fachkräften. Das haben Sie richtig erkannt. Aber die Lösung und die Antwort ist auch Zuwanderung.
Also die AfD schreibt jetzt in ihre eigenen Anträge rein, dass wir einen Fachkräftemangel haben. Und die Lösung ist natürlich, kann ja nur sein, Zuwanderung. Welche andere Lösung soll es denn geben?
Ich hatte ja damals das AfD-Wahlprogramm mit Ole gelesen und das war interessant, dass die ja da schrieben, wir müssen hier die Flüchtlinge ausbilden im Handwerk, um sie dann nach Hause zu schicken in ihre Heimat, damit sie da alles aufbauen und wo man sagen muss, ja genau, aber die Bauwirtschaft braucht ja dringend mal Leute, die handwerklich tätig sein können. Absurd.
Das ist so diese japanische Rangehensweise, das sind alles nur Werksarbeiter, die machen hier nur kurz, die gehen dann wieder und so, dass es alles nur vorübergeht.
Ja und da ging es ja noch ein bisschen weiter, es sollte nur hier eine Ausbildung erfolgen, damit die dort aufbauen können, damit die Syrien aufbauen können.
Das ist ja Ethnop pluralismus, wir unterstützen sie bei ihrem Schicksal zu Hause.
Ihre Identität dort sein zu können.
Nun ist es aber alles ganz anders. Peter Tschentscher war zum Beispiel auch beim Wohnbautag eingeladen, wenn auch nur zugeschaltet, mit folgender überraschender Zahl, er Münzt sie auf Hamburg, sie gilt natürlich für ganz Deutschland.
Wir haben in Hamburg, in der Baubranche, 20 Prozent der Auszubildenden sind Flüchtlinge jetzt. Das sind diejenigen, die nicht in der dritten Generation bei uns leben, sondern die im Zusammenhang mit diesen großen Flüchtlingsbewegungen nach Deutschland, nach Hamburg gekommen sind. Dort bedarf es einer guten Integration, einer Sprachbildung, aber auch der Bereitschaft, diesen Menschen eine Bleibeperspektive zu geben. Und da bin ich froh, wenn da jetzt in der Union nicht mehr so ideologisch herangegangen wird, sondern wenn man einen Spurwechsel ermöglicht, wenn man sagt, Leute, die hier sind, die leistungsbereit sind, die wir auch dringend brauchen, und zwar nicht nur in der beruflichen Bildung, wir brauchen ja die Fachkräfte überall. Da ist es gut, wenn wir dort auch, was die Zuwanderung und die Anwerbung angeht, offen sind, eine internationale Sichtweise bekommen und die Leute dann auch zu uns finden.
Die Kriege auf der Welt sind Jungbrunnen für die westlichen Volkswirtschaften. 20 Prozent der Auszubildenden in Hamburg im Bauwesen sind Flüchtlinge, die 2015 zu uns kamen. Jetzt sagt die CDU immer, 2015 darf sich nicht wiederholen. Und alle in Hamburg, die irgendwas mit Bau zu tun haben und da Geld verdienen wollen, schlagen die Hände über den Kopf zusammen und sagen, können wir nicht 2017, 18, 19 nochmal so ein Jahr machen, damit wir mal hier unsere Auftragsbücher und so weiter perspektivisch abarbeiten können. Also das sind einfach, und so muss man, finde ich, auch jetzt auf die Ukraine schauen. Wer profitiert eigentlich davon, dass da so viele junge Menschen gerade das Land verlassen? Robert Habeck, der nun auch durch die aktuellen Kriege sehr im Fokus steht als Wirtschaftsminister, betont das hier auch nochmal, wenn wir jetzt 100 Milliarden locker machen für die Bundeswehr und dann nochmal so viel, haben wir ja gehört beim BDI, die wollen ja 680 Milliarden investieren und so weiter. Wie weit kommt man denn mit Geld, wenn man keine Menschen hat?
Wir haben es in allen Sektoren, aber vielleicht im besonderen Maße auch betroffen im Baubereich, dass wir einen eklatanten Mangel an Fachkräften haben. Heute, fresche Zahlen, haben wir in Deutschland 510.000 Stellen, die nicht besetzt sind. Der Großteil in Pflege, in Handwerk, Bauen und Wohnen und sonst in IT- bzw. elektrischen Berufen. Wir können politisch alles richtig machen und darüber werden wir uns noch streiten, was richtig machen bedeutet. Aber man unterstellt, wir machen alles richtig und wir haben genug Geld, das alles zu fördern. Wenn wir nicht genug Menschen haben, die dann auch bauen, dann werden wir gesellschaftlich und politisch scheitern. Deswegen muss das Anwerben von Fachkräften, die Attraktivität von Handwerk, deutlich gesteigert und gehoben werden.
Das ist Rentner Republic schon 2022. Nächstes Jahr geht es ja richtig los. Wir stellen fest, wir sind wahnsinnig reich, aber wir sind auch wahnsinnig arm. Und dann nützt uns der Reichtum eigentlich nichts.
Die Arbeiterlosigkeit kann dann noch schlimmer werden als die Arbeitslosigkeit.
Genau. Wir haben ja jetzt gerade einen leergefickten Arbeitsmarkt wie nie. Das habe ich ja gestern als letzten Clip noch mal in die Fernsehmomente so reingeschoben, während gleichzeitig gerade die größte Flüchtlingsbewegung wieder stattfindet. Also hier kann man auch leicht eins und eins zusammenzählen und sich die eine oder andere politische Frage stellen. Giffey, unsere neue Berliner Bürgermeisterin, diesen Clip will man am liebsten gar nicht zu Ende spielen, denn das ist diese Diffamierung der Jugend. Das ist unglaublich. Davon werden wir die kommenden Jahre auch noch mehr sehen.
Ich bin selber aus einer Handwerkerfamilie. Ich habe einen befreundeten Zimmermann, der mir erzählte, wie soll das eigentlich alles werden, wenn wir jetzt hier in Holzbau laufen und wenn das so richtig alles losgeht und so energetische Sanierung. Und dann sagt er mir, naja, weißt du, also meine Auszubildenden, die Hälfte, die ankommt, hat schon mal ein bisschen Probleme mit der Höhe. Also Sprichhöhenangst macht sich natürlich schlecht. Der eine Teil möchte gerne eigentlich lieber YouTuber werden. Auf dem Dach gleichzeitig YouTube ist nicht ganz immer so ungefährlich. Und dann gibt es noch die, die sagen, wo die Eltern vielleicht auch sagen, du weißt ja Handwerk an, nee, lass mal.
Studier mal lieber.
Studier mal lieber, ja, ist doch besser.
Und sie hat ja genau das gemacht. Sie stammt aus einer Handwerkerfamilie und ist jetzt ohne irgendeine Leistung zu erbringen. Die erste Frau von Berlin hat gefakt ihre Doktorarbeit. Sie ist genau diese Persönlichkeit und dann wirft sie jetzt Leuten vor, dass die lieber YouTuber werden als schlecht bezahlt irgendwo eine Ausbildung zu machen, wo sie dann von Boomer-Chefs noch irgendwie fertig gemacht werden, wenn sie ein bisschen Höhenangst haben. Also so Leute, die dürften in dem politischen Spektrum einfach nicht mehr stattfinden.
Also wir lesen das nächste Woche bei Mark Schieritz, Olaf Scholz. Wenn er sowas hört von seiner Parteimitgliedschaft, dann würde den rechts und links einer runterhauen. Respekt, ganz wichtiges Ding bei Olaf Scholz und dieser Verweis auf, ja, Akademiker, Schön und Guter, wir brauchen auch den Arbeiter, den Handwerker und so weiter. Also diese Förderung, die steckt da ganz tief drin. Aber eben über diese Respektschiene und nicht über so wie sie das hier macht. Also das ist keine versöhnliche Generationen Verständigung, die hier stattfindet. Naja, sehr interessant waren diese Aufarbeitung zu den Zahlen, wie wir in Deutschland leben und wie die das selber so finden. Also die lassen sich da als Verbände jedes Jahr so eine große Studie vorlegen, wo einfach der Sachstand, wie ist es in Deutschland, aufgeschlüsselt wird. Wir beginnen aber im Bundestag, als die Wohnungspolitik diskutiert wird. Karen Lai äußert sich.
Die Mieten sind in den letzten Jahren eskaliert. In Berlin ein Plus von 44 Prozent, Osnabrück 36 Prozent, München 32 Prozent. Das sind die aktuellen Zahlen aus meiner Anfrage. Und das alles in den letzten sechs Jahren, wo doch die Mietpreisbremse wirken sollte, das beweist, die Mietpreisbremse funktioniert nicht.
Bis zu 44 Prozent und dann diskutieren wir über 4 oder 5 Prozent Inflation.
Ja, also das ist im Buch auch eine ganz große Rolle, dass jetzt die Rentnerpublik so aufwacht, weil die Inflation mal über 2 Prozent ist. Während alle die neue Mietverträge, neue Kaufverträge und neue Arbeitsverträge, die das dann eben unterfüttern, unterschreiben, die seit 15 Jahren feststellen, also mein Lohn steigert nicht, aber jedes Mal, wenn ich umziehe, kostet meine Miete 11 Prozent mehr, 15 Prozent mehr und so weiter.
Und ich verdiene irgendwie gar nicht mehr. Wie kann das sein?
Genau, dass diese Inflation längst auf diesem Niveau da ist. Die Geldmenge sogar noch mehr erhöht wird, aber nicht da ankommt, wo sie da echt mal gebraucht wird. Naja, in dieser Studie, die hier vorgestellt wird von einem der Studienautor, klingt das jedenfalls alles sehr, sehr, sehr drastisch.
Sehr beschämende Thema ist, und das wirft auch einen Blick auf unsere Grundrisse, auf unsere Wohnungen, die zu Zeiten entstanden sind, als eben andere Bedürfnisse herrschten. Als wir in der unmittelbaren Nachkriegszeit sehr viel kleine Wohnungen schnell gebaut haben. Als wir in 60er Jahren Monostrukturen gebaut haben für die Vater-Mutter-Kind-Kind-Situation. Und im Grunde eben an vielen Bedarfen vorbei gebaut haben. Und das zeigt sich an einer sehr bestürzenden Zahl, wie wir finden, dass nämlich mittlerweile 8, 5 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland in überbelegten Wohnungen leben. Das heißt, zu wenig Räume für die dort lebenden Menschen, keine Kinderspielzimmer für kleine Kinder, keine getrennten Zimmer für ältere Kinder, die zwei Geschlechter oder was auch immer haben.
Zwei Geschlechter oder was auch immer?
Zu viele Funktionen in einem Raum, auch bei kleinen Wohnungen, auch bei kleinen Familien, kochen, wohnen, schlafen in einem Raum. Hygienische Mindeststandards, die unterschritten werden. Und das ist eben etwas, was zum einen als Ist-Situation tatsächlich beschämend ist, aber eben auch sich aufbaut. Es steigert sich immer mehr. Mittlerweile, Sie sehen die obere Kurve. Das ist die Lage in den Städten. 15 Prozent der Menschen, die in den Städten wohnen, insbesondere diejenigen, die sehr wenig Geld verdienen, haben das Problem, dass sie in einer überbelegten Wohnung leben.
1, 5 Millionen Menschen leben in überbelegten Wohnungen.
Und überbelebt meint ihr wirklich, Artikel 1 ist so langsam in Anklang zu bringen. Das ist unwürdig.
Also das schockiert mich jetzt auch nochmal. Man hat ja viel gelesen, aber das sind doch mal eine Zahl.
Ja, also diese Mietpreissteigerungen und so weiter. Irgendwo mündet es dann halt. Und klar, 15 Prozent, die so richtig unwürdig leben. Aber 80 Prozent, für 80 Prozent sind die Wohnpreise eigentlich zu hoch.
Die Rahmenbedingungen, die ja eben auch so ein bisschen in der ersten Teil der Gespräche an diesem Tag schon mitschwangen, für den Neubau sind schwierig geworden. Wir haben es gemeinsam letztlich geschafft, durch Normen, Vorschriften, Gesetze und all das, was wir so in den letzten 20 Jahren geschafft haben. Die Bauwerkskosten faktisch zu verdoppeln. Sie liegen mittlerweile auf 60 Indexpunkten über dem Lebenshaltungskosten, über der Teuerungsrate. Das macht das Bauen eben extrem schwierig. Und wenn wir uns dann angucken, was dann noch mit den Grundstückspreisen geschieht, das ist die orange Linie, die mittlerweile durch die Decke geht. Und bei 160 Indexpunkten liegt in den letzten 3-4 Jahren 34% Grundstückskostensteigerung über alle Regionen in Deutschland, sowohl in den Oberzentren, in den Metropolregionen, aber auch in den Unterzentren, in den Mittelzentren, wo es mittlerweile schwierig wird, bezahlbaren Wohnraum zu errichten. Und das Ganze führt dazu, dass wir derzeit ganz aktuelle Zahlen, letzte Woche ermittelt, derzeitige Kostenstand, Geschosswohnungsbau in den deutschen Städten. Wir bauen die Gebäude für 3.400 Euro, den Quadratmeter brutto. Und darauf kommen nochmal 860 Euro für das Grundstück umgelegt auf die Wohnfläche. Das heißt Summa summarum bauen wir im Medien den Geschosswohnungsbau für 4.200 Euro. Wer das baut und vermieten möchte, muss 13, 50 Euro, 14 Euro Kaltmiete verlangen, weil sonst geht er am Bestand, an diesen Wohnungen pleite. Das gilt für jede Genossenschaft, für jedes kommunale Wohnungsunternehmen, für jedes freie Wohnungsunternehmen, gleichgültig welcher Art. Er muss es verlangen und das ist eine Höhe der Miete, die sich mittlerweile 80 Prozent unserer Mieterinnen und Mieter einfach nicht mehr leisten können.
Wo sind die 100 Milliarden?
Genau, das ist reine Ideologie und da wird auch gar nicht diese Forderung gestellt. Da doktoren wir jetzt hier mit 60 Milliarden, da müssen es sieben Ausschüsse geben, bis man mal irgendwann sagt, die 60 Milliarden, die könnte man vielleicht auch noch verwenden, wenn man sie für Corona nicht gebraucht hat. Aber diese ganzen Forderungen kommen nicht. Und wenn das aus der Bevölkerung nicht kommt, und ich würde auch hier nochmal das ganz klar adressieren, an Fridays for Future und damit meine ich nicht die Spitze, die ist ja eher beschäftigt, Original Podcasts mit Felix Loprisch zu machen, sondern wirklich die Basis. Wenn die das nicht artikuliert, dann haben wir solche sozialen Verwerfungen auf Dauer, dass auch dann natürlich jeder zurecht sagt, mir geht der Klimawandel sonst wo vorbei und die brauchen wir auch nichts mehr von ökologischem Wohnen und Bauens erzählen. Ich lebe hier auf beängten Raum, nach mir die Sintflut. Ich werde jetzt noch tun, was ich kann, um einigermaßen die Zeit hier verbringen zu können. Also das wird ein Fiasco.
Genau, wir sind auch nicht aus altersgerechtem Wohnen vorbereitet. Das ist auch noch mal ein großer Punkt da gewesen. 80, 90 Prozent der Menschen leben einfach noch zu Hause. Wollen sie auch weiter? In deren große, große Bedarfe. Bei der Frage, wie wird das jetzt diskutiert? Es war sehr lustig, sich im Bundestag das mal anzuschauen.
Darf ich eine Sache einhaken mit diesem Wohnen im Alter? Das hat mich auch jetzt noch mal beschäftigt. Denn wenn man sich irgendwo auskennt in der Nachbarschaft, weiß man natürlich, wer da so wohnt etwa. Und gerade wo die großen Häuser sind, wohnen viele Leute, die vollkommen vereinsamt sind. Also da sind ja ganz viele Leute, die wohnen wirklich auf 150 oder 180, 200 Quadratmeter. Man ist schon lange gestorben. Die Kinder kommen da mal vorbei. Dann sieht man, da steht das Auto wieder vor der Tür. Da ist jetzt mal die Tochter da. Aber eigentlich ist das ja ein sehr trauriges Leben, weil das dann auch mit Ängsten verbunden ist. Dann regeln die die Türen siebenmal ab, weil ja irgendjemand kommen könnte, der einbricht und so. Und jetzt sind natürlich auch unsere Seniorenresidenzen nicht alle so, dass man da unbedingt leben will. Aber man hätte doch wahrscheinlich, und das ist jetzt fast schon was, was man eher dann in einem sozialistischeren Staat machen würde, oder in einem sozialistischen Staat machen würde, dass man einfach denkt, wie organisiert man eigentlich das Alter, also wenn man an einen Punkt angelangt ist, wo das für einen vielleicht selbst gar nicht so sinnvoll erscheint, mehr so zu leben, aber irgendwie die Alternative nicht da ist, weil man jetzt auch nicht sagt, ja, ich gehe ins Heim, das ist ja toll, weil so ist man dann auch nicht. Also man ist ja zum Beispiel nicht dement und so, aber dass man noch mal da in einer Siedlung leben kann, wo Apartmentstrukturen sind, wo man noch alles selbst machen kann, wo man aber vielleicht draußen wirklich mal jemanden trifft, mit dem man sich unterhalten kann, und wo nicht die drei Freunde, die im Umfeld waren, verstorben sind oder auch ziemlich immobil zu Hause rumsetzen.
Also ganz große Frage, das ist natürlich nur, wie soll man sagen, in ganz großen historischen Bögen. Also wenn man will, dass alte Menschen gut leben, und das tun sie nicht, wenn sie alleine für sich leben und so weiter, dann müsste man schon zwei Generationen vorher anfangen, vorbildhaft und politisch Programme auszutesten, damit dann irgendwann es total normal ist zu sagen, hör mal zu, ich bin jetzt 75, ich ziehe jetzt mal um.
In der DDR, meine ich, war das doch zumindest, dass Wohnungen dann auch sich verkleinerten wieder, oder? Wie war das?
Das weiß ich gar nicht, ob es da so, ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Lebenserwartung in der DDR so war, ob man das so groß planen musste. Jetzt haben wir ja mit 21 Jahren Rentenbezug zu tun. Also wahnsinnig viel. Und es sind halt alles Eigenheime, während man in der DDR ja gewohnt hat für 20 Mark. Dabei wieder einfach 20 Mark. Also das hat man dann einfach, dass man halt einfach umgezogen ist, von einer Wohnung in die andere. Heute klemmt man halt krass an diesem Eigentum. Und ich weiß nicht warum, das gibt es auch in keinem anderen europäischen Land in diesem Maße, in Italien vielleicht so ein bisschen, da ist die Eigentumsquote auch so hoch, dass die Familie dann immer sagt, nee, jetzt nochmal einen Umzug, das muten wir denen nicht zu. Und so weiter. Während das vom wissenschaftlichen Standpunkt aus das Beste ist, was man machen kann. Wir haben nochmal eine neue Nachbarschaft, keine Streitereien, vor 30 Jahren mit irgendjemand gehabt, sondern einfach jetzt geh ich raus, jetzt hab ich Spaß. Und dieses gemeinschaftliche Wohnen. Da ist ja Henning Scherff, der ehemalige Bremer Bürgermeister, ein ganz großer Verfechter davon, dass man im Alter nochmal ganz neu wohnt, die WG wieder für sich entdeckt und so weiter. In Deutschland ist diese totale Versingelung. Und das ist auch eine große Folge, das ist ja dann Niklas Markthema, einfach des Lobbyismus. Dass einfach die Bauwirtschaft kam und sagte, also Häuser müssen hier 400.000 Euro kosten oder mehr. Das Dach muss ganz teuer sein. Ich weiß, es geht nur um Regenabschutz und so. Aber das muss ein ganz teures Dach sein. Das muss auch überall in den Gesetzen stehen, wenn ein Haus baut. Das muss das teuerste Dach, das möglich ist, sein und so. Und so hat man ja unglaublich viel Geld daraus gezogen. Und eben gesagt, wenn ihr euch das leisten könnt, dann baut ihr euch ein ganz teures Haus. Aller anderen ist uns egal. Uns geht es nur darum, du bist halt derjenige, der es finanzieren kann. Einer der vier Verantwortlichen ist Ernak Ferlemann in der CDU. Und der bekommt hier eine ganz wunderbare Zwischenfrage von der linken Nicole Goelke.
Von Milieuschützsatzung halte ich allerdings nicht allzu viel, denn sie zementieren einen Zustand, der heute vielleicht noch gewünscht ist, in 10, in 20, vor allem in 30 Jahren völlig überholt sein kann. Warum soll die Mieterin im dritten Stock, die ältere Dame, nicht davon profitieren, dass es einen Fahrstuhl gibt, der eingebaut wird? Das ist einfach sinnhaft. Und wir werden es einer älter werdenden Bevölkerung noch erleben, dass wir das viel mehr diskutieren werden, als wir es vielleicht noch heute tun. Es gibt viele andere Dinge, ob Sie jetzt die Gebäude verändern wollen, was den ganzen Klimaschutz und anderes angeht.
Herr Kollege, erlauben Sie eine Zwischenfrage von der Linken?
Frau Präsidentin, vielen Dank, dass Sie die Zwischenfrage ermöglichen. Ich gebe zu, dass ich Sie bislang nicht kannte. Deswegen habe ich gerade gegoogelt und habe dann bei Wikipedia gefunden, dass Sie Geschäftsführer der Gesellschaft der Dr. Mingram Immobilienhandel, Unternehmensberatung, GmbH sind. Dann habe ich mich ganz kurz gefragt, ob Ihre Haltung, die Sie hier gerade vortragen und die sich übrigens eklatant unterscheidet von der Haltung Ihrer Unionskolleginnen und Kollegen in München, die dort in Verantwortung sind und die das Vorkaufsrecht gerne wieder zurück hätten, ob Ihre Haltung eventuell mit Ihren eigenen Interessen begründet sein könnte und ob es da vielleicht ein gewisser Interessenkonflikt sogar vorliegt, nicht im Interesse der Mieterinnen und Mieter handeln zu können.
Schönen Dank für Ihre freundliche Frage. Es wundert mich ein bisschen, dass Sie mich noch gar nicht kennen. Dann können Sie mit Verkehrsprojekten in den letzten Jahrzehnten ja nicht viel zu tun gehabt haben. Sonst würden Sie das wahrscheinlich wissen.
Ja, da ist auch mal ein neuer Wind.
Ganz genau. Ja, gut, dass man ihn bislang nicht kannte. Aber natürlich treibt er seine Politik. Das ist der meiner, der im OMR-Podcast sagt, es geht hier nicht um meine persönlichen privaten Vermögen. Es geht mir um die Mission. Und wir machen die Welt für alle ein bisschen besser. Und man macht die Welt für alle ein bisschen schlechter und profitiert prächtig davon.
Genau, dieses kommunale Vorkaufsrecht, was hier behandelt wird, weil die Linken das wieder haben wollen, bezieht sich ja, wir haben das ja in Ulm zum Beispiel besprochen. In Ulm kommt einfach die Gemeinde und sagt, ihr wollt hier Land verkaufen, dann verkauft ihr es an uns. Und wir verkaufen es dann weiter an die Familien nach Bedarf, aber nicht nach höchstbietend. Und die Ulmer hatten sich ja, wir haben es im August 2021 besprochen, die beziehen sich einfach auf Artikel 28 Grundgesetz. Den Gemeinden muss es recht gewährleistet sein, alle Angelegenheiten der örtlichen Gemeinschaft im Rahmen der Gesetze in eigener Verantwortung zu regeln. Was bedeutet, hier kann man durchaus mal die Marktwirtschaft aufheben, also das Prinzip des Höchstbietenden, der Versteigerung, wenn es eine Angelegenheit der örtlichen Gemeinschaft ist, hier einfach mal für Zustände zu sorgen, solange nicht Gesetze, im Rahmen der Gesetze dagegen sprechen. Also gibt es hier durchaus im Bundestag darüber zu diskutieren, ob man jetzt dieses Vorkaufsrecht hat oder nicht. Und jetzt hat sie ja angemerkt, selbst in München stellt die CDU fest, dass es hier ein echtes Problem gibt. Und die wollen das gerne ordentlich wieder haben. Die wollen dieses kommunale Recht der Gemeinden haben. Und ganz fern, also nicht nur regional, sondern auch sozusagen in der Stratifikation des politischen Betriebs steht einfach so ein Typ im Bundestag und hält ja so seine Lobbyistenrede. Und das sind schon Zustände in Deutschland. Da muss man auch echt nochmal sich fragen, warum hat der Bundestag überhaupt dazu zu entscheiden? Wenn die das in München machen wollen und sich da einig sind, warum dürfen die das nicht einfach? Weil es so schön ist, hören wir hier nochmal Jan-Marco Lutzak von der CDU. Und wir beide sehen einfach nur, wie Nicole Goelke im Plenum sitzt und leidet, während da die Typen quatschen.
Seit 2015 hat man über das Vorkaufsrecht in gemeintliches Eigentum überführt. 530 Millionen Euro hat man dafür ausgegeben. Und jetzt kann man ja mal rechnen. Was heißt denn das eigentlich? Das sind pro Wohnung 200.000 Euro fast. Wenn man jetzt mal davon ausgeht, eine Haushaltsgröße, die ist im Durchschnitt nur 1, 2, dann bedeutet das, wir haben 100.000 Euro pro Person ausgegeben. Steuergelder, die wir ausgegeben haben. Und jetzt frage ich mal, was hätte man mit diesem Geld eigentlich alles sonst noch machen können? Wie viele Belegungsrechte hätte man kaufen können? Wie viele Subjektförderung, höheres Wohngeld, hätte man machen können? Nur mal als Beispiel, 250 Euro pro Monat über 30 Jahre hätte man jemanden zahlen können. Und ich kann Ihnen sagen, damit hätte man wirklich Menschen geholfen.
Wir sprechen jetzt hier wirklich von einer Summe von 530 Millionen Euro. Da hat er genannt, das war der Betrag, 530 Millionen. Also wir haben 100 Milliarden jetzt für die Rüstung. An einem Tag locker gemacht und wollen noch da weitergehen mit dem NATO-2-Prozent-Ziel. Und wir reden jetzt über 530 Millionen und eine vollkommen absurde Rechnung, die daraus dann erfolgt und man hätte die Leute unterstützen können, wo man auch sagen muss, ja habt ihr ja auch nicht.
Ja, das ist einfach völlig absurd, dass das so diskutiert wird. Eins der großen Probleme ist eben diese Eigenheime, die ja jetzt nun auch in München, in Stuttgart und überall, die wird es nicht mehr geben auf dem Stadtgebiet, sondern da wird jetzt mal ordentlicher Geschosswohnungsbau gemacht. Und als ich diesen Clip hier von Peter Tschentscher beim Wohnungsbautag habe ich gesagt, wie er gedacht, das stimmt. Wir haben so unglaubliche Lobbyisten-Erfolge in Deutschland. Dieses Ein-Auto-für-Jeden und zwar ein möglichst großes. Alle Kosten da werden vergesellschaftet, haben wir ja gehört. Das kostet ja 5000 Euro pro Jahr. Einfach gesellschaftliche Kosten, die wir alle aufbringen, damit irgendwer mit seinem SUV rumfahren kann und beim Wohnen eben auch. Denn das ist ja dann auch, Miklas Maag sagt das ja immer wieder, wenn er öffentlich auftritt, dass wir wohnen, wie wir wohnen, hat ja nur damit zu tun, dass uns irgendwelche Lobbyisten das so aufgedrückt haben. Wir sind ja total unglücklich in diesen, klar, wir haben einen eigenen Zaun und die Nachbarn sind weit weg. Wir haben unsere Ruhe, nur das ist ja nicht so, wie wir leben wollen. Und das stellen nämlich auch die großstädtischen urbanen Zentren, Bürgermeister dann immer wieder fest. Es ist nicht verwunderlich, dass die da in München einfach sagen, ne, wir brauchen jetzt ein kommunales Vorkaufsrecht und wir wollen dann auch ein bisschen mitplanen und wir brauchen hier mal ein Geschossbau und ein bisschen enge und nicht nur einfach jeder hat sein eigenes Loft und so weiter. Peter Tschentscher hat das hier mal auf den Punkt gebracht und Giffey sagt dann, das gilt für Berlin auch.
Uns in Hamburg gilt es auch. Die eng bebauten, quirligen Stadtteile sind oft die, die dann am Ende auch noch die größte Beliebtheit haben bei den Menschen, weil es nicht immer so ist, dass viel Platz da bedeutet, dass dort man auch gerne lebt. Es gibt unterschiedliche Anforderungen und Interessen. Und deswegen gilt für Wien, für Hamburg, für viele Städte dort, wo es eng bebaut ist, wo es quirlig ist, wo es urban zugeht. Dort gibt es auch eine hohe Lebensqualität.
Es ist mir auch nicht erklärlich, wie man überhaupt auf die Idee kommen kann, Metropolen zu errichten und nicht in die Höhe bauen zu wollen. Das ist ja ein uraltes Thema 60er Jahre. Alexander Mitscherlich, der das schon aufgebracht hat. Auf dem Land wird der Geschossbau schwierig werden. Aber dass man das in einer Stadt nicht macht und man immer weiter irgendwie in die Breite ging und dachte, was hat man überhaupt dabei gedacht? Nee, man hat sich nichts dabei gedacht. Man hat tatsächlich diese kurzfristigen Lobbyinteressen befriedigt.
Wir hören zum Abschluss dieses Themas, das Energiepolitische und Energiewende. Das heben wir uns später auf, denn das wird wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen aktueller, als es jetzt gerade ist. David McWilliams in seinem Podcast, er ist ja dieser irische Ökonom, der immer mal wieder so ein bisschen für aufsehen, zumindest in meinem Podcatcher sorgt, und er hat es hier mal ganz wunderbar in 14 Sekunden runtergebrochen. Was ich im Buch ein bisschen ausführlicher mache, es gibt in Köln so einen Ökonom, der das mal durchgerechnet. Allein die Steigerung der Wohnkosten hat in den letzten elf Jahren 3 Billionen Euro von Mietern zu Vermietern umgelenkt. Also nur die Steigerung, wenn man die Referenzmiete 2011 so nimmt. Und wir wissen ja, dass da eine gewisse Generationenfrage mit verknüpft ist. Denn diejenigen, die die neuen Mietverträge unterschreiben, sind vor allem junge Menschen. Und die, die die Wohnung vermieten, sind nun mal in Deutschland 58 im Schnitt. Also überwiegend älter. Ungefähr 25 Jahre älter als ihre Mieter. Wir haben es also mit einer extremen Umschichtung zu tun. Und David Nathan Williams. Und ich wünsche mir das so sehr, dass es das auch mal in Deutschland irgendwie gibt. Dass irgendein Podcast das einfach mal immer wieder so betont. Auch so in Nachsätzen, dass man es einfach mal runterbricht.
Housing Inflation für eine jüngere Person hat einen dramatischen Impakt auf den Kosten des Lebens. Und konsequent ist das das Standard des Lebens. Whereas Housing Inflation für eine älteren Person macht sie sich eigentlich viel reicher.
Ja, wenn wir von Inflation sprechen, haben wir es mit einem Zustand zu tun, der die Jungen auszehrt, die Alten aber eigentlich reicher macht. Die sind gar nicht betroffen von Inflation. Die sind ja auf der Empfängerseite des Geldes.
Auf die Alten passen wir dann nach wie vor auf und lassen alles zu. Oder wir hätten gerne nochmal mit Lockdown und so weiter. Weil die ja sich auch dann noch nicht mal impfen lassen wollen, wo ich auch nochmal betonen würde, wer sich nicht impfen lässt. Das ist mir dann auch egal, das Schicksal desjenigen, der sich nicht impfen lässt. Wir haben es dann geschafft bei einer unglaublichen Zahl, ich muss die wirklich nochmal sagen, weil die mir gar nicht aus dem Kopf rausgibt, 8, 5 Millionen Menschen leben beengt, also zu eng, wie das eigentlich nicht sein sollte. Und wir haben es trotzdem geschafft, dass man immer wieder Lockdown und jetzt nochmal Homeschooling und so weiter gemacht hat. Es ist skandalös. Lass uns doch noch zum Abschluss jetzt, oder?
Ja, die letzten drei Clips liegen bereit.
Du hast die letzten drei Clips, gut, dann bin ich gespannt. Ich sehe schon was, okay.
Wir fangen an, das ist ein kleines Sammelsorium, weil die Bundeswehr gerade Thema ist und wir gerade die Generationenfragen ansprachen und überhaupt jetzt 100 Milliarden zur Verfügung stehen. Die Bundeswehr soll irgendwas machen, hat aber auch Personalnot. Jetzt ist ja eine Überlegung, und das ist schon vorher im Bundestag, am 16. thematisiert worden hier. Wir hören gleich den Parlamentarischen Staatssekretär der Verteidigung Thomas Hitschler. Er ist echt Hitschler. Muss gerade ein bisschen schmunzeln auch, aber gut. Und er bekommt die Frage, kann man nicht einfach die Soldaten ein bisschen länger arbeiten lassen? Das ist ja die allgemeine Diskussion. Längere Lebensarbeitszeit geht das nicht auch bei Soldaten. Wir wissen, wie bei der Bundeswehr agiert wird, nach Buch, nach Vorschrift, nach, wie man das halt so macht, ganz formaler Sprache. Und selten habe ich ein so amüsantes Stück Rentenrepublik serviert bekommen. Es gilt im Grunde für alle Organisationen der Arbeit in Deutschland, natürlich dann auch für die Bundeswehr. Und es klingt so.
Zusammenfassend ist klarzustellen, Frau Abgeordnete, dass eine querschnittliche Anhebung der Altersgrenzen in den Streitkräften keineswegs automatisch zur Erhöhung der personellen Einsatzbereitschaft führt. Eine mögliche Anhebung der Altersgrenzen würde zwar zunächst und kurzfristig den Personalbestand sowie den Grad der Dienstpostenbesetzung weiter erhöhen. Vakanten in hochspezialisierten und körperlich sehr anspruchsvollen Verwendungen wären dabei aber weiterhin absehbar, dahin besonders jüngeres und körperlich belastbares Personal benötigt wird. Eine Anhebung der Altersgrenze hätte außerdem eine Alterung des gesamten Personalkörpers zufolge und würde dem besonderen Aspekt der psychischen und physischen Anforderungen an den Soldatenberuf im Kontext der Einsatzbereitschaft der Streitkräfte in vielen Bereichen nicht gerecht. Durch längere Personalbindungen erfüre überdies das Bestandspersonal eine deutliche Attraktivitätsminderung durch Verwendungsstaus im Hinblick auf Förderung und der damit verbundenen Beförderung sowie geringe Übernahmequoten für Berufssoldaten.
Vielleicht könnte man den Clip mal an Marina Weisbandt senden, was sie denn dazu sagt.
Das ist doch ein sehr unhöflicher Umgang mit Opa in der Bundeswehr, muss man schon sagen.
Der Personalkörper, wann ist er noch attraktiv, wann ist er einsatzfähig, wann braucht man den jungen belastbaren Personalkörper?
Er sorgt für Verdroß, er will einfach nicht weggehen, er macht den Posten nicht frei, man kann nicht befördert werden, was ist denn das für ein Scheiß hier, ich dachte hier ist mal was, also tja, das ist Red Republik.
Aber vielleicht könnte man noch mal alles in dieser Sprache frameen, wie man heute sagt, und gucken, was dann passiert.
Ja genau, bei Lanz nur noch solche Texte runter nudeln.
Berlinale.
Clip Nummer zwei, Berlinale.
War ich in diesem Jahr nicht, weil ich mir sagte, das tue ich mir nicht an.
Sie ist nicht in Bern, also fahre ich nicht hin.
Genau, diesen ganzen Test, Wahnsinn und so, da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Wir gucken einen Ausschnitt der Tagesthemen am 10.2. ich dachte mir gleich, das bringe ich mit zu Wolfgang. Claudia Roth ist ja nun Kulturstaatssekretärin. Sie lobt das Kino über alles, wird dann aber je unterbrochen. Von der Moderation und von der Realität.
Und ich glaube, das ist noch mal eine Motivation zu sagen, wir Kinoliebhaber und Liebhaberinnen, wir lassen uns von der Corona den Film, das Kino, die Kultur nicht wegnehmen. Insofern ist es ein Ermutigungszeichen, ein Zeichen der Hoffnung und der Ermutigung. Und ich habe vorher mit dem Hauptdarsteller reden können von Peter von Kant, dem Film von Francois Ousson. Und er hat zu mir gesagt, das ist heute politisch. Heute ist es ein politisches Zeichen, weit über Berlin hinaus an die Welt zu sagen, Kunst und Kultur können wir uns nicht nur in guten Zeiten leisten.
Liebe Frau Roth, Entschuldigen Sie, dass ich Sie unterbreche, weil es geht doch vielen Kinobetreibern um die harten Maßnahmen, unter denen sie derzeit leiden. Sind Sie dafür, dass wir da sehr bald Öffnungsschritte bekommen werden? Denn nächste Woche treffen sich ja wieder Bund und Länder und dann wird man darüber reden, ob es 2G plus nicht mehr geben muss in den Kinosälen.
Ich bin dafür, dass auf der einen Seite die größtmögliche Sicherheit in einer Zeit, in der die Pandemie mitnichten vorbei ist, garantiert wird und zugleich Zugangsmöglichkeiten geschaffen werden.
Ja, ich bin jetzt auf 180. Sie ist wirklich eine Schwätzerin. Und ich halte auch die Personalentscheidung, dass sie da überhaupt mit der Kultur zu tun hat, für die dümmste Entscheidung sowieso. Ich habe sie auch gesehen, wie sie da mit Igor Levit über den roten Teppich ist. Das ist halt eine Kulturelite, die nur profitiert, egal welche Verhältnisse gerade sind und die sich natürlich für all die eigentliche Kultur in Deutschland überhaupt nicht interessiert. Diese Leute sollten abgesetzt werden und die haben überhaupt nichts verstanden. Und die Bundesregierung, die Alte wie die Neue, hat noch überhaupt nichts getan, um die Kinokultur zu stärken. Der Parkplatz ist immer halb leer, wenn ich ins Kino gehe und ich bin momentan zwei- dreimal die Woche im Kino. Es ist eine Katastrophe und wirklich ein Hohn, so ein Geschwätz da abzuliefern.
Letzter Clip. Wir sorgen für gute Laune. Ich höre derzeit sehr viele Podcasts, die sich mit irgendwas mit Liebe befassen. Beziehungsgestaltung, wie auch immer. Ich bin total überrascht, wie aufgeschlossen das in Deutschland ist. Ich stelle aber irgendwie fest, ja, das passt.
Eine Sache fällt mir gerade ein. Das muss ich noch mal losnehmen, weil sie mehrmals sagt, Zeichen, ein politisches Zeichen. Da sind, dass es genau die Hyperpolitik, die heute gemacht wird. Man verändert nicht die Situation. Man verändert nicht tatsächlich den Wohnungsbau. Man verändert nicht die Gehälter. Wir setzen ein Zeichen. Wir sagen, heute sind wir LGBT, morgen sind wir Ukraine. Und wir sind auch für das Kino. Die ganze Welt hört es von Berlin aus. Nein, die ganze Welt guckt nie nach Berlin.
Interessiert überhaupt nicht. Hauptsache, keine Budgetfragen stellen.
Aber wir wollen auf keinen Fall einen Euro den Kinobetreibern geben oder einfach mal diese verrückten Reglementierungen ausmachen. Die Kinos haben jetzt Personal eingestellt, das mit der Taschenlampe dasteht, meinen Impfausweis und meinen Personalausweis abscrennt. Dann gehe ich zum Eintritt, löse den da und kann nur als 2G-Plus-Mensch, also als Geboosterter, in den Saal, muss aber da die Maske drin tragen. Es sei denn, ich esse was, dann kann ich sie zum Essen abziehen. Dann will man nur Zeichen setzen. Das ist aber genauso hier die genannten Twitter-Leute, die dann auch die ganze Zeit Zeichen setzen.
Sie hat ja nun die Nachfrage bekommen, ich bin schon dafür, dass wir jetzt einfach post-Corona erklären fürs Kino. Leute wissen Bescheid, was Corona ist, wenn sich jemand schützen will, kann er sich schützen. Wir wissen, dass eine FFP2-Maske rundum schützt, zu 100% durch 3 Stunden. Wenn einer tragen will, trägt einer, und wenn nicht, dann nicht. Sie möchte größtmögliche Sicherheit. Es ist auch entspannt für alle, die unter diesen Situationen leiden, so wie du. Und es ist jetzt Frühling, wir spüren es hier auch gerade schon, wir haben es ganz offen, es ist einfach toll. Die Frage ist, wie nähert man sich den Menschen jetzt wieder an? Wir müssen es ja wieder lernen. Das Daten geht wieder los. Und ich stelle in diesem Podcast, den ich jetzt aber höre, fest. Ja, diese FDP, SPD, wie auch immer, neue Familienpolitik, die jetzt so entsteht, auch ein bisschen von den grünen Doktoren so mitgetragen. Die ist nicht ganz verkehrt. Menschen führen jetzt neue Leben und es beginnt beim Dating. Wo geht man am besten hin zum ersten Date? Ins Kino? Da ist dunkel, da ist laut, da kann man nicht gut sprechen. Geht man in ein Café? Da sitzt man sich so gegenüber, ist sich so richtig ausgeliefert. Was tut man? Man geht in die Natur. Wir hören eine kurze Empfehlung, ein Ausschnitt, Deutschlandfunk, eine Stunde Liebe, wo man sich jetzt, erklärt Erik Hegemann, am besten zum Dating trifft.
Ich glaube, die letzten zwei Jahre haben gezeigt, Spazierengehen ist echt eine gute Angelegenheit für das erste Kennenlernen. Und wir haben ja auch ganz viele Leute befragt und der Spaziergang ist wirklich sozusagen das Setting der Wahl für die meisten. Früher war es das Café, das gab es eine Zeit lang nicht. Ich glaube, es ist aber sinnvoll, tatsächlich mit dem Spaziergang zu beginnen. Wenn der gut war, kann ich immer noch in ein Café gehen. Aber bei der Bewegung fällt vielen Menschen das Gespräch leichter. Und außerdem sieht man neue Eindrücke, über die man dann auch wieder reden kann miteinander. Man erlebt gemeinsam etwas und ein Café ist weniger ein Erlebnis, als eben eine Art Bewerbungsgespräch. Und bei einem Bewerbungsgespräch, ist meine Vermutung, verliebe ich mich einfach nicht so sehr.
Und das meint nicht nur Spaziergang in der Natur, sondern auch in der Stadt. Ich bin ja großer Verfechter auch des Stadtspaziergangs. Nach Veranstaltungen einfach nach Hause gehen, auch wenn es eine Stunde dauert.
Die Schirrits-Anträge aus der Schweiz kommen, die Schweiz hat ja herrliche Seen. Da kann man auch wunderbar spazieren gehen. Ich bin gespannt.
Richtig, genau so ist es zu machen. Gut, wir lesen im Salon Kampf der Nation. Ich habe es noch nicht gelesen, du?
Ich auch noch nicht. Aber das ist, glaube ich, ein Buch, das wir jetzt schon direkt wieder einordnen können. Du bringst den Schirrits. Schirrits schreibt über Scholz mit. Schreibt über Scholz. Und ich bin erstaunt, dass du so begeistert bist.
Sag uns mal so.
Oder dass dich das gereizt hat, über Scholz was zu lesen. Und du jetzt sogar sagst, es ist sogar spannend, weil man das ja nicht direkt denkt.
Und das ist genau der Punkt. Es ist wahnsinnig anregend. Denn wir haben ja ansonsten nur diese Biografie, die dieser Chefredakteur des Hamburger Abendblatt oder so geschrieben hat, der dann selber in Kulturzeit im Gespräch sagte, naja, so viel gab es eigentlich nicht zu erzählen. Und jetzt haben wir aber mit einem Wirtschaftsredakteur, der Olaf Scholz eben auch beruflich einfach so begleitet hat durch seine Finanzministerzeit, also er ist sehr überraschend auch in diesen Posten gekommen, uns dann doch noch mal die großen Linien aufzieht. Ich finde, ein bisschen zu lobhudelnd geschrieben. Also man hätte bei Cum-Ex und so, trage dann die Zitate vor, es ist wahrscheinlich alles gut begründet und so, Aufregung ein bisschen groß. Aber ich finde, man hätte da noch ein bisschen härter rangehen können. Ansonsten eine sehr wohlwollende und aufschlussreiche, also selten so ein aufschlussreiches Buch irgendwie gelesen, wo einfach noch mal was erklärt wird, was man jetzt auch wissen sollte, finde ich. Denn der Typ ist jetzt einfach unser Bundeskanzler und so. Da kann man, also das wird ganz interessant, glaube ich.
Und die kürzeren Texte, da legst du dich noch nicht fest. Ich mich auch noch nicht.
Genau, ich gucke jetzt nicht nach im Handy. Ich habe ein paar zurechtgelegt. New York Times hat noch mal große Aufarbeitungen. So, das ist ja echt geiles Zeug.
Da kann es ja auch noch mal viel tun jetzt in fünf Tagen. Ich habe auch schon ein paar in der Pipeline. Was ich auch besprechen möchte, ist ein Buch einer amerikanischen Philosophin. Das heißt, das Recht auf Sex, ein Plädoyer für einen neuen Feminismus. Und der offenbar dieses Recht auf Sex sich einfordert oder so. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich werde morgen mit der Lektüre beginnen. Es wird schon heiß diskutiert. Und die anderen Texte, da schaue ich mal, was dann kommt. Ich will noch ein Detail, weil wir ja auch ein bisschen den Zeitgeist abbilden müssen, noch mal herausstellen. Ist dir eigentlich aufgefallen? Und ich würde sagen, das passiert so seit zwei Jahren. Also mit den Neuen Zwanzigern, wie sie begonnen haben. Dass Aussagen, die man trifft, ja schon mal eine Bestätigung brauen, dass man sagt, genau, oder früher hätte man vielleicht gesagt.
Stimmt, da hast du absolut recht, Wolfgang.
Und was passiert heute? Wie antwortet man heute, wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, ja, wir müssen jetzt dringend mehr in ökologisches Bauen investieren? Wie würdest du dann als junger Mensch oder als Zeitgeist-Mensch darauf antworten?
Keine Ahnung, würde ich sagen.
Voll.
Ja, man sagt voll.
Aber mit dem Sound.
Voll.
Das habe ich von meiner Tochter jetzt noch nicht so im Ohr. Sie sagt immer du schlau. Ich weiß nicht.
Das ist bestimmt was ganz Junges. Aber wenn man irgendwo bei Veranstaltungen irgendwas sagt, mit Leuten noch danach redet, dann kommt immer voll.
Ja, voll. Ich meine, das Coolste, was die Amerikaner immer so, was ich so fand, ist, wenn man sie da, also dieses bestätigende, ja klar, was hast du gedacht, Captain Obvious, aber jetzt kommt immer du schlau. Ach so, die Butter steht schon auf dem Tisch. Also es ist verrückte Sprache.
Vielleicht können wir aber doch mal wieder lieber gewiss sagen als voll.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, da bist du auch ganz falsch.
Aber das voll klingt auch komisch. Naja, achtet mal drauf und vielleicht kann man es ja mal weglassen.